les syndicats vont-ils transformés
laissés combien de personnes descendront
dans la rue et en cas de succès le
gouvernement a-t-il la moindre chance de
faire marche arrière nous avons des
questions et à la fin de l'après-midi
nous aurons sans doute des réponses
bonjour et bienvenue nous suivons on
dirait que cette deuxième journée de
grève la manifestation à Paris doit
s'élancer d'une mit à l'autre et nous la
suivront avec l'ensemble des
journalistes du Figaro bonjour
Marie-Cécile
adjoint au service économie du Figaro
j'ai plein de questions pour vous mais
d'abord on se rend dans la manifestation
bonjour Timothée d'ellem vous êtes Place
d'Italie tiens donnez-nous le parcours
de cette manifestation et puis le
dispositif mis en place cet après-midi
pour contenir de potentiels débordements
oui bonjour Thibault bonjour à tous
voilà vous le voyez nous sommes ici au
bout de à l'angle en fait entre l'avenue
des Gobelins et le boulevard du
Port-Royal c'est ici que la
manifestation va s'élancer d'ici
quelques minutes vous le voyez sur ces
images de Julien Leclerc une
mobilisation qui pourrait être
historique aujourd'hui entre 1 et 1,2
millions de personnes sont attendues par
tout en France ça ce sont les prévisions
du ministère de l'Intérieur à Paris et
bien ce sont entre 80 000 et 100 000
personnes qui devraient défiler dans les
rues de la capitale aujourd'hui c'est
ici donc que le cortège devrait
s'élancer d'ici quelques minutes je vous
le disais vous me demandiez le parcours
Thibault le parcours qui va donc
emprunter cet avenue des Gobelins que
vous voyez juste juste derrière moi le
cortège prendra ensuite la direction sur
la gauche du boulevard du Port-Royal
juste ici et ensuite le boulevard de
Montparnasse en direction du boulevard
des Invalides pour rejoindre la place
Vauban dans le 7e arrondissement de la
capitale un cortège près de 5 km donc et
la préfecture de police et bien qu'il a
prévenu la circulation qui évidemment
est fortement perturbée dans ce dans ce
périmètre il est recommandé évidemment
aux automobilistes et bien de contourner
très largement le secteur le temps de la
manifestation les manifestants
seront-ils aussi nombreux que lors de la
précédente journée de mobilisation le 19
janvier c'est l'une des questions de
l'après-midi l'un des enjeux également
c'est cette mobilisation des jeunes
puisqu'on le sait les lycéens et les
étudiants devraient se joindre également
au cortège cet après-midi jusqu'ici ils
étaient plutôt en retrait de la
mobilisation contre cette réforme des
retraites mais il pourrait bien suivre
les appels à la mobilisation des
nombreux syndicats et puis un petit mot
sur le dispositif de sécurité qui est
important de la croiser beaucoup de CRS
beaucoup également de gendarmes mobiles
ici du côté de la place Bovo et bien ce
sont pas moins de 100000 de 11000 pardon
policiers et gendarmes qui sont mob
réalisé partout en France c'est 1000
policiers et gendarmes de plus qu'il y a
10 jours d'après Gérald Darmanin et dans
les rues de la capitale et bien les
forces de l'ordre ne sont pas moins de
4000 aujourd'hui pour encadrer le
cortège qui devrait débuter d'ici
quelques minutes ici merci merci
Timothée Timothée avec Julien Leclerc on
vous suit tout l'après-midi nous sommes
aussi en direct avec Vincent roseron
bonjour Vincent vous êtes vous aussi
Place d'Italie et bah tiens ma question
les images que vous nous proposez vont
vont y répondre est-ce qu'il y a des
personnalités politiques des figures
autour de vous
[Musique]
et bien oui effectivement il y a des
personnalités politiques comme vous
pouvez voir sur ces images alors je me
trouve entre les gobelins et la place
d'Italie je vais vous montrer rapidement
voilà sur ce côté là là vous voyez la
place d'Italie qui est derrière moi avec
tout le cortège syndical habituel et
donc le compteur et là vous pouvez voir
les ballons là-bas de de Sud par exemple
de la CFTC qui sont là-bas et de l'autre
côté alors là on sait comme si la manif
a commencé mais elle l'a pas encore
débuté plus sur le parcours vous voyez
le stand de la France insoumise qui est
ici et vous pouvez le voir juste devant
moi c'est Alexis Corbière qui est
présent pour cette manifestation tout
comme de nombreux élus de la France
insoumise
Eric Coquerel tout près avec son écharpe
bleu blanc rouge
Marie-Cécile revient vers vous on va
parler technique notamment ce qui change
pour sur cette réforme pour les femmes
mais d'abord ce qui se passe sous nos
yeux acte 2 c'est un moment décisif
voilà on se retrouve comme il y a 12
jours avec un peu les mêmes images alors
on a déménagé le 19 janvier on était
rive droite entre la Place de la
République et la nation là on est rive
gauche entre le la place de la place
d'Italie dans le 13e
voilà j'ai l'impression comme ça en
regardant les images que ça a l'air
peut-être un peu moins dense
de la République alors c'est peut-être
les lieux qui qui donnent cette
impression voilà donc un parcours qui
valait du 13e au 7e arrondissement près
du ministère de la Santé
alors c'est vrai que la semaine il y a
12 jours on avait été frappé par une
mobilisation que personne n'avait prévu
aussi importante il y avait plus d'un
millions de de personnes dans la rue
finalement c'est à la fois alors les
syndicats ont surfé sur ce succès de
mobilisation inattendue mais finalement
c'est peut-être aussi un piège parce que
s'ils font moins cette fois-ci on va
dire le mouvement c'est souffle le fait
d'être parti avec une barre très haut
d'avoir mis la barre très haut dès la
première journée de mobilisation
finalement ça leur met la pression pour
faire aussi bien sinon mieux sinon on va
dire que voilà le mouvement s'essouffle
et que la contestation ne prend pas dans
la durée je salue le petit poussin sur
Youtube Arnaud également vous n'hésitez
pas vous réagissez je transmets vos
questions Lulu sur Le Figaro.fr on passe
l'après-midi ensemble qu'est-ce qu'il
s'est passé dans ces 12 jours est-ce
qu'on veut il y a eu encore des
négociations ou non tout est gelé on ne
parle plus entre syndicats et
gouvernement non bien sûr il y a des
discussions il y a eu aussi des
discussions entre les syndicats parce
que
suite à cette ce succès de mobilisation
de il y a 12 jours certains syndicats
comme force ouvrières ou la CGT voulait
battre le faire tant que tant qu'il est
chaud vous voulez continuer surfer sur
le sur la vague ne pas laisser le
soufflet retomber et d'autres comme la
CFDT vous les plus être dans la maîtrise
du mouvement ne pas se laisser déborder
et bien canaliser les l'énergie et
prévoir des manifestations ponctuelles
des grandes journées un certain se sont
plants mais qu'est-ce qu'on attend un
million 200000 personnes dans la rue et
on attend 12 jours qu'est-ce qu'on fait
certains sont posés cette question toute
la question de la stratégie des
syndicats avec surtout pour eux la
nécessité de rester unis de ne pas
rompre ce front syndical uni qui fait
finalement leur force
mais donc il faut il faut bien sûr
affûter les stratégies et se mettre
d'accord
bon Laurent Berger disait que qu'il
avait
pardon le patron de la CFDT il sait
qu'il avait gagné 30% d'adhérents sur le
mois de janvier et même une accélération
à plus de avec un gain de 50% sur les
dernières semaines donc
il avait l'air d'être satisfait de son
côté la CGT mais la pression aussi parce
qu'elles sont congrès en mars donc voilà
il y a une forme de surenchère aussi du
côté de la CGT vous avez vu Marie-Cécile
je vous coupe un instant on avait
l'impression sur un autre plan que la
place d'Italie était plutôt vide et sur
celui-ci que c'est assez rempli vous
voyez la petite différence bon oui alors
là le cortège effectivement
à s'avancer sur les chiffres on va voir
les images qui progressivement nous
parviennent mais
je crois la semaine il y a
bonjour
se faire entendre dans un instant il
suit les chiffres de très près et
apparemment c'était mieux ce matin en
région est-ce qu'on a de nouveau
secteurs qui sont entrés dans la dans la
danse est-ce que le privé est en grève
aujourd'hui parce que les spécialistes
dont vous la semaine dernière me disait
si le privé entre en grève ça peut être
un vrai changement alors le privé ne
semble pas vraiment complètement se
mobiliser bien sûr il y a des salariés
du privé qui qui manifestent mais le
privé ne bouge pas en masse il faut dire
qu'en période d'inflation et de pouvoir
d'achat la préoccupation des salariés
c'est le salaire en fin de mois plus que
la réforme des retraites
on retrouve là dans les dans les
grévistes les secteurs traditionnels
alors l'éducation la semaine dernière
était très mobilisée c'est toujours le
cas avec la moitié des enseignants
grévistes selon les syn pas parmi les
professeurs de la maternelle au lycée un
quart selon le ministère dans le métro
c'était plutôt mieux que le 19 janvier
aujourd'hui ça circulé plutôt mieux avec
la ligne une et 14 qui sont automatiques
qui a le fonctionnait normalement et
certaines lignes qui fonctionnaient ce
matin oui pour l'instant c'est à dire
qu'on est à la fois sur les chiffres
qu'on attend qu'on voit tomber petit à
petit des régions qui semblent un peu
plus haut mais ce matin par exemple dans
les transports moins de moins de grève
apparemment bon la fonction publique
reste mobilisée le 19 janvier il y avait
eu 28,5% de grévistes voilà
chez Total énergie oui la mobilisation
est forte dans les raffineries et les
dépôts de carburant mais selon la
direction le taux de grévise serait de
55% contre 65% le 19 janvier
voilà non mais comme on le disait votre
porter le la grande la vraie inconnue la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
la capacité à mobilité des syndicats à
mobiliser la jeunesse je rappelle que la
zone A va être en vacances ce weekend et
certaines organisations de jeunesse on
va parler dans un instant parce que ça
peut faire la différence je vous coupe
Marie Cécile parce que vous voyez en bas
de l'écran à droite
Eric Coquerel est avec Vincent roseron
Vincent tiens posez-lui la question
Eric Coquerel lors de cette petite
interview est-ce que les jeunes sont
mobilisés aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors je vais lui demander bonjour
monsieur le Coquerel merci d'être avec
nous député de la France insoumise
aujourd'hui est-ce que les jeunes sont
mobilisés avec vous en tout cas plus
encore que le 19 voilà donc c'est ça
c'est un des phénomènes aujourd'hui
qu'on observe un peu partout c'est que
il y a de plus en plus de jeunes dans le
mouvement tout comme d'ailleurs il y a
de plus en plus de grévis tout comme il
y a plus en plus de manifestations et ce
qui fait qu'on peut annoncer sans se
tromper que cette journée sera plus
importante encore que la journée déjà
historique du 19 janvier il y avait 2
millions de personnes sur mon syndicat
un million une selon les autorités vous
selon vous là déjà on peut déjà dire que
c'est que c'est au dessus ouais ça va
être au-dessus mais surtout je voudrais
insister sur le fait que c'est aussi des
secteurs qui se mobilisent et qui se
mettent en grève qu'il avait pas fait
depuis très longtemps vous savez on
était dans des mouvements de grève par
procuration et là ce à quoi on assiste
c'est des secteurs privés de petites
boîtes dans des petites villes qui se
mettent en grève c'est ça à mon avis qui
est le le signe de souvent et qui
d'ailleurs peut être l'amener à la
victoire tout à l'heure on parlait des
jeunes c'est ce qui peut faire vraiment
la différence lors de cette
manifestation
parce qu'on sait que quand il y a
jeunesse plus souvent social
c'est-à-dire au bout d'un moment
incontrôlable pour un gouvernement donc
c'est ça qui peut se passer aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
attendez qu'elle se sur quoi ça va
déboucher à votre avis tout ça sur le
retrait plus récemment de ce projet de
loi voilà c'est déjà arrivé dans la 5e
République que la démocratie sociale
l'emporte parce que manifestement ce qui
se passe ici c'est que ça matérialise le
fait qu'il y a une écrasante majorité de
Français et quasiment la totalité des
actifs contre un projet de loi et un
gouvernement il peut pas comme ça
imposer un projet à tout un peuple voilà
c'est pas arrivé pendant la Cinquième
République ou quasiment pas et je vois
pas pourquoi ça arriverait avec Monsieur
Macron ce projet doit être retiré c'est
à mon avis non seulement nécessaire d'un
point de vue social mais même d'un point
de vue démocratique oui parce que il y
aura l'Assemblée nationale et ça va
jouer là-dessus et là c'est pas sûr que
ce que ce que ça y passe mais avec la
macronie et leurs alliés alors ils ont
de plus en plus de problèmes vous avez
raison ils utilisent d'ailleurs des
moyens non démocratiques pour la poser
on n'a jamais vu le projet de loi de
cette ampleur passé par un projet de loi
de finance de la sécurité sociale
rectificative qui normalement est fait
pour travailler aux marges ou actualiser
un projet de loi là grâce à ça ça fait
que par exemple il y a plein
d'amendements qu'on peut pas déposer ça
fait que ils peuvent se priver du vote
on va nous priver du vote plus
exactement donc ils essaient de passer
en force mais je pense que tout ça me
suffira pas comment ça se passe à la
commission des finances sur ce sur
ce projet de loi justement bah écoutez
on a on essaie de j'essaye de contribuer
à éclairer par les arguments
nos concitoyens j'ai déjà fait en sorte
d'auditionner le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites je crois qu'on a
suffisamment parlé puisqu'il avait
rappelé je le rappelle encore une fois
que les dépenses de retraite non
seulement n'augmente pas mais qu'elles
vont stabiliser même baisser donc toute
la question c'est les ressources et nous
les ressources on dit bah ils existent
notamment dans les revenus du capital
mais pas que créer de l'emploi aussi et
aussi de faire en sorte que la
commission des finances s'empare de
sujets qui évidemment évidemment
financier c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
voilà on joue aussi un rôle d'éducation
populaire très bien merci beaucoup
monsieur Coquerel comme vous avez pu le
voir derrière moi Thibault la
manifestation est partie les gens
commencent à descendre depuis la place
d'Italie vers les gobelins qui est juste
à côté visiblement ça part plus vite que
la semaine dernière où il y avait eu
embouteillage sur la place de la
République rappelle pierre-y Coquerel et
président de la commission des finances
oui dans la Cécile
Eric Coquerel sur ce rapport du corps
donc on en parle très souvent de ce
rapport du corps et n'importe quoi au
rapport du corps et là donnez-nous la
vérité
Eric Coquerel et malin il sait très bien
il parle des dépenses
effectivement les dépenses de retraite
ne vont pas augmenter parce que comme on
a sous indexé les retraits des pensions
des retraités les dépenses ne vont pas
augmenter mais vous savez bien que dans
votre porte-monnaie il y a les dépenses
et il y a les recettes le problème c'est
que ça des recherches et donc il y a
bien un problème de soldes et les gens
sont très malins qui utilisent le
rapport du corps en prenant ce qui va
dans leur sens mais le corps dit bien
montre graphique à la pluie qui a un
problème de sol c'est-à-dire ce qui
reste dans les caisses des dépenses
n'ont pas mais les recettes baissent
donc il manque de l'argent c'est clair
c'est très clair
non mais faut être précis et c'est fait
à dessin souvent les gens savent très
bien mais ne disent qu'une partie de la
vérité vous parliez de cette date là de
vacances
euh on voit bien tout l'intérêt des
syndicats et des et des partis
politiques de de
coaguler les luttes et de faire
descendre la jeunesse dans la rue avec
bon en plus les vacances qui commencent
le weekend prochain pour la zone a pour
l'instant franchement on peut pas dire
qu'il y a une mobilisation massive des
jeunes que les organisations de jeunesse
soient présentes certes mais ne
confondons pas ces organisations qui
sont somme toutes assez peu
représentatives et les jeunes en général
qui pour beaucoup se concentrent sur
leurs études sur parcoursup qui les
stress en ce moment et qui ont de toute
façon pensent qu'ils n'auront pas de
retraite alors que c'est un tort cette
réforme elle est fait justement pour que
nos jeunes aient une retraite et
continuent je lis ce que nous dit Arnaud
sur Youtube les jeunes se mobilisent
mais la retraite c'est dans 40 ans mais
Garanderie qui nous dit au contraire
cette réforme est nécessaire voilà ce
qu'on nous dit sur Youtube je salue
Bovary également qui est avec nous
Timothée delhem vous êtes avec une
manifestante me semble-t-il
est-ce qu'elle y croit est-ce qu'elle
pense que le gouvernement peut reculer
j'imagine que oui si elle est dans la
rue aujourd'hui
on va le lui demander Thibault juste un
petit mot pour commencer vous le voyez
le cortège qui commence à s'élancer là
au début du boulevard du Port-Royal vous
le voyez quelques drapeaux et donc le
mouvement qui commence à s'élancer avec
quelques minutes de retard mais il faut
dire qu'il y a beaucoup de monde cet
après-midi je suis vous le disiez avec
une manifestante Séverine professeur de
mathématiques en région parisienne à
Paris est-ce que vous y croyez est-ce
que vous pensez que le gouvernement doit
et peut reculer sur cette réforme des
retraites oui tout à fait c'est pas
possible que tout le monde puis continue
à travailler jusqu'à 64 ans le
gouvernement doit reculer et il reculera
ça je vous le promets pour quelle raison
manifestez-vous aujourd'hui pour quelle
raison pensez-vous que le gouvernement
doit retirer son projet de loi sur la
réforme des retraites alors je manifeste
aujourd'hui pour la retraite de manière
à ce que tout le monde puisse avoir une
retraite et puisse partir décemment dans
de bonnes conditions à la retraite en
bonne santé bonne condition financière
et se manifeste également pour la non
fermeture des 7 lisses et parisiens
prévues à la rentrée 2023 dont mon lycée
le lycée professionnel Charles de Gaulle
situé dans le 20e arrondissement il y a
eu des concertations depuis la campagne
présidentielle depuis les propositions
d'Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne il
a revu sa copie sur certains points il a
dit-il en tout cas écouté les syndicats
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est enfin
vous semblez dire que ça n'est pas
suffisant pour quelle raison
de fait quand on dit 64 ans non
négociable par Madame borne la première
ministre là déjà ça c'est pas possible
il y a une inconnue également
aujourd'hui c'est la mobilisation des
jeunes vous êtes vous-même professeur de
mathématiques est-ce que vous avez
croisé des jeunes est-ce que vous avez
discuté peut-être avec certains de vos
étudiants est-ce que vous pensez que les
jeunes en tous les cas seront mobilisés
cet après-midi oui tout à fait parce que
les les jeunes là ils sont en train de
se dire qu'ils vont travailler jusqu'à
70 ans minimum on pouce à faire des
études 5 6 7 8 ans d'études qui ne sont
pas pris en compte dans le temps de
calcul de la retraite et ça c'est pas
acceptable pour eux certains de vos
étudiants vous ont confié qu'ils
allaient se rendre à la manifestation
oui tout à fait un dernier mot peut-être
sur cette pancarte je veux vous êtes
venus voilà avec ces quelques mots qu'on
va montrer sur ces images de Julien de
Julien Leclerc quel est le sens de ce
que vous avez écrit de ce que vous allez
porter pendant toute l'après-midi mais
sauver le lit chez Charles de Gaulle non
contre la fermeture de ce lycée
professionnel situé derrière le Père
Lachaise et aussi sauver les retraites
des enseignants des aesh et des surtout
des élèves voilà merci beaucoup et
Thibault je vous le disais le cortège
qui vient de s'élancer vous le voyez
derrière moi ce mouvement qui est parti
ça y est en direction du boulevard du
Port-Royal
une sorte de convergence d'élite là on
le manifeste pas que pour la retraite
c'est très frappant moi il y a deux
choses qui me qui m'interpellent dans ce
que dit cette professeur de
mathématiques d'une part manifeste pour
les retraites mais aussi pour contre la
fermeture de ce lycée professionnel
Charles de Gaulle donc on voit et son
cas est symptomatique il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui manifestent pour les
retraites mais aussi contre d'autres
irritants contre le gouvernement des
petites contre le gouvernement mais pour
contre l'inflation contre le la hausse
des prix contre voilà le la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat contre aussi on a
beaucoup parlé des petites villes de
province qui s'étaient mobilisées il y a
aussi ce sentiment d'insécurité ce
sentiment de perte d'identité il y a un
mal plus profond au delà des retraites
enfin dont les retraites sont le
révélateur finalement et donc il y a une
[Musique]
cet objet des retraites permet de de
manifester contre des tas d'irritants et
coagulent des des raisons très très
variées très très diverses finalement et
une deuxième chose me frappe dans son
discours c'est qu'elle dit elle
manifeste pour pouvoir à partir dans des
conditions financières décentes pour
de santé mais ce qui m'interpelle c'est
des conditions de financière décentes
mais justement la réforme des retraites
sans réforme des retraites les pensions
seront misérables seront et on fait
cette réforme des retraites pour pouvoir
continuer à assurer dans aux générations
futures des pensions telles qu'on les
connaît aujourd'hui c'est pour maintenir
ce niveau de pension donc les jeunes
cette réforme elle est faite aussi pour
eux pour leur assurer notre niveau de
protection sociale pour le maintenir et
pour sauver notre système par
répartition donc il y a une forme de
paradoxe dans ce qu'elle dit voilà c'est
ce qui me frappait François sur Youtube
10000 personnes à Auch ce matin il a
l'air visiblement pour la réforme parce
qu'il dit que tout pour la retrait de la
réforme ce qui dit que tout le monde
doit se mobiliser Marie Cécile explique
et moi la polémique sur les femmes
c'est compliqué parce qu'à la base on
nous dit gouvernement nous dit cette
réforme et plus juste pour tout le monde
et ensuite Premier ministre c'était sur
le Figaro life Franck Riester en charge
des relations avec le Parlement nous dit
qu'en fait certaines femmes vont être
pénalisées lesquelles et pourquoi j'ai
besoin que vous soyez pédagogue parce
que pour tout vous dire je comprends pas
et je suis sûr que bon nombre
d'internautes ne comprennent pas non
plus quel est la situation sur certaines
phares
il y a s'il vous plaît les femmes et il
y a une sous-partie des femmes qui sont
les mères celles qui ont des enfants
voilà les mamans alors pour les femmes
modestes qui ont des carrières hachées
qui ont des petites pensions la réforme
est plutôt favorable c'est vrai le
gouvernement a raison pourquoi parce que
elles vont bénéficier en priorité de la
revalorisation des petites pensions à
85% du SMIC c'est elle qui sont visées
après il y a un sujet sur les maires de
famille est-ce que vous savez que les
femmes les mères peuvent avoir des
trimestres qui leur sont attribués quand
elles ont des enfants on a les mères ont
trimestre par enfant dans le privé et
quatre dans le public c'est une des
rares fois où le privé est plus
avantageux que le public mais avec le
recul de l'âge de départ puisque
aujourd'hui vous devez aller jusqu'à 64
ans une partie pas toute une partie de
62 ans
avec la nouvelle réforme
et bien certaines femmes qui ont des
carrières complètes qui ont tout leur
trimestres qui ont toujours travaillé
qui ont eu des enfants perdre en quelque
sorte le bénéfice de ces trimestres qui
ne leur servent plus à rien par exemple
une femme avec trois enfants qui
pouvaient partir à 62 ans à taux plein
devra travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
finalement elle aura trop de trimestres
elle sera ce qu'on appelle surcotisante
en fait elle aura des trimestres qui lui
servent à rien ça durait de cotisations
lui permettrait de partir à 62 ans ou 63
mettons mais comme l'âge de départ légal
et augmenter à 64 ans sera obligé
d'attendre 64 ans et faire des
trimestres en plus cotisés en plus vous
avez tout compris c'est pas si dur que
ça non finalement bon alors quels sont
les solutions parce que j'imagine qu'il
y a des négociations
soit imaginer que bah ces femmes qui ont
des trimestres en trop pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle les donneraient pas au père qui
lui n'a pas ses TRIMA supplémentaire et
qui pourrait en avoir besoin pour
atteindre son taux plein sauf que pour
tous les enfants qui sont nés avant 2010
les trimestres ne peuvent pas être
partagés entre les parents tout va à la
mer depuis 2010 où l'effet des lois
parité il est possible que la moitié des
trimestres soit cédée au Père selon le
choix des
parentsales de papa
c'est vraiment lié à la maternité c'est
le fait d'avoir un enfant qui donne des
trimestres il y a quatre il y a une
partie des trimestres qui sont liées à
la maternité cela il reste acquis à la
mer et il y a une partie l'autre moitié
des trimestres qui est au titre de
l'éducation et c'est cette partie qui
peut être partagée entre le père et la
mer donner complètement au père ou gardé
par après pour les enfants d'après 2010
sauf que beaucoup de gens ne le savent
pas et il faut se décider avant les
quatre ans de l'enfant donc il faut
mentionner cette ce choix avant les
prendre l'enfant beaucoup de gens ne le
savent pas en réalité les gouvernements
ont fait ça un peu par obligation avec
la parité qui s'est installé dans les
mœurs mais l'idée était souvent des gens
qui sont assez jeunes donc assez loin de
la retraite donc on y pense pas
forcément donc ça c'est là ça a été mis
en place les sous l'impact des lois
parité mais comme les femmes ont quand
même des pensions moins importantes
moins importantes que les hommes le
gouvernement on n'a pas trop fait la
publicité de cette mesure l'idée étant
de ne pas dépouiller les femmes de leur
de leur avantage
les hommes peuvent donner enfin peuvent
récupérer les trimestres de leurs femmes
il faudrait autre solution n'est pas
possible mais ça pourrait être une
solution mais qui risque d'être coûteuse
parce que les hommes ont des salaires
supérieurs et donc donner des trimestres
bon ça aurait un coût important l'autre
solution ce serait de dire bon ben
finalement les femmes ont leur donne des
trimestres parce que elles sont
pénalisées dans leur carrière
professionnelle et donc finalement dans
leur salaire elles sont ralenties
donc ça gagne moins bien on pourrait
leur donner un petit bonus valoriser ces
trimestre donner un petit accélérateur
pour la pansement enfin une espèce de
surcote alors non mais ce sont deux
mesures coûteuses et puis surtout en
fait cette histoire des trimestres c'est
ça concerne essentiellement les femmes
qui ont des carrières complètes
donc ils sont plutôt
des cadres CSP plus parce que les femmes
plus modestes ont souvent s'arrêtent
plus souvent en plus souvent des
carrières hachées et donc comprenez bien
que la femme cadre CSP plus c'est pas
forcément celle que le gouvernement veut
privilégier et voilà donc c'est un sujet
un sujet qui est sensible quand même
parce que nous sommes dans une une
période de démographie en berne nous
avons le niveau de naissance le plus bas
depuis 1945 ce sont les derniers
chiffres de l'Insee donc la natalité
c'est très important et c'est encore
plus important
elle permet en plus de financer les
pas répartition les naissances c'est
essentiel donc voyez il y a une forme
d'injonction contradictoire sur le
gouvernement qui n'est pas simple à
résoudre bon on va ces images d'Italie
avec la manifestation qui vient de
s'élancer à quoi ça sert tout ça
honnêtement tout ça pourquoi est-ce que
le gouvernement peut reculer avec à
cause de ces manifestations alors bon il
y a toujours des manifestations à toutes
les réformes des retraites j'ai repris
les dates en 95 plus de trois semaines
de transport paralysé 2003 1 à 2
millions de manifestants 2007 train et
métro à l'arrêt 2010 manifestation
massive raffinerie bloquée il y avait eu
quoi entre 1,2 et 3 millions 5 de
manifestants au pic de la mobilisation
le 12 octobre 2010 et en 2017
café et en 2019 je vous rappelle en
décembre 2019 il y avait eu entre 800
000 et 1 million et demi de personnes le
manifestant et la réforme avait été
votée avec le 49-3 mais en première
lecture et sans le covid probablement
qu'elle aurait été adoptée voilà donc
c'est il y a toujours des manifestations
des mobilisations importantes
avec des manifestations importantes les
politiques ne reculent plus c'est ça que
vous me dites franchement Emmanuel
Macron comme Elisabeth borne ont dit les
64 ans c'est voilà on peut pas reculer
on peut pas toucher ils tiennent la
barre fermement je vous rappelle que la
France est un pays qui a 3000 milliards
de dettes que si on continue à
s'endetter comme ça on risque on risque
de ne plus pouvoir continuer à emprunter
à des taux qui vont augmenter et donc ça
va mettre un vrai problème des
d'équations des finances publiques et il
y a aussi un problème responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
ça fait des années j'allais dire des
mois mais non des années qu'on s'engage
à réformer à remettre nos finances
publiques d'équerre et il y a une
attente très forte de nos partenaires
européens on est pas seul la France on
est à interconnecté avec nos partenaires
européens et
pragmatique merci beaucoup merci de
m'avoir accompagné la triste en chef
adjointe au service économique du Figaro
merci d'avoir lancé ce live avec nous on
va voir Timothée delaime Timothée la
manif et lancez ça y est
absolument Thibault la manifestation est
lancée vous le voyez sur ces images de
Julien Leclerc le cortège qui s'est
élancé il y a quelques minutes
maintenant là nous nous trouvons sur le
boulevard de Port-Royal à quelques
quelques mètres donc de la place
d'Italie ou le rassemblement est fixé à
14h et je me trouve avec et bien une
élue d'Arcueil conseillère municipal
membre du parti de la gauche
républicaine et socialiste bonjour
madame pourquoi c'est important pour
vous d'être là aujourd'hui
c'est important parce que la gauche
républicaine et socialiste est engagée
dans les défenses des valeurs de la
République tout simplement et là la
réforme des retraites proposées par le
président Macron et parfaitement
inacceptable puisque c'est une grosse
réaction sociale c'était un recul de nos
valeurs et de nos engagements et c'est
un mépris du combat de nos anciens qui
qui nous avait permis d'avoir des des
services sociaux des services municipaux
toutes sortes d'aide aux gens surtout de
pouvoir vieillir après des années de
travail de pouvoir les lire
tranquillement et là c'est toute façon
c'est inadmissible pour en mettre tout
ça en place surtout que c'est pas
nécessaire vous êtes venus à plusieurs
vous êtes en train de tracter
précisément depuis tout à l'heure
dites-nous un petit peu monde on va
peut-être montrer un tract à la caméra
et dites-nous un petit peu de quoi il
s'agit il s'agit simplement de quelques
valeurs que nous défendons on a fait un
petit résumé en fait parce que
notre programme est beaucoup plus
important par exemple une école une
écrasante majorité de Français rejettent
la rotation sociale comme je vous ai dit
tous les syndicats salariés sont unis
contre ce projet ça on l'a vu
Macron arrive à ce que tous les
syndicats soient d'accord c'est une
performance extraordinaire qu'on
attendait depuis longtemps merci
Monsieur Macron il n'y a pas de facilité
des pays maintiennent l'âge de 62 ans
donc pourquoi pas nous surtout que notre
système actuellement n'est pas en danger
ça sera peut-être dans 15 ans mais dans
15 ans ça sera passé des choses est-ce
que vous pensez que cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui va mobiliser du monde on
le sait la manifestation du 19 janvier
était un succès pour les syndicats
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura
autant de monde aujourd'hui alors
sincèrement j'espère que ça sera
beaucoup plus et j'ai eu quelques
remontées de provinces ou il y avait
effectivement plus de manifs plus de
monde beaucoup plus de monde combien de
personnes vous espérez aujourd'hui à
partir de combien de personnes on peut
dire que c'est un succès
qu'on arrive à 3 millions 3 millions
dans toute la France
de loi du gouvernement n'est pas retiré
quelle sera la suite du mouvement pour
en tous les cas la gauche républicaine
socialiste nous serons tous les combats
on ira jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire que
dès qu'il y aura une manifestation des
engagements on sera présent voilà
Thibault pour cette élu d'Arcueil dans
la région
Île-de-France et le cortège vous le
voyez qui continue d'avancer sur ce
boulevard du Port-Royal avec des slogans
avec beaucoup de pancartes beaucoup de
panneaux que vous envoyez d'ailleurs une
juste ici sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc le boulevard qui n'est pas noir
de monde mais quand même assez rempli et
surtout qui s'étend sur de nombreux
mètres vous le vous le voyez derrière le
début de la manifestation sous le soleil
parisien merci Timothée vous regardez
les pancartes parce que j'aime beaucoup
ça moi vous savez Christophe le bon
petit slogan ah ça c'est l'une des
attractions des manifestations
Christophe
là où ils ont véritablement eu un angle
mort euh où ils ont été très surpris
c'est sur les petites et moyennes
communes juste pour mémoire j'avais noté
il y avait
à trois il y avait 5000 personnes c'est
pas grand chose mais à Digne il y avait
10000 personnes à Limoges 10000
personnes à Verdun 1000 personnes à
Guéret dans la Creuse 5000 bref tout cet
agrégat de petite de petites villes ça
va être ça a été vu et alors ce qui est
amusant enfin en tout cas ce qui est ce
qui est à noter c'est que on aurait pu
croire que c'était un coup d'essai et là
j'ai eu des sources qui me disaient que
ce phénomène d'enracinement de la
cristallisation de la colère dans les
replis du territoire dans la profondeur
de la France ne fait que s'accentuer
encore ce ce aujourd'hui dans la mesure
où il y a des parce qu'il y a les
premiers chiffres de ce matin voilà
des forces de l'ordre et le ministère de
l'intérieur c'est encore trop mal les
services de renseignement puisque on
nous annonce entre un million et un
million 200000 hein ce qui
correspondrait à ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière est-ce que ce matin sur
les premiers chiffres dans les villes on
est en hausse on est en baisse on est en
hausse très largement
trois exemples on va prendre Marseille
par exemple alors là j'ai à Marseille
donc les syndicats donnent la CGT dit
000 personnes à Marseille versus
245 en le 19
55000 le 19 chiffres janvier 6 syndicats
de police Christophe une dépêche qui
vient nous tomber les syndicats
l'intersyndicats l'annonce une
mobilisation en hausse voilà ce qui nous
disent on n'a pas les chiffres pour
l'instant mais c'est ce que nous dit des
syndicats les chiffres polis à Marseille
et ça confirme là d'ailleurs la 7e c'est
confirmé complètement par la police pour
l'instant
et pour Marseille par exemple les
policiers à s'attendaient à Marseille
du matin à 25 30 000 personnes maximum
Rome et en fait ils ont eu un décompte
qui vient de nous être rendu et on est à
40000 donc on est presque le double
presque ces deux fois la prévision
pareil pour Nice Nice on était à la
semaine dernière on était à 15 20 000 et
là on sera plutôt à 25 30 000
les syndicats 80% partout comme ça
c'est-à-dire que si on poursuit la
courbe
on peut arriver on peut arriver ce soir
à des syndicats qui nous annoncent 2
millions voir 2 millions et demi de
personnes dans les rues sans que ça
trouble véritablement le public bon nous
verrons mais nous verrons donc ces
chiffres qui avaient été sous-estimés un
petit peu le 19 janvier on vous a parlé
des des petites villes je vous ai lu
votre article ce matin que vous pouvez
retrouver d'ailleurs sur le Figaro.fr si
vous ne regardez le ministère de
l'intérieur c'est que ce sera une
mobilisation forte mais ne s'attend pas
au grand soir ce serait quoi le
un soir pour bobo ah bah le grand soir
pour Beauvau c'est c'est le scénario
catastrophe ou ou la manifestation des
vis et tourne au chaos donc ça peut
prendre des formes assez assez
variés et qu'on avait vu une question de
nombre c'est une question de question
d'intensité de la violence d'accord et
d'intentionnalité des casseurs c'est à
dire que pas sur le le nombre de
personnes on est sur les dégâts causés
par ces manifestations c'est le grand
soir ce serait une une entreprise de la
rue visant à déstabiliser l'état donc
concrètement
on y était pas mais on peut y penser par
exemple au gilet jaune quand ils étaient
à l'Arc de Triomphe
les gilets jaunes qui
avaient notamment aussi tenté de marcher
sur l'Elysée des manifestations qui se
solltent par 15 15 à 20 000
interpellations comme on l'avait vu il y
a deux trois ans voilà c'est vraiment
des des schémas un peu de naturationnel
là on n'est pas du tout dans ce dans ce
cadre-là pour qu'on y arrive il faudrait
que les notamment que les que les les
groupuscules les plus radicaux passe à
l'action d'accord et ce qu'il semble
s'être passé ces derniers jours c'est
que il y a eu alors est-ce qu'on peut
employer le mode de connivence certains
l'emploi ou en tout cas de de d'entente
passer entre les organisations
traditionnelles et les groupuscules
c'est possible dans la mesure où
notamment dans les des services
spécialisés on laisse entendre que les
les syndicats avaient passé un message
notamment au groupuscules d'ultra gauche
de ne pas venir
perturber cette cette
manifestation de masse là que l'on voit
quitte à ce que après bon bah après les
Ultra gauche reprennent la main vous
allez m'expliquer tout ça je vous donne
les chiffres à Nantes la préfecture
annonce 28 000 manifestants ils étaient
25000 il y a 10 jours
ose légère mais hausse quand même on va
voir Vincent roseron est-ce que Vincent
roseron nous reçoit j'ai l'impression
que son image est figée on essaiera de
le retrouver tout à l'heure
c'est quand même chiffré énorme parce
que moi j'avais pas de son chiffre ouais
parce que il faut quand même se souvenir
quand qu'en 2000 en 2019 ils étaient
15000 donc à la à la réforme de la
retraite du décembre 2019 sur la réforme
des de la retraite à point qui a été
avorté
ils étaient je retrouve les chiffres là
ils étaient à peine en 2010 contre la
loi verte donc dire que là si on est à
l'âge de départ
62 ans à l'époque voilà c'est ça dire
que là on est multiplié par 3 quand même
non il est très impressionnant vous avez
l'impression alors quels sont les moyens
de police déployés aujourd'hui en France
et à Paris avec Christophe alors
si on peut ou prouler même que pendant
l'acte 1 du 19 janvier
la jauge de 1000 hommes on avait 10000
hommes
et policiers qui étaient déployés à peu
près sur le sur le sur les sites de
manifestations là on sera à 11000
d'accord donc 4000 à donc 4000 à Paris
sachant que ces hommes là c'est
uniquement des experts du maintien de
l'ordre c'est donc des des gens des
unités mobiles
CRS et escadron et qui sont épaulés par
les brigades anti criminalité les braves
j'ai une image à vous montrer Christophe
je voudrais qu'on la commente ensemble
c'est Timothée de Lem et cette cette
image est-ce que ce sont ces gens qui
sont considérés comme des casseurs des
Black Blocs des groupes radicaux
ça me correspondre là entre me Soignies
cette image oui ça ça ça rappelle un peu
ce qu'on appelle les les le système de
barrière rigide c'est à dire
c'est des c'est une barrières derrière
laquelle peuvent se dissimuler des
casseurs potentiels
pour après passer à l'action et c'est
une barrière finalement qui leur sert de
bouclier quand il passe quand il
s'affrontent les forces de l'ordre vous
m'expliquer la semaine dernière c'est
bâche rigide c'est ça c'est les fameuses
bâches rigides en fait donc ça permet de
d'éviter d'éviter les d'éviter les
d'éviter notamment que les de recevoir
des grenades etc donc une espèce de
bouclier en géant et puis par ailleurs
ça permet aux gens qui sont derrière de
s'organiser de deux sites de se
désilluer notamment pour changer
d'allure avant de passer à l'action oui
on va écouter ce qui se passe sur place
les Christophe ont continué à parler de
cette image qui peut paraître un peu
inquiétante évidemment on écoute on
écoute ce qu'ils disent
[Musique]
si tu veux je peux faire du pack là
dessus
[Musique]
voilà pour ces pour ces images on va
essayer d'avoir Timothée Delem qui dans
un instant qui voulait nous raconter ce
qui est de ce qu'il voyait oui cette
fameux décilhouétage c'est ça
expliquez-moi les techniques alors en
fait évidemment pas de conseils
mais en fait en gros il faut bien
comprendre que les que les
que les les le Black Bloc ça on le
répétera jamais assez le Black Bloc ce
ne sont pas des gens c'est un mode
opératoire et dans ce mode opérateur
j'ai tendance à dire et je vous ai dit
est-ce que ce sont des Black Blocs non
est-ce que c'est un black bloc voilà ça
black bloc en fait c'est une méthode
d'action de rue pour pour passer à la
violence pour faire dévisser une une
manifestation le BlackBox ne peut
exister que s'il y a une masse critique
c'est-à-dire que on ne peut déployer un
Black Box que dans des manifestations
nombreuses d'accord s'il y a très peu de
gens ben c'est compliqué parce qu'après
on peut pas se cacher dans la dans le
défilé c'est difficile et donc la
stratégie est simple c'est qu'il y a
deux choses il y a une stratégie dite de
recomposition perpétuelle c'est-à-dire
que les recompositions perpétuelles
c'est avec les protagonistes du Black
Bloc vont par petit groupe
harceler les forces de l'ordre casser
une agence bancaire ou un magasin après
ce retourner dans le cortège repartir
sous une autre forme donc il se
recompose 5 accords qui se recompose en
permanence et puis qui se dessilhouette
donc dire que ils sont en tenue
la baignoire et il se renoient dans la
masse pour passer inaperçu il laisse
tout sur le champ de bataille les les
objets les barres de fer etc et il
s'évanouissent dans la nature j'ai lu
que place Beauvau considérée qu'il
aurait potentiellement 2000 à 3000
émeutiers
sont ces gens est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
un effet d'entraînement c'est à dire
Vincent roseron par exemple qui est sur
place dans la manifestation le point en
l'air se dit tiens moi je manifeste
contre la réforme des retraites et en
voyant je sais pas 2003
mais 23000 personnes en train de se
battre contre les forces de l'ordre en
train de casser une banque peuvent
entrer dans la danse alors bien sûr
qu'il peut y avoir un phénomène de
mimétisme mais il faut quand même faut
quand même faire attention au fait que
ne pas prenons l'exemple de Rennes par
exemple le 19 janvier dernier c'est le
seul ville où il y a eu des incidents
notables d'accord en France il y a eu
des Black Blocs donc un black bloc qui
s'est formé avec un black bloc qui s'est
formé avec
des policiers qui ont été prises à parti
avec des voitures qui ont été incendiées
des des magasins qui ont des vitrines de
magasin qui ont été brisés et en fait là
ce qui s'est passé c'est que
tout ça s'est passé sous les hués en
fait des manifestants traditionnels
parce que il faut bien comprendre qu'à
partir du moment où une manifestation
est entachée par de la violence sa
disqualifie et ça ça brouille le message
bien sûr et on parle que de ça
oui et d'ailleurs et vous vous souvenez
les les Thibault des gilets jaunes
bien sûr qu'il n'arrivait pas à se
défaire de ces problèmes de violence au
point que il y en a qui se disait de
guerlas qu'ils allaient verser eux aussi
dans la violence et c'est ce qui a donné
après les Ultra jaunes mais globalement
en tout cas dans des manifestations on
va dire de nature syndicale et bien
encadrées il est assez peu probable que
les que les manifestants se mêlent au
casseurs je fais un détour par la place
d'Italie peut-être ce cortège a avancé
Vincent roseron vous êtes sur place vous
étiez dans la manifestation de 19
janvier est-ce que selon vous
une première impressions il y a plus de
monde qu'il y a 12 jours
[Musique]
pour l'instant c'est pas grave on reste
ensemble en plateau Christophe et je
vous promets on aura de Vincent roseron
notre envoyé spécial sur place la bonne
surprise du 19 vous me parliez de ces
incident à Rennes mais c'est quand même
qu'il y a eu quasiment aucun incident on
va pas se mentir il y a eu très peu de
choses c'était presque inattendu
pourquoi ça ne s'est pas embraser on
avait l'impression qu'on ne savait plus
faire une manifestation en France sans
que ça effectivement en fait on va pas
dire c'était la divine surprise mais
considérons quand même que
le soir Place Beauvau ou à la préfecture
de police de Paris les responsables ont
plutôt poussé un ouf de soulagement
vient de dire hormis Rennes il y avait
eu 227 cortèges à travers la France donc
drainant plus d'un million de personnes
et il s'est absolument rien passé
pourquoi pour je pense
deux raisons principales la première
c'est que on est et il faut on est dans
une manifestation encadrée par des
centrales syndicales donc des
professionnels de la rue on m'a souvent
parlé des gros bras de la CGT voilà des
services de des services d'ordre de la
de la CGT ou même d'autres d'autres
syndicats qui sont
reconnaissant le assez dissuasif
j'aime bien
j'ai eu à les connaître pour manifester
avec eux enfin couvrir des
manifestations où ils étaient il y a des
anciens dockers il y a des anciens
ou des gens qui travaillent dans la
manutention donc de très très gros
gabarits qui sont assez bien organisés
qui sont reliés entre eux et qui peuvent
ramener le calme la même parfois ou la
police a du mal à le faire donc je pense
que ça c'est le premier élément le
second élément est et aussi
lié au fait que il n'y a pas que
il n'y a pas que des que des
professionnels justement de la
manifestation il y a des il y a des
familles il y a des il y a des cadres
à changer il y a des gens on dit dans
les prestations
on est on est dans une France qui a
largement dépassé les limes les
frontières du des syndicats des partis
politiques et donc on est vers ce cette
France qui qui veut s'exprimer alors
c'est pas forcément la France des
déclassés même si dans les petites et
moyennes villes c'est celle que c'est
celle qui est descendu dans la rue vous
avez vu il y a quelques instants
Timothée de Lem à l'image on vous
retrouve Timothée on a vu des gens se
cachaient derrière une bâche noire
avait-il des intentions violentes
[Musique]
difficile à ce stade de le dire Thibault
ce qui est sûr c'est que vous l'avez vu
comme moi sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc certains ici défilent
effectivement avec des cagoule noir avec
également une banderole noire des
fumigène noir et violet également à
l'instant ils ont donné un champ siamo
tout petit fascisme nous sommes tous
antifasciste disait-il vous le voyez sur
ces images de Julien Leclerc beaucoup de
journalistes évidemment qui sont là pour
prendre des photos pour couvrir cet
événement pour l'instant à ce stade dans
tous les cas pas de débordement mais
c'est vrai qu'on sent une certaine
tension on voit vous le voyez peut-être
d'ailleurs les gens ici qui se sont un
petit peu arrêtés de défiler qui
regardent c'est une dizaine de
d'individus qui effectivement
semble voilà dans une atmosphère en tous
les cas assez tendu on voit les gens qui
regardent qui savent pas trop ce qui se
passe nous les premiers d'ailleurs pour
pour ne rien vous cacher on continue
évidemment de regarder ce qu'il se passe
le cortège là qui sait un petit peu
arrêté en tous les cas au niveau où nous
nous trouvons et quelques chants à
nouveau qui sont entonnés juste derrière
nous par ces manifestants cagoulés tout
de noir vêtus un Timothée est-ce que
vous voyez des forces de l'ordre autour
de vous est-ce qu'ils sont proches prêts
à réagir toujours avec leur calot ou
est-ce qu'ils ont enfilé leur casque par
exemple ou justement non on se tient
loin pour ne pas agiter la la colère et
l'attention
et à venir passer en cours alors c'est
ça qui est assez surprenant
effectivement Thibault on va avancer un
petit peu parce que le cortège vient et
bien de reprendre vous entendez les
champs derrière nous pas de force de
l'ordre effectivement vous le voyez
d'ailleurs sur ces images pas de
policiers de CRS ou de gendarmes mobiles
à cette à cet endroit là pour l'instant
il faut dire que les choses se passent
sans de s'en débordement il n'y a pas eu
de en tous les cas nous n'avons pas
observé de mouvements de violence
simplement d'ambiance un petit peu
tendue vous voyez cette cette banderole
et c'est manifestants et avec ce visage
plutôt fermé le regard un peu noir voilà
mais à ce stade dans tous les cas pas de
force de l'ordre sur place pas de
débordement non plus
merci Timothée faites attention à vous
et
vide best of
tiens quoi là manifestation n'avait pas
dégénéré la semaine dernière est-ce que
à Paris
on peut accorder cela à Laurent Nunez le
nouveau préfet de police on parlait
d'une nouvelle doctrine après
l'élection de Didier l'allemand l'ancien
préfet qui était très critiqué sur ces
questions alors je pense pas qu'on
puisse parler à proprement on peut pas
parler de nouvelles doctrines c'est pas
le c'est pas le logo ils disent non non
surtout pas je suis dans la continuité
etc mais moi je me suis entretenu avec
le préfet Nunes que je connais vraiment
très bien depuis de longues années non
non vraiment qui est un pour le coup un
vrai technicien parce que il a lui il a
eu à connaître le la ville il était
secrétaire d'État il était directeur de
cabinet du préfet de police il y a une
dizaine d'années
c'est un spécialiste des questions de
renseignement et puis là il a il a eu à
gérer des des mouvements dans le public
absolument majeurs en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est que il y a pas
de méthode Nunes pour le coup en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que dans la mesure
où les manifestations sont encadrés la
police fait toujours la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'elle se met hors des
regards aller dans les rues adjacentes
parce que c'est intéressant parce que
j'ai découvert moi beaucoup de
manifestations notamment les gilets
jaunes où il y avait des fils de CRS et
c'était on ne pouvait pas sortir ni à
droite ni à gauche ça n'existe plus ces
deux techniques différentes parce que
chez les gilets jaunes il n'y a pas de
service d'ordre d'un comme dans les
syndicats donc les polices s'appellent
ce qu'on appelle ce que vous avez vécu
ça s'appelle flan garder flan Garden
plan garder voilà il y a de chaque côté
de l'endroit flamant gauche il y a un
cordon qui essaye de faire ce que font
les services d'ordre en fait des
syndicats vu que c'était gilets jaunes
ils avaient rien donc voilà donc ils
vont ils sont obligés d'aller au contact
mais en revanche là dans la mesure où on
est sur des sur des manifestations avec
des syndicats qui comme la fait observer
hier Gérald Darmanin qui vous l'avez
observé n'est pas l'étranger
c'était l'une de mes questions juste de
l'intérieur est en France
à la différence de l'acte 1 ils étaient
en Espagne avec le président de la
République et 12 min exactement
là comme l'a dit hier Gérald Darmanin en
fait le les syndicats jouent le jeu
c'est à dire que les services d'ordre
sont présents ils communiquent
parfaitement que les forces de l'ordre
et donc du coup ce qui permet aux forces
de l'ordre de ne pas être au contact et
de ne pas jouer les provocateurs entre
guillemets en se mettant dans les rues
un peu adjacentes je relance notre cher
Vincent Vincent vous êtes sur place je
crois qu'on vous a retrouvé dites nous
est-ce qu'il y a plus de monde qu'il y a
12 jours je sais que c'est dur à dire
mais selon vos premières impressions
alors c'est dur à dire surtout que
là-bas le cortège n'avait pas avancé on
était resté bloqué à Place de la
République pendant très longtemps je
sais pas si vous voyez sous ces images
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de monde je
remonte le cortège depuis tout à l'heure
pour récupérer on va dire du de la du
réseau et en fait il y a quand même
énormément de monde et en fait on a
toujours pas vu la tout au fond vous
pouvez voir l'ordre un ballon de foot de
la CGT là on est dans le avec FO et en
fait après il y a encore la CFDT après
donc il y a encore beaucoup de monde je
pense Place d'Italie que j'essaie de
j'essaie de remonter donc voilà pour
l'instant beaucoup de monde on a vu pas
mal de politiques bien évidemment
François Ruffin qui était là aussi pour
cette manifestation mais donc voilà
beaucoup beaucoup de monde il y a encore
pas mal de gens qui sont pas du tout
parti en tout cas de la place d'Italie
merci merci Vincent roseron nous tenez
au courant des événements dans cette
manifestation je rassure sinaïl sur
Youtube c'est quand qu'il parle de la
raison de la manifestation oui oui on en
a parlé déjà une demi heure avec
Marie-Cécile Renaud on fait un point
sécurité chiffre avec Christophe
Cornavin et premier dans quelques
minutes on reparlera des tenants et des
aboutissants de cette réforme des
retraites et oui vous disiez que juste
Thibault je porte à votre connaissance
une information que je viens de recevoir
là
la préfecture de police m'annonce avoir
réalisé depuis
autour de la manifestation à 14h45 donc
il y a peu de temps plus de 16 minutes
7000 contrôles 7000 contrôles c'est
beaucoup c'est énorme réalisé donc
autour de la manifestation ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire concrètement que quand
même ils prennent les menaces de
dérapage assez au sérieux ils essaient
de déminer le terrain j'ai l'impression
que le chiffre que vous me donniez il y
a 12 jours à peu près à la même heure
été était un peu plus faible
la gelée là je l'ai là je l'ai là à
13h50 donc c'est un peu avant il y avait
2300 contrôles donc là on aurait
là on est à 7000 donc on est quand même
beaucoup on est au moins est-ce qu'on
chiffre de garde à vue et alors là pour
l'instant je n'ai pas de je n'ai pas
d'interpellation c'est-à-dire que pour
l'instant la physionomie de cette
manifestation me semble plutôt plutôt
correct pour mémoire il y a il y a donc
12 jours on était à ce moment-là déjà 15
interpellations entre nous soit dit
Thibault 15 interpellations c'est rien
du tout il faut se souvenir que au plus
fort des gilets jaunes il y a eu des
journées à plus de 2000 interpellations
et 1500 garde à vue c'est-à-dire
qu'après 1500 personnes il faut les
mettre dans les jaunes 1500 personnes
avec beaucoup moins de manifestants
visible avec beaucoup moins de
manifestants donc pour l'instant c'est
extrêmement calme il y a toujours une
suspicion autour de la direction de la
police du ministère de l'Intérieur
certains disent qu'il donnerait des
ordres pour en venir les choses comment
ça peut être démenti tout ça comment les
Français peuvent être rassurés comment
donner confiance dans ses forces de
l'ordre dans ces manifestations
j'ai envie de faire une réponse
quasiment intuitive c'est à dire que il
y a quand même
peu d'avantages pour un préfet de police
ou pour un ministère de l'Intérieur
avoir une rue qui flambe parce que c'est
une manifestation qui s'embrasse bien
justement
elle décrit ce mouvement mais elle
décrivent aussi les forces de l'ordre ça
peut être les deux c'est il y a pas
d'exclusive là-dedans dire qu'en fait
tout le monde est perdant dans
l'histoire il faut bien comprendre qu'à
partir du moment où vous avez le chaos
social évidemment ça brouille
complètement le message mais il faut pas
croire que le préfet de police ou le
ministre de l'interne n'ont pas de
contre-in derrière vous souvenez quand
même qu'il y a eu des préfets de police
notamment le préfet del Puech qui ça lui
a coûté son poste les gilets jaunes
a vite été oublié Delpech c'était
pourtant c'était un c'était un préfet de
police qui était plutôt plutôt pas
mauvais sauf que là il avait pas il
avait un peu on va dire sous-estimé
peut-être la violence sociale qui
agissait dans dans la France à ce
moment-là et salut à écouter son poste
gardez aussi en mémoire que comment le
Christophe Castaner et ressorti du
ministère de l'intérieur avec du goudron
et des plumes parce que justement il
avait pas pu prendre la mesure de la
colère de la rue et notamment de la
colère qui avait aussi au sein des
forces de l'ordre c'est une autre
question la majorité sera unie c'est ce
que vient de dire Elizabeth borne la
première ministre au député macroniste
on parlera justement politique dans
quelques minutes parce que oui certains
députés de la majorité semble vouloir
voter contre cette réforme des retraites
on en parlera tout à l'heure dernière
question Christophe parcours différent
cette fois
parcours moins classique moins de gauche
si j'ose dire pourquoi ce choix là qui
décide d'ailleurs
alors les parcours en fait c'est
c'est les organisateurs mais après je
rappelle parce que ceux qui nous
rejoignent ne savent pas le
manifestation c'est ça c'est lance Place
d'Italie passera par Montparnasse pour
arriver devant les devant les Invalides
derrière les Invalides plutôt place
Vauban alors que il y a 12 jours c'était
un parcours un peu plus classique le
fameux République bassine voilà
exactement un grand grand classique là
on passe effectivement rive gauche
il est intéressant à noter que c'est un
parcours qui est qui va faire 5 km qui
va passer quand même par des points
chauds par exemple à la Rotonde
la rotonde c'était quand même un endroit
un restaurant du de la du boulevard
Montparnasse
à l'intérieur duquel le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron avait célébré
dans sa victoire effectivement
aux premières sa première mandature et
donc est devenu un peu un des symboles
de la de la macronie et il faut quand
même bien se souvenir là que évidemment
les gens sont vendent beaucoup contre
les retraites mais
c'est aussi une manière de contester la
personnalité de d'Emmanuel Macron et la
gouvernance Emmanuel Macron donc
tracer un un
parcours de défilé qui va passer devant
un des lieux symbolique qui a marqué la
victoire d'Emmanuel Macron en pendant sa
première voiture 2017 c'est cet appareil
osé je suis certain que le préfet de
police a dû mettre au moins une unité
mobile autour de ce cet établissement
pour éviter pour éviter la casse quid
des jeunes est-ce qu'ils seront dans la
manif ça aussi c'est un défi ah bah oui
c'est un défi parce qu'en fait les
jeunes il y a
ils étaient assez 13 ans il y a 12 jours
là on a vu que les notamment les les
syndicats essaient de battre le rappel
syndicat Alicia étudiant il y a quelques
blocages de de de
d'établissement il y a notre journaliste
Victor Mira qui qui est allé sur place
pour couvrir ça
et il y a des tentatives d'Aget qui sont
faites dans les dans les facs on peut
pas dire que pour l'instant ça mobilise
encore énormément mais pour les
policiers c'est un point extrêmement
important de savoir si oui ou non il y
aura des jeunes manifestation s'il y a
des mineurs on agit pas tout à fait de
la même manière mais c'est un public
très différent peut-être s'il y a de la
violence vous pouvez pas technique et
faire travailler sur une sur une masse
en terme de maintenance si vous avez des
enfants il faut quand même se souvenir
que les les services d'ordre sont hantés
par la tragédie de
1986 qui avait coûté la vie à
manicocyking qui était un jeune un jeune
étudiant qui était d'ailleurs
qui ne va rien avoir avec les
manifestations qui avaient été tué alors
que il y avait un défilé sur la loi de
vaquer donc c'est à dire que
c'est un point d'attention pour
l'instant on peut pas dire que il y a
une révolte que la jeunesse se soulève
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que la jeunesse
on l'a entendu n'a pas l'air du tout
prompte à à en dossier cette réforme des
des 64 ans parce qu'ils se disent que
eux s'ils font les 43 années de pouvoir
plus et qui se lance sur le marché de
travail à 25 ans ça valait presque à 70
ans et ça je vois que la colère monte
dans leur rang merci beaucoup Christophe
Cornavin rédacteur en chef adjoint
service société du Figaro spécialiste
les questions de sécurité de
renseignement c'est toujours très
intéressant de vous avoir vous restez
avec vous et puis vous nous transmettez
les chiffres dès que vous les avez sans
faute évidemment Timothée delaime je
vous rejoins et je vous donne un chiffre
19,4% de grévi dans la fonction publique
d'État contre 28% le le 19 janvier c'est
un peu moins et bien justement est-ce
qu'il y a un peu moins de monde que
qu'il y a deux jours dans la
manifestation dans laquelle vous vous
trouvez Timothée
[Musique]
vous faire remarquer vous le voyez
d'ailleurs sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc le cortège qui est moins fourni
que la semaine dernière en tous les cas
à l'endroit où nous nous trouvons il y a
plus de monde derrière derrière nous au
niveau des ballons de syndicats mais ici
en tous les cas vous le voyez ce cortège
qui n'est pas très fourni en fait ce qui
est assez assez étonnant c'est que le
cortège n'avance pas de manière on va
dire ils sont les gens ne sont pas
forcément tous ensemble il y a certaines
personnes qui se trouvent devant
d'autres qui se sont ici arrêtés je vous
le disais tout à l'heure un petit
attroupement autour de ce groupe de
personnes vêtus de noir qui scandait qui
ont commencé à chanter tout le monde
déteste la police ce genre de slogan
vous l'entendez un pétard à l'instant
c'est pas la quelques personnes qui
s'étaient arrêté pour les regarder
certains d'ailleurs assez incrédule se
demander on les entendait se dire mais
qui sont ces personnes qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils font pourquoi sont-ils
dans cette pourquoi sont-ils habillés
par exemple comme cela les gens étaient
plutôt plutôt étonnés et plutôt
interpellé ici vous le voyez un relatif
calme mais c'est vrai qu'on voit pas un
cortège qui avance de manière de manière
uniforme vers et bien cette place Vauban
qui est la destinationale de la
manifestation cet après-midi pour vous
donner une idée nous sommes maintenant
dans le cinquième arrondissement de la
capitale au niveau de la rue
Saint-Jacques nous venons en ce qui nous
concerne de passer devant l'hôpital du
Val de Grâce et nous allons bientôt
rejoindre le boulevard du Montparnasse
nous sommes au niveau de Port-Royal
quasiment à la jonction entre le
boulevard du Port-Royal et le boulevard
Montparnasse la tour Montparnasse qui
d'ailleurs est visible à quelques à
quelques centaines de mètres de la voilà
Julien Leclerc qui vous montre cela sur
ces images et vraiment voilà ce cortège
ce cortège qui avance mais comme un
petit moment de flottement on voit
certaines personnes d'ailleurs on sait
pas vraiment presque si ce sont des gens
qui sont là pour manifester ou bien si
ce sont des gens qui sont venus pour
voir pour regarder voilà une ambiance
assez particulière on n'entend pas de
slogans comme on l'entendait l'année
dernière c'est aussi parce que nous
sommes à l'avant du cortège encore une
fois probablement qu'il a plus de monde
plus de bruit au niveau de l'arrière et
au niveau de toutes les ballons les
pancartes des syndicats mais ici en tous
les cas voilà c'est vrai qu'on a le
sentiment qu'il a moins de monde que la
semaine dernière merci Timothée nous
verrons ce qu'il en est lorsque les
chiffres tomberont en fin de journée
autre barrière dit bonjour bonjour
journaliste au service société
spécialiste des questions d'éducation
aborder plusieurs points avec vous les
profs et les initiens on commence par
les profs est-ce qu'ils sont dans la rue
aujourd'hui
26% des enseignants du premier degré
donc maternelle et élémentaire et 25% en
second degré collège lycée CIO c'est pas
etc c'est moins c'est moins que le 19
janvier alors je rappelle quand même une
chose importante ministère la semaine
dernière c'était 42% en primaire
34% au collège
26 34 contre 25 donc évidemment c'est
moins ce sont les chiffres du ministère
les chiffres des syndicats sont un peu
différents puisque aujourd'hui on avait
annoncé
à peu près 50-55% dans le second degré
50 % dans le primaire et la semaine
dernière c'était 70 % en premier degré
et puis 65 % dans le second degré donc
on voit bien que que ce soit les
chiffres du ministère ou les chiffres
des syndicats là pour le coup on baisse
ça reste quand même des chiffres
relativement importants mais ça laisse
ça baisse et j'ai l'impression que c'est
c'est moins que prévu je voyais la
semaine dernière je voyais un de vos
articles certains syndicats de preuves
disaient 70% de grévistes on est quand
même largement en dessous est-ce que
c'est étonnant de voir des profs qui se
mobilisent mais pas tant que ça
finalement alors il y a toujours une
marge entre les estimations évidemment
de tout ce que c'est aussi pour les
syndicats c'est aussi un moyen
d'annoncer une grande mobilisation aussi
remobiliser leur troupes donc évidemment
on n'est pas à 70% après ça reste quand
même des un chiffre assez important on
n'est pas au niveau de la dernière une
trentaine de pour cent enfin j'arrive
pas
en tout cas la dernière grosse
mobilisation des enseignants ça date
déjà d'une réforme des retraites
celle-ci de 2019 les chiffres étaient
plus importants là on n'a pas atteint ce
plafond mais c'est quand même une grosse
mobilisation par rapport à d'autres
journées de manifestations qui a eu
depuis 2019 pourtant les profs c'est
souvent la première ligne dans les
mouvements sociaux non ils mènent ils
mènent les contestations c'est un
secteur qui est assez syndiqué alors ce
qui est important de savoir c'est que il
y a quelques années dans les années 90
et 45% des enseignants qui étaient
syndiqués aujourd'hui selon une enquête
qui a été fait par l'Ifop l'an dernier
c'est 30%. donc ça baisse ça baisse
alors après 30% ça reste quand même un
tiers des enseignants en France qui sont
syndiqués ce n'est pas rien c'est pas
rien et traditionnellement vous avez
tout à fait raison la mobilisation des
enseignants scrutés comme celle des
agents EDF des des conducteurs de la
SNCF il y a des salariés comme ça et des
salariés des agents publics des
fonctionnaires dont on scrute la
mobilisation les profs en font partie
mais ils sont moins syndiqués qu'avant
donc clairement l'âge d'or du
syndicalisme enseignant est plutôt
derrière nous mais on voit bien quand
même danser ces mobilisations et je
pense que mon collègue Christophe
corneva vous en a parlé les syndicats
sont en première ligne syndicat
enseignant et les autres c'est ce sont
des mobilisations c'est une mobilisation
très tenue par les syndicats
on a interrogé deux personnes dans cette
manifestation ce Timothée d'Hélène tout
à l'heure qui était justement avec avec
une prof très rapidement ils sont ils
sont visibles ils partent à quel âge les
profs parce que c'est comme les autres
ou non ils partent un peu avant oui
alors là c'est 62 ans donc comme les
autres comme les autres voilà sauf qu'il
y a quand même certains qui bénéficient
d'un ancien statut qui était celui des
instituteurs c'est un petit peu
compliqué peut-être un peu long à
expliquer ici mais en fait ce statut des
instituteurs permettait de partir à la
retraite à 57 ans aujourd'hui c'est un
statut qui n'existe plus il y a quelques
personnes qui ont encore ce statut
d'instituteur mais sinon globalement ce
sont maintenant des professeurs des
écoles qui partent à la retraite à 62
ans et pareil pour les enseignants du
second degré je précise quand même une
vraie différence entre les enseignants
du premier du second degré parce que
dans le second degré si vous devez
partir à la retraite disons le 30
décembre vous partez à la retraite le 30
décembre si vous le souhaitez en
revanche oui c'est ça aujourd'hui un
prof part à la retraite à la fin de
l'année scolaire c'est ça alors dans le
premier degré oui dans le second degré
vous partez comme dans le privé quand
vous finissez
au milieu de l'année scolaire mais que
ma retraite je peux la prendre le 15
décembre je peux partir le 15 décembre
si vous êtes prof par exemple de maths
au collège ou au lycée si vous êtes
professeur des écoles en maternelle en
élémentaire et bien là vous partirez à
la fin de l'année scolaire c'est une des
inégalités qui font un peu bondir les
syndicats en disant mais si en plus on
repousse l'âge de la retraite déjà un
peu loin et qu'en plus je comprends
c'est que si quelqu'un peut partir par
exemple à la retraite le 15 septembre le
4 juillet donc ça évidemment c'est
compliqué même si en fait on voit bien
que il y a pas mal de professeurs même
dans le second degré qui attendent la
fin de l'année scolaire parfois pour
partir mais c'est vrai que c'est eu un
des motifs de de mobilisation notamment
des professeurs du premier degré de
rétablir l'égalité à ce niveau-là est-ce
qu'au fond c'est leur priorité de
revendications cette réforme des
retraites aux professionnels n'ont pas
tout un tas d'autres problèmes et
d'autres revendications que celle-ci
c'est intéressant de vous poser la
question parce qu'en effet je pense
qu'il se saisissent de cette ce
mouvement de contestation pour
évidemment évoquer les retraites parce
que les professeurs leur syndicats leur
représentant disent que c'est un métier
fatiguant usant et qu'à 64 ans 65 ans
vous avez pas forcément l'énergie de
gérer 30-30 enfants pendant des jours
enfin d'avoir une attention sans faille
donc il y a ça évidemment mais il y a
aussi toute la question du ras-le-bol
général des profs on sent bien que les
profs ils attendaient beaucoup de
l'arrivée de papel Ndiaye au ministère
d'éducation nationale ça avait été très
déçu par Jean-Michel Blanquer ouvert là
sur la forme il y a plus de dialogue
enfin en tout cas c'est ce que disent
les syndicats mais en revanche ils sont
pas satisfaits des mesures de
revalorisation repas donc de
revalorisation salariés
quand est-ce qu'il y a eu une grève sur
ces questions il y a eu un des
mouvements qui ont été peut-être moins
suivis que que ce que les syndicats
auraient aimé comme souvent mais il y a
quand même un ras-le-bol là-dessus sur
les conditions de travail on a
évidemment
recruter un peu n'importe comment et
Emmanuel Macron était allé leur parler
en leur promettant des revalorisation
salariales c'est peut-être ça leur
priorité évidemment c'est sûr que le
salaire alors les retraites c'est
intéressant ce que ça touche tout le
monde tout le monde va être touché même
si évidemment les plus anciens sont plus
directement concernés mais c'est vrai
que la question de des conditions de
travail et de la revelarisation
salariale est important sont importantes
pour les professeurs et c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il se mobilisent aujourd'hui et le
19 janvier et peut-être dans les jours à
venir retourne en instant dans la
manifestation avec Vincent roseron
Vincent vous voyez les affiches autour
de vous j'ai vu que vous étiez avec
force Ouvrière tout à l'heure est-ce
qu'il y a des profs justement et
dites-nous quelles sont les personnes
que vous voyez autour de vous
alors je suis tout j'étais avec force
ouverte je suis toujours avec force
Ouvrière parce que le convoi officiel on
va dire le convoi de véhicules avance
très très peu alors vous voyez à côté de
moi les gens avancent beaucoup mais le
convoi principal qui est plutôt au
centre de mon image là actuellement
bouge très très peu c'est à dire que
tout à l'heure on était quasiment pas
avancé vous voyez ce ballon avec CGT le
ballon CGT et là-bas et alors est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup de profs oui on en a
vu côté solidaire là du voyeur drapeau
du SNES un peu plus loin la base qui
doit aussi être des profs de de nombreux
profs avec de nombreux slogans sur ça il
ne voulait pas faire
l'éducation avec 35 élèves par classe
jusqu'à 64 ans certains le mettaient sur
leur pancarte par exemple
merci merci Vincent est-ce que ça ça
pourrait changer l'ensemble de la
mobilisation et de contre cette réforme
des retraites si les profs entraient
plus clairement en grève si il y a pas
de preuve les enfants sont obligés de
rester à la maison si les enfants
restent à la maison les parents restent
à la maison ils vont pas travailler le
pays est bloqué est-ce que ça pourrait
arriver est-ce que
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est ce que nous
expliquait Christophe Cornavin tout à
l'heure avec des mineurs il est plus
difficile de les faire partie d'être
plus violent d'une certaine manière pour
les forces de l'ordre bah disons que
c'est de toute façon c'est compliqué
parce que il y a eu vraiment une à la
fois une liberté de manifester
s'exprimer et puis une liberté pour les
autres d'aller en cours il faut faire
respecter les deux libertés c'est le cas
dans les lycées mais aussi dans les
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
qui sont toujours assez concernés par
exemple la science au Sciences Po
étaient bloqué ce matin selon notre
journaliste qui allait sur place c'était
quand même assez Pacifique il y avait
quelques quelques quelques blocages
voilà mais ça restait quand même assez
calme le chiffre qu'on a qui a annoncé
par la voie lycéenne qui est un syndicat
lycéen c'est qu'il y aurait 300 lycées
mobilisés 200 bloquer plus ou moins
bloqué et dont une trentaine en
Île-de-France ce qu'ils sont crédibles
les lycéens quand ils font rêvent ça
c'est vrai c'est toujours plus facile à
la fin on ne manque pas une journée de
salaire quand on est lycéen alors quand
on est lycéen non en revanche il y a
quand même de plus en plus d'étudiants
qui travaillent donc qui peuvent se
sentir concernés parce que quand on
travaille ou déjà directement concerné
par les questions de retraite et puis
c'est vrai que même si les retraites
peuvent sembler un peu peut-être un peu
lointaines à nos horizon un peu lointain
pour pour des lycéens et des étudiants
ils sentent quand même qu'il y a tout un
mouvement de contestation qui est là et
ils veulent en faire partie est-ce
qu'ils peuvent être eux aussi
déclencheurs d'un grand mouvement on
pense à chaque fois que cette question
revient on pense à mes 68 parce que
c'est une des craintes peut-être du
ministère de l'Intérieur du gouvernement
les jeunes les étudiants entrent dans sa
grève pleinement c'est drôle que vous
disiez ça ce que je sais pas si on l'a
vu sur les images mais un des slogans
des jeunes de cette journée c'est une
omis 64 pour 64 ans on te remet 68 avec
le jeu de mots 68
j'aime bien les slogans dans les
manifestations celui-là est très bien
68 pour l'instant on est quand même très
loin de Mai 68 mais c'est vrai que on
sent quand même et d'ailleurs pas que
dans l'éducation et probablement
d'autres personnes sur ce plateau le
diront mais un mouvement qui s'en quand
même un peu les étudiants j'ai la
sensation pour les entends un peu moins
on entend les lycéens on entend ceux qui
travaillent et les étudiants dans tout
ça est-ce qu'ils sont mobilisés ou pas
un peu comme les lycéens de manière
réparti il y en a quand même pas mal
dans le cortège cet après-midi il y en
avait à Paris notamment dans les autres
villes aussi et on avait le 19 janvier
on sent pour l'instant pas non plus une
mobilisation générale sur la question
étudiante mais quand même vous seriez
surpris de voir qu'il y a pas mal de
jeunes qui se sentent concernés par les
retraites et d'ailleurs c'est ça fait
l'objet d'un article qui paraîtra
bientôt sur le Figaro à ce sujet
justement cette question des retraites
qui n'arrivera pour certains pas avant
45 ans 40 ans c'est une vraie inquiétude
pour les jeunes ou bon fait grève de
manière plutôt idéologique
je dirais un peu des deux et à la fois
vraiment un horizon certes lointain mais
qui concerne je veux dire les retraites
ça concerne tout le monde c'est pas
comme par exemple comme la réforme sur
les lycées professionnels qui ne
touchent que les lycées professionnels
ou d'autres d'autres choses
particulières ça concerne tout le monde
donc ça peut concerner des jeunes et à
la fois il y a quand même aussi une
volonté de contestation de mobilisation
contre le gouvernement le président qui
est là donc je dirais que c'est un
ensemble un petit peu déduit merci
beaucoup merci Aude journaliste au
service société en charge des questions
d'éducation de nous avoir éclairé sur
les intentions des profs et des lycées
en retrouvent Vincent roseron sur place
à s'enrodront vous êtes avec un
manifestant ou une manifestant dites-moi
tout
[Musique]
qui est professeur
pourquoi pour vous c'était important
pour vous d'être ici n'importe quoi pour
moi d'être ici pour défendre les acquis
déjà sociaux
au service à j'ai le futur parce que
dans certaines professions il sera
difficile d'aller jusqu'au bout pour
tout le monde de pouvoir continuer à
travailler jusqu'à descend pour
accueillir des élèves correctement
profiter correctement des fans de vie
aussi la
pour beaucoup de gens on sera difficile
d'arriver au bout de la carrière d'avoir
les trimestres quelle que soit leur
profession et avoir une société de
personnes âgées qui seraient à la misère
dans la plus grande misère c'est pas
forcément le progrès social or en
ouvrant ce projet comme un progrès
social on est à l'encontre de ce de
cette idée de progrès social pour tous
les travailleurs quel que soit les
métiers et du côté du professeur enfin
du côté du professeur est-ce que vous
imaginez je suis toujours travaillé
jusqu'à 64 ans comme ça va être le cas
avec cette réforme 64 ans très peu de
collègues arriveront 64 ans beaucoup de
collègues commencent à 23 24 ans après
le concours donc ça veut dire que si on
a l'âge limite à 67 ans partira même pas
la retraite forcément avec le nombre
d'années avant 67 ans et est-ce qu'on
aura l'énergie de tenir encore des
classes à 35 36 un âge avancé et avec
moins d'énergie qu'on peut en avoir à 30
ou 40 ans très bien merci beaucoup en
tout cas
pour les profs mais pas seulement quand
vous avez pu l'entendre oui merci
Vincent roseron
vous avez manifestants qui collait à
notre débat précédent et codes barietty
bravo Arthur bilota bonjour bonjour
Thibault bonjour à tous aux flic data
tout à fait bon j'ai plein de questions
à vous poser
des gens on va essayer de coller un peu
à l'actu à ce qui s'est passé ce matin
on est on se dirige vers une hausse de
la mobilisation et si j'ai bien compris
tout à fait Thibault nous on a pris les
comptes officiels des préfectures des
services de police dans les préfectures
les sous-préfectures les villes donc les
chiffres officielles les chiffres
officiels dans les villes qui ont
manifesté ce matin qui tombe petit à
petit grâce à nos à nos collègues
également de la presse quotidienne
régionale qui qui sont sur le terrain et
on voit dans la plupart des villes une
augmentation de la mobilisation par
rapport à la première manifestation du
19 janvier alors c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs vous pouvez retrouver cette
carte vous allez sur la homepage du
Figaro vous avez le note live ou
descendre un petit peu vous avez tout ce
qu'il se passe par tout en France et
vous avez alors je donne le nom du
papier
il s'appelle réforme des retraites vers
une hausse de la mobilisation vous avez
figata devant comme ça vous savez tout
et on parle de la de la même chose
ensemble je vais vous mettre le lien
d'ailleurs dans dans le dans le chat
alors je peux passer ma souris et je
vois par exemple je prends une ville en
rouge c'est que ça fortement augmenté
c'est ça non rouge c'est que c'est ABC
ah oui d'accord donc le rouge est vers
la baisse le jaune et la stabilité et le
vert correspond à l'augmentation
d'accord donc je prends une ville tient
comme Albertville par exemple en Savoie
hausse de 2400 manifestants le 19
janvier à 3200 manifestants voilà donc
c'est quand même une plus puissante
personnes quand vous en aviez 2400 ce
que ça représente une hausse assez
importante d'accord quelle est la
tendance générale c'est à dire que la
semaine dernière si on continue comme ça
la semaine dernière il y a toujours
d'ailleurs le 19 janvier nous étions à
un million 120 000 manifestants c'est la
tendance se poursuit à combien
serons-nous de manifestants ce soir
selon les chiffres officiels c'est très
difficile de faire des prédictions parce
que je vous demande il y a plein de il y
a plein de paramètres qui rentrent en
compte par exemple la météo peut
expliquer ce surcroît de mobilisation
mais en tout cas on se dirige vers une
mobilisation légèrement supérieure si
j'avais un pronostic à faire comme comme
dans les matchs de football je dirais
peut-être un virgule deux millions de
manifestants ce soir selon le ministère
de l'Intérieur toujours les syndicats
eux avancent des chiffres bien plus
élevés bon je vous ai fait venir Arthur
évidemment pour parler des chiffres du
jour mais pour vous nous parliez de
cette ce grand papier que vous avez fait
vous avez rencontré Jérôme Fourquet tout
à fait évidemment et c'est assez
étonnant mais
les manifestations ne se sont pas
concentrées que dans les grandes villes
c'est bien ça c'est c'est là Thibault et
en fait nous on est parti d'un constat
c'est qu'on voyait des chiffres très
élevés dans certaines préfectures
sous-préfecture je pense à La
Roche-sur-Yon à Avignon à Béziers à
Châteauroux est-ce qu'on a décidé de
faire on a répertorié les 225
manifestations qui avaient eu lieu le 19
janvier d'accord puis ensuite on a pris
la population travail de fourmis on a
pris la population de l'agglomération ce
qu'on appelle l'erreur urbaine et on a
fait un ratio et là on a vu que dans les
villes moyennes les préfectures je pense
par exemple à Digne-les-Bains à Gap
de Provence j'aime beaucoup cette région
qui sont très souvent cités je pense à
Guéret par exemple dans la Creuse
également toutes ces villes là avaient
un ratio parfois
10% de la population de l'agglomération
avait manifesté le 19 janvier je
comprends donc c'est c'est assez élevé
donc on est parti de ce constat là et
ensuite on a montré ses chiffres à
Jérôme Fourquet qui en a qui en attiré
une brillante analyse qui était dans le
journal d'hier voilà là vous voyez cet
article dont on parlait tout à l'heure
vous avez les chiffres en temps réel de
la manifestation d'aujourd'hui pourquoi
c'est étonnant pourquoi ça vous a étonné
que cette manifestation
une manifestation ne se déroule pas que
dans les grandes villes c'est rare nous
ça nous a étonné mais je renforca ça ne
l'a pas étonné puisque il nous a dit que
c'était plutôt quelque chose d'habituel
et il a expliqué notamment par un
facteur qui est selon lui prépondérant
c'est la présence d'emploi public plus
vous avez d'emploi publics ça peut être
dans les hôpitaux il donnait l'exemple
de dîner bain on en parlait tout à
l'heure à Digne-les-Bains vous avez
30000 personnes dans l'agglomération et
le centre hospitalier emploie 1000
personnes donc vous imaginez le taux
d'emploi public dans les
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence et donc plus il
y a d'endroits plus il y a de d'emplois
publics pardon plus on manifeste c'est
c'est une première corrélation que que
nous a que nous a montré Jérôme Fourquet
d'accord premier point donc il y a plus
d'emplois publics les hôpitaux notamment
les hôpitaux notamment bon il y a aussi
les lieux où il y a des industries oui
Jérôme Fourquet toujours lui citait
Figeac dans le Lot on avait je crois
presque 11 de la population de l'aire
urbaine de Figeac dans la rue jeudi 19
janvier un chiffre énorme l'un des plus
l'un des plus importants de notre
classement et lui corrélait cela à la
présence de de sous-traitance
aéronautique on est dans la région de
Toulouse il y a Airbus donc il corait
les save avec la présence d'une usine
comme Figeac Aero si ma mémoire est
bonne et donc ses ouvriers ces employés
qui sont le plus souvent défavorable
c'est la catégorie socio-professionnelle
la plus défavorable à la réforme des
retraites avait plus tendance à se
mobiliser on continue de parler de ces
mobilisations en région dans les villes
de province ce qui vous a étonné et
Arthur bizota du fil data c'est
intéressé à la question essaie de nous
expliquer pourquoi ces manifestations
n'ont pas lieu qu'à Paris ou dans les
grandes villes mais d'abord on retourne
sur place on retourne dans le cortège on
se rapproche de Montparnasse si j'ai
bien compris Timothée delhem et vous me
dites que c'est un peu tendu
[Musique]
Thibault on se rapproche de Montparnasse
mais assez lentement malgré tout parce
que comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure vous le voyez d'ailleurs ici il
y a des moments un petit peu d'attente
un peu un peu de moments de flottement
comme vous le voyez par exemple à cet
instant avec des manifestants qui sont
là qui regardent qui observent ce qu'il
se passe mais qui n'avance pas
franchement on a vu on l'a dit la
semaine dernière un cortège très rempli
très compact avec une bonne ambiance ça
c'était le 19 janvier c'est vrai que
l'ambiance est assez différente
aujourd'hui
nous en tous les cas on observe moins de
monde même si je vous entendais dire que
les prévisions
prévoient peut-être plus de plus de
monde en tous les cas nous ce que nous
voyons c'est qu'ici la foule est moins
compact et puis surtout une ambiance un
petit peu plus pesante que la semaine
dernière on l'a dit la semaine dernière
encore une fois une ambiance assez bonne
enfant presque familiale là cette
fois-ci c'est assez différent par
exemple vous le voyez juste ici sur ces
images de Julien Leclerc certaines
personnes qui sont en train et bien de
mettre le feu à une à une poubelle ce
sont des micro-événements mais que nous
n'observions pas la semaine dernière
nous avons vu également certains
manifestants tagués des arrêts de bus
beaucoup de personnes aussi cagoulées
cagoulé en noir avec un regard parfois
qui dévisage voilà donc une petite
tension dans l'air on sent que les gens
sont un petit peu à couteau serrés ici
même si pour le moment et bien il n'y a
pas de gros débordement à signaler vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la
mobilisation des plus jeunes c'est vrai
que j'ai cherché on nous aimerons bien
nous aimerions bien trouver un jeune un
étudiant un lycéen pourrai bien lui
demander pourquoi il est là pourquoi il
le manifeste comme cette réforme des
retraites mais nous nous envoyons pas
beaucoup
bah énormément de jeunes en tous les cas
à cet endroit là du cortège qui continue
de se diriger vers la place Montparnasse
même si voilà comme je vous le disais ça
avance très lentement pour le moment
on va voir la suite des événements oui
vous nous disiez des microvénements on
ne va pas affoler les gens pour
l'instant ça se passe dans l'ensemble
très bien et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
vous notiez ce sont des cortèges avec
des ambiances bonnes enfants il y a pas
les mêmes personnes que d'habitude c'est
ça
c'est pas plutôt une c'est pas une
différence de personne c'est plutôt une
forme de continuité dans les dans les
villes moyennes c'est ce que me disait
Jérôme Fourquet au téléphone jeudi il
voyait des cortèges bon enfant on
rejoint on rejoint ses copains on
rejoint ses copains on rejoint ses
collègues on rejoint des amis son
beau-frère sa belle-sœur sa sœur son
oncle ou sa famille je vais pas énumérer
mais dans ces villes moyennes le trajet
était établi ne change généralement pas
et c'est aussi une manière de se
retrouver donc c'est aussi ça qui
expliquait les manifestations et et la
forte présence la forte mobilisation
dans ces préfectures et sous-préfecture
donc dans les régions vous me disiez
dans les moyenne de province il y avait
plus de monde parce que beaucoup
d'employés du public parce que beaucoup
d'employés dans les industries et puis
les villes où il y a il y a peu de cadre
de professions intellectuelles
supérieures c'est ça c'est ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle la composition
démographique de des métropoles et des
villes moyennes dans les métropoles vous
avez plus de cadres ce qu'on appelle des
CSP plus des professions intellectuelles
supérieures qui eux ont intériorisé le
fait qu'ils allaient devoir travailler
très longtemps parce qu'ils ont fait des
études ils ont commencé à travailler
tard donc pour eux le décalage de l'âge
légal à 64 ans n'aura que peu
d'incidences dans notre simulateur vous
le voyez bien si vous avez commencé à
travailler tard sachant la réforme ne
change pas grand chose pour vous à
l'inverse dans les villes moyennes on a
une plus grande présence d'ouvriers et
d'employés qui eux vont être impactés
par la réforme donc qui manifeste en
plus grand nombre des manifestations qui
ont eu lieu ce matin dans la plupart des
des grandes villes et des villes
moyennes manifestations cet après-midi à
Lyon on signale qu'il y a là aussi
quelques quelques événements avec des
manifestants qui auraient par exemple
renversé un conteneur bon on verra ce
qu'il en est dans les dans les heures
qui viennent vous êtes aussi rendu
compte mon cher Arthur j'avais une
différence entre les régions c'est à
dire que on manifeste pas avec la même
intensité dans le Sud-Ouest ou dans
l'Ouest que dans le nord-est c'est ça
c'est tout à fait ça et c'est également
corrélé à ce qu'on vient de dire sur les
employés les ouvriers la présence
d'emploi public mais dans l'Ouest et
dans le Sud-Ouest on dispose d'une
culture manifestante bien plus
importante que dans le nord-est on a
l'habitude de sortir des filets
c'est entre guillemets une institution
donc vous observez et je pense
directement à la Bretagne une très forte
mobilisation en Bretagne avec de
nombreux points de rassemblement c'est
encore visible aujourd'hui et on a cette
tradition manifestante cette culture de
de l'opposition mais de défiler pour
pour exprimer son rejet d'une réforme
etc etc chose qu'on a beaucoup moins
dans le nord-est dans le nord-est on a
une population qui Géronde pour quel
résumait en une phrase qui pense à quoi
bon à quoi bon se mobiliser à quoi bon
descendre dans la rue de toute façon
c'est fichu c'est j'ai encore deux
petites questions et puis après on aura
le risque boit le choix du service
politique parce qu'on va essayer de
décrypter les enjeux pour le
gouvernement et à l'Assemblée nationale
autour de cette réforme des retraites
vous êtes aussi rendu compte vous êtes
rendu compte de beaucoup de choses que
le travail on manifeste assez peu dans
les dans les les fiefs du rassemblement
national pourquoi alors que le
rassemblement national est aussi contre
cette réforme de retraite effectivement
le rassemblement national votre a les 88
députés rassemblement national voteront
contre la réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée nationale et pourtant dans
le Nord dans le nord-est là où il y a
les fiefs de Marine Le Pen et du
rassemblement national la mobilisation
est pas si importante que cela et on
peut l'expliquer par par deux ou trois
facteurs qu'il faut bien sûr mettre en
compte remettre dans leur contexte il y
a beaucoup moins cette culture
manifestante et le RN n'appelle pas ces
électeurs à manifester donc ça pourrait
expliquer le fait que même dans le
nord-est vous avez beaucoup d'ouvriers
beaucoup d'employés des industries qui
sont assez rejetés dans les d'ailleurs
les syndicats ne les veulent pas les les
rassemblement national donc forcément ça
joue merci beaucoup Arthur merci de nous
avoir éclairé sur ces manifestations qui
ont lieu en province c'est assez
surprenant avec beaucoup de monde enfin
en tout cas plus de monde que d'habitude
allez on tombe dans la prestation à
l'instant Vincent roseron j'ai
l'impression que le cortège est encore à
l'arrêt on croyait que ça avait pu se
lancer assez vite et bien finalement non
effectivement parce que si Timothée est
peut-être déjà arrivé à Montparnasse moi
je suis toujours à plasie vous rappelez
il y a 12 jours le cortège n'avait pas
avancé de la place de République avant
très longtemps là le cortège avance mais
avance vraiment petit mètre par petit
mètre je crois qu'on a dû à mon avis
avancer de 50 mètres sur les la dernière
demi-heure à mon avis ça avance petit à
petit c'est un peu bloqué devant mais du
coup ce qui se passe c'est que ça avance
beaucoup sur les côtés de des gens
avancent beaucoup sur les côtés et le
cortège qu'on appellera le cortège
principal vu qu'il y a les les voitures
et beaucoup plus on va dire c'est
beaucoup plus disperser la foulée
beaucoup plus dispersée à l'intérieur
mais en tout cas vous voyez toujours au
fond là vous voyez ce ballon CGT qui est
le début en fait de la CGT la CFDT est
aussi derrière elle n'est pas à passer
non plus pour l'instant il y a fort
ouvrière une ça et la CF euh
alors j'ai un trou sur l'autre syndicat
qui était tout devant en début de
manifestation mais voilà en tout cas il
y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de monde
à la place d'Italie alors que cette
manifestation et maintenant partie
depuis à peu près une heure et demie
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron Laurie
boischaud est avec nous bonjour bonjour
à tous journalistes au service politique
du Figaro acte 2 c'est un moment déjà
décisif là cet après-midi alors bien sûr
l'exécutif suit de près ainsi que les
députés de la majorité les
parlementaires de la majorité suivent de
près l'ampleur de la mobilisation
1,1 million la dernière fois sur les
chiffres du ministère de l'Intérieur 2
millions selon les syndicats ce sont des
chiffres qui donneront effectivement le
ton de l'évolution de cette mobilisation
est-ce que les syndicats ont un besoin
absolu de faire plus de faire mieux
pour et bien continuer à mobiliser et
montrer que c'est une mobilisation
importante pas seulement un coup d'essai
qui n'aura pas de suite ils doivent
faire aussi bien au moins que la que la
dernière fois pour ne pas qu'on puisse
parler d'essoufflement de cette
mobilisation et c'est un enjeu qu'ils
ont bien compris en appelant une
nouvelle fois et il y a plus d'une
semaine déjà vous souvenez vous c'était
le soir même de la première journée de
mobilisation en appelant tout de suite à
une nouvelle journée mobilisation
il voulait montrer que cette
mobilisation ça tout opposition de veste
maintenir frontalement contre la réforme
des retraites justement que s'est-il
passé depuis le 19 est-ce qu'il y a un
dialogue entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats ce qu'on a vraiment négocié ou
non non pas du tout on ne se parle pas
alors les
négociations sont plutôt à ce stade avec
les groupes parlementaires
les syndicats ne parlent pas avec le
gouvernement le dialogue bien sûr est
maintenu mais la les bougies si on peut
dire sont surtout poussés par les
groupes de la majorité et des
oppositions pour tenter d'amender le
texte on est rentré depuis lundi dans la
phase d'examen du contexte d'abord en
commission puis dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale à partir du 6
février et c'est à travers cette
discussion parlementaire que les partis
politiques vont tenter de corriger de
modifier plus ou moins en profondeur le
texte du Gouvernement alors ça
m'intéresse c'est à dire que les
syndicats qui sont là dans la rue
demandent le retrait plus récent de
cette réforme mais il discute quand même
avec des parlementaires en se disant si
le texte passe bon bah qu'il soit le
moins défavorable possible non alors ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une
opposition frontale à la mesure d'âge de
la part des activités ça c'est une
évidence et les syndicats on efface là
un dialogue de sourd entre des syndicats
et qui disent on veut pas de cette
mesure d'âge et l'exécutif qui dit s'il
y a bien quelque chose qui n'est pas
négociable c'est la mesure d'âge bien
sûr donc on fait face là à deux lignes
très différentes évidemment et qui sont
frontalement opposés cela n'empêche pas
que des négociations puissent avoir lieu
mais plus sur des corrections des petits
correctifs des aménagements de la loi et
surtout encore une fois entre les
groupes politiques et le gouvernement
15h30 si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes
en direct pour suivre cette deuxième
journée de grève contre la réforme des
retraites nous pensions que la
manifestation aurait plus de mal à
s'élance et qu'il y a 12 jours et bien
visiblement non puisque vous voyez ces
images Place d'Italie de là où vous
devez partir le cortège ou le doigt à
partir le cortège est bien visiblement
les manifestants sont à l'arrêt il y a
une petite phrase Loris ce week-end
c'est le d'Elisabeth borne les 64 ans
son non négociables ça vous a étonné
cette sortie là à deux jours de la grève
non la logique du gouvernement depuis le
début c'est de dire il faut sauver le
système de retraite et pour sauver ce
système de retraite il faut en passer
par cette mesure d'âge 65 ans avait dit
Emmanuel Macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle il avait ensuite amendé
son propos en évoquant
64 ans il s'était dit ensuite c'était
fin octobre sur France 2 favorable
ouvert plutôt à au scénario 64 ans
report de l'âge légal et accélération de
la durée de cotisation en parallèle la
réforme Touraine en effet donc s'il y a
bien quelque chose qui caractérise la
rhétorique du gouvernement depuis ce
début de seconde quinquennat c'est bien
mesure d'âge et
mesure d'âge très importante bien sûr
dans cette logique là pas étonnant donc
ils avaient de borne a dit ce n'est pas
négociable
Elizabeth borne non parce que on a eu
l'habitude de la voir dans la
négociation elle répète tout le temps
concertation c'est des mots qui
n'utilise très souvent alors là il y a
plus de concertation possible elle prend
des risques non Isabelle en tout cas
elle nous montre qui elle est vraiment
moi c'est ce que je ressens cette
réforme des retraites c'est un c'est un
marqueur pour
Emmanuel Macron et pour Elisabeth borne
s'il y a bien un élément du programme du
candidat Macron en 2022 qui a retenu
l'attention c'est cette réforme des
retraite et cet âge donc 65 64 ans qui
avait été évoqué
Emmanuel Macron joue là une partie de
l'élan réformateur qu'il avait promis
élan bien sûr par sa majorité
relative mais c'est bien cela qu'il vise
continuer à réformer le pays c'était son
ambition pendant la campagne électorale
il tente de montrer et sa première
ministre avec lui que c'est encore
possible quant à la négociation il les
avait de bornes va tout de même devoir
s'y soumettre c'est la discussion
parlementaire dont je parlais tout à
l'heure avec des correctifs qui lui sont
demandés à l'intérieur même de la
majorité par certains groupes d'une
clause de revoyure en 2028 c'est
intéressant c'est à dire que on pourrait
voter les 64 ans mais en disant à la fin
Macron ou à une date précise on se
réunit et si finalement la conjoncture
est bonne et que nous n'avons pas besoin
de repousser l'âge à 64 ans et bien on
ne repoussera que jusqu'à 60 absolument
en réalité ça ne coûte pas très cher de
d'inscrire cette clause de revoyure dans
la loi puisque on sera sous un nouveau
quinquennat peut-être un nouvel exécutif
ça permettrait en tout cas de faire
d'accorder une concession à certains
parlementaires notamment les centrist du
Mouvement Démocrate François Bayrou qui
tiennent à cette clause de revoyons ces
images sur le cortège avec ses forces de
l'ordre je ne sais pas ce sont des
gendarmes mobiles ou des CRS qui
protègent une devanture de banque on a
vu tout à l'heure des antifas de
potentiel Black Bloc défilé dans les
rues de la capitale c'est sans doute
pour ça que les forces de l'ordre sont
devant cette enseigne donc vous voyez la
marque qui est très largeur a déjà été
taguée vous le voyez sur sur la gauche
bon la rue on la voit ici d'accord mais
est-ce que ça sert vraiment à quelque
chose est-ce que le gouvernement peut
dire un million un million et demi bravo
c'est bien mais nous on continue et ça
nous intéresse assez peu en tout cas
pour le moment de la ligne du
gouvernement c'est de dire face à la rue
nous maintenons notre projet il est
vital il est nécessaire pour sauver le
système des retraites on a vu que la
rhétorique du bilan là-dessus un peu
changé ces derniers jours et peut-être
sous le coup de la prière mobilisation
souvenez vous ça n'est un sommeil le
gouvernement disait c'est une réforme
nécessaire et juste le gouvernement
tentait de convaincre l'opinion de la
justice
inclut incluse dans son projet de loi
ces derniers jours forcent de constater
que l'exécutif parle plutôt de nécessité
du projet il s'est bien rendu compte
qu'il était difficile de convaincre
l'opinion majoritairement opposée à
cette réforme de la justice de son
projet de loi on a changé un petit peu
la sémantique alors il y a la rue puis
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai fait mes
comptes les comptes ne sont pas très
bons pour le gouvernement une quinzaine
de députés de la majorité vous me dites
si je me trompe pourrait ne pas voter le
texte entre 10 et 15 à ce stade une
vingtaine de LR entière 62 c'est ça une
vingtaine de LR serait contre où
s'absciendrait il faut 289 fois et si on
fait ce calcul là ça fait
297,889
c'est très serré et c'est ça compliqué
à ce stade d'imaginer une adoption de ce
texte sans recours au 49,3 alors ce
n'est pas un problème pour l'exécutif
puisque
[Musique]
notre Constitution il a un 49-3 sous le
coude par an mais ce texte là qui est un
texte budgétaire n'est pas concerné et
donc il peut utiliser à l'envie des 49-3
sur ce texte budgétaire par lequel il
fait passer la réforme donc ce n'est pas
un problème de ce point de vue là pour
le gouvernement le problème c'est plutôt
l'acceptabilité est-ce qu'il y a un
risque
un recours aux 49-3 durcisse davantage
les oppositions et la mobilisation et
c'est la question je me pose des
millions de millions en tout cas un
million un million et demi de Français
dans la rue
un parlement qui vote contre en tout cas
qui est contre ce
qui n'aurait même pas l'occasion de
voter qui serait plutôt en défaveur de
cette réforme est-ce que c'est une
certaine manière un peu
anti-démocratique alors je sais Emmanuel
Macron a été élu il a la légitimité des
urnes mais quand même un 49-3 face à une
rue qui visiblement ne veut pas de cette
région les oppositions insoumises
socialiste écologiste et du
rassemblement national ont déjà prévu de
répliquer sur ce terrain là du passage
en force en cas d'utilisation du 49-3
forcée de constater que cette
argumentaire de du régime qui qui passe
en force du président autoritaire pourra
être déployé à l'envie par les
oppositions si le gouvernement par
rapport à cette arme là et le
gouvernement on est conscient j'ai quand
même une interrogation vous me dites le
problème ce serait l'utilisation du 49-3
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un autre
problème parce que là en son sein Macron
au sein de sa majorité il a des des
frondeurs alors rendez-vous compte on a
un président de la République qui est
privé de majorité absolue déjà et en
plus de cette situation est compliquée
pour lui doit affronter des oppositions
des réticences des réserves en interne
qui était anciennement ministres je
pense à barbara Pompili qui la première
a dit je en l'état je pourrais ne pas
voter ce texte
absolument laissant donc la porte
ouverte à une abstention ou à un vote
contre ce qui est étonnant également
dans la majorité quand on regarde de
près c'est l'abstention ou le vote
contre potentiel de député horizon
groupe d'Edouard Philippe très étonnant
quand on sait que c'est un peu différent
mais là dessus sur la réforme des
retraites
systémique alors Édouard Philippe en
effet avait porté à une réforme
systémique passage à un régime universel
à point c'est en 2019 ces dernières
années ces derniers mois il s'est fait
toutefois l'écho d'une volonté plus
forte de modifier la mesure d'âge et de
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite ce
qui était tendance à de voir que
certains dans son groupe parlementaire
ne le suivent pas là-dessus et ça
c'était inattendu pour le gouvernement
on continue d'analyser
la période politique parce que c'est
parfois compliqué pour Emmanuel Macron
en ce moment il y a des mondes dans la
rue il a une Assemblée nationale loin
d'être acquise à sa cause je croyais que
c'était fait lorsque Éric Ciotti le
président DLR et Olivier Marleix le
président DLR à l'Assemblée avait
publiquement validé leur attention de
voter pour cette pour cette réforme
c'est pas fait du tout ils ont pas la
main les LR sur sur leurs hommes et
leurs femmes à l'Assemblée nationale
alors ce qu'on observe depuis le début
de cette nouvelle législature c'est
qu'une partie du groupe les républicains
ne s'intéressent pas aux consignes qui
sont données plus haut certains
considèrent qu'ils sont élus depuis
longtemps qui doivent d'abord rendre des
comptes à leurs électeurs c'est quelque
chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier dans ce
contexte là c'est qu'on a des députés
qui sont élus dans des circonscriptions
et d'une circonscription à l'autre on a
des réalités sociales parfois très
différentes j'avais un député horizon
justement au téléphone il y a il y a
quelques jours qui lui vient d'une
circonscription populaire et qui me
disait c'est difficile de vendre une
réforme des des retraites quand on est
face à des habitants qui sont des
ouvriers notamment et donc il ne faut
pas perdre de vue la dimension parfois
locale qui peut dicter un vote national
c'est le cas bien sûr pour une partie
des députés les républicains on pense
Aurélien Pradier notamment hein qui
était candidat à la présidence des des
LR et alors une question si le
gouvernement décide de ne pas utiliser
le 49-3 ce qui paraît risqué mais ça
peut cesser pourquoi pas après tout pour
le garder sur le coup de ce 49-3 pour
l'utiliser d'autres d'autres lois et que
l'assemblée votre contre est-ce que
c'est terminé à ce moment-là c'est fini
on peut pas faire passer le n'oubliez
pas le Sénat ah alors deuxième chambre
du Parlement
qui a voté ces dernières années
plusieurs amendements qui après n'était
pas retenu mais pour montrer qu'il était
favorable à un allongement de de la
durée de cotisation voter un amendement
chaque année donc le Sénat voit d'un œil
plutôt favorable cette réforme des
retraites avec cette mesure d'âge et cet
allongement de la durée de cotisation et
donc le Sénat pourra adopter ce texte
mais c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui le
dernier mot et donc il faudra que ce
texte soit adopté Infiné par l'Assemblée
nationale donc le gouvernement
parfois de la tambouille parlementaire
ce que le gouvernement pourrait tenter
de le faire passer 149-3 une première
fois l'Assemblée nationale s'il ne passe
pas il y a au Sénat et lorsqu'il revient
à faire utiliser le 49-3 ça c'est
absolument ouais d'accord
vous voulez donner
j'ai une dernière question après je vous
libère le risque parlez-moi de cet
article 47 1 parce qu'on parle beaucoup
du 49-3 qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
affaire alors cet article
47,1 c'est un article de la Constitution
qui dont on a beaucoup entendu parler
c'est ces dernières semaines et qui
permet à l'exécutif
définitivement par par l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est un recours aussi à la
main du gouvernement nous verrons le
gouvernement à plusieurs options ça
commence quand définitivement alors en
commission ça a commencé lundi et à
partir du 6 février dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale je sais que vous
suivrez avec beaucoup d'attention les
débats évidemment et je sais que le
service politique viendra nous voir
également merci beaucoup merci à vous on
fait un tour par la manifestation
Timothée delaime racontez-moi ce qu'il
se passe autour de vous et vous êtes à
l'arrêt encore ça n'avance plus
dites-moi
on entend pas Timothée delaime bon c'est
pas très grave vous savez ce qu'on va
faire on va regarder pendant quelques
secondes ce qu'il se passe dans la
manifestation on essaie de s'imprégner
de l'ambiance
je demande à Ryan Becker est-ce qu'on
peut avoir ça et puis on vient dans un
instant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu nous installer avec
marylisot bonjour Marie
rédactrice en chef du service écho
économie du Figaro dans un instant j'ai
plein de questions mais d'abord on va
dans la manifestation Timothée delaime
on la retrouvée vous êtes encore à
l'arrêt cette manifestation n'avance pas
à décidément
alors précisément Thibault nous avons
temporisé un petit peu avec Julien
Leclerc parce que je vous le disais
cette foule qui n'était pas très compact
qui était assez étalé le cortège qui est
effectivement très étalé puisque les
policiers qui sont au tout début du
cortège se trouve eux au niveau de la
place Montparnasse au moment où je vous
parle ça ce sont des informations qui
nous sont communiquées par des
journalistes du Figaro qui sont donc à
l'avant du cortège nous avec Julien
Leclerc nous avons un petit peu
temporisé nous avons un petit peu
attendu nous sommes actuellement au
niveau de Port-Royal vous le voyez sur
ma gauche le cortège qui ici est
beaucoup plus compact que tout à l'heure
avec ces manifestants qui sont en train
et bien de défiler assez lentement
effectivement et puis certains qui sont
ici à l'arrêt qui regardent le cortège
s'avancer c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez l'impression que le cortège
n'avance plus c'est simplement parce que
nous nous sommes un petit peu décalé
mais le cortège continue de s'avancer si
c'est assez lent et ici et bien
évidemment des slogans des pancartes des
drapeaux nous cherchons toujours tant
bien que mal un étudiant on voudrait lui
demander pourquoi et bien il manifeste
pourquoi il est con cette réforme nous
en avons croisé quelques-uns assez peu
mais voilà ils vont pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions continuez de
chercher puis on vient vers vous on vous
signale dès que dès qu'on en trouve
on en recherche alors Timothée bon acte
2 Marie Viso moment décisif ou pas
encore bah en tout cas maman
supplémentaire on était il y a 12 jours
ici à la même on savait qu'il y avait
quand même une deuxième journée qui
était en préparation
moment décisif à la fois oui et non on
les on entend la les syndicats depuis ce
midi dire c'est une belle journée de
mobilisation on est au moins aussi
nombreux que la dernière fois bon
c'est discuté et c'est discutable on
pourra parler je leur donne raison sur
un point tous les chiffres qui nous
remontent de région pour l'instant
montre une légère hausse dans à peu près
toutes les villes alors on a
effectivement des chiffres globaux qui
montrent des légères hausses après quand
on prend
par taux de participation des grévistes
bah là on est on est vraiment nettement
en dessous il y aurait plus de monde
dans la rue et moi de monde en grève là
il y a des chiffres un peu compilés qui
viennent de sortir bienvenue avec mes
antisèches dans l'éducation il y avait
38% de grévistes il y a 12 jours ils ne
sont plus que 25,9 donc c'est quand même
c'est une bonne signification
les cheminots ils étaient 46 % ils sont
plus que 36 10 points de moins c'est
beaucoup aussi dans un contexte de grève
de réforme pardon qui les concerne dans
la fonction publique on est passé de 28
à 19 enfin voilà les dans l'énergie on
est passé de 5 ans de 65 à 55
donc voilà vraisemblablement il y a
moins de grévistes
qui apparaissent dans les chiffres de
métro plus de TGV par exemple donc ça
montre qu'il y a plus de gens qui
travaillent alors les métros pour
l'avoir pris ce matin
il faut aller sur les lignes
automatiques qui qui sont vides il y a
personne les gens se sont organisés
organisé leur télétravail aujourd'hui
mais le reste ça marche pas bien non bon
est-ce qu'on a de nouveaux secteurs qui
seraient entrés dans la danse on dit
souvent allez dès que le privé se met en
grève là ça devient chaud pour le
gouvernement là c'est pas le cas pour
l'instant alors c'est une bonne question
et d'ailleurs c'est un
argument des
syndicalement il n'y ait pas une
profession plus représentée que les
autres c'est à dire que ce n'est pas une
manifestation sont pas des
revendications catégorielles c'est à
dire que il y a tout le monde
il n'y a pas que les cheminots
et en ça ils sont contents les syndicats
ça apparaît comme la manifestation de
tout de tous les Français donc non il y
a pas il y a pas un métier qui sort plus
la tête la tête que l'autre en tout cas
pas pour l'un pas pour l'instant
racontez-moi que s'est-il passé depuis
la dernière manifestation du 19 janvier
pourquoi un temps aussi long
choix
je trouve qui a été discuté entre les
syndicats entre ceux qui voulaient
rebondir très vite sur la manifestation
d'y à 12 jours
qu'on souffle enfin souffler sur les
charbons ardents et se dire allez on
repart tout de suite la CFDT était
beaucoup plus dans organisons quelque
chose de construit d'organiser ne nous
laissons pas commencer par
les bases les violences faisons les
choses correctement et nous mobiliserons
davantage voilà c'est cette option là
qui a été qui a été retenue
entre temps alors certains syndicats
je vous dirais pas les calmer ce plan de
n'avoir eu plus aucune nouvelle du
gouvernement c'est à dire que ça a été
non je vous dirai pas lesquels
mais il y aurait eu en tout cas envers
certains un silence radio c'est-à-dire
on discute plus
intéressant c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
le gouvernement estime que c'est sur la
table et que s'il négociation il doit y
avoir ce sera dans le cadre du Parlement
et qu'on n'est pas entre deux journées
de manifestation pour
faire du donnant donnant et donc
finalement ce serait le gouvernement qui
dure si le ton à ce moment-là allez-y
vous êtes un mignon un million et demi 2
millions 3 millions dans la rue il est
dans son rôle lâché entre deux journées
de manifestations
ça l'aurait mis en
en considérable position de faiblesse
cette phrase ce dimanche Elizabeth borne
les 64 ans ne sont plus négociables vous
connaissez bien les syndicats est-ce que
ça les a braqué et est-ce que ça va dans
le sens de ce que vous venez de me dire
que vous parle plus s'attendre parce
qu'elles disent autre chose
ils savent et a fortiori avant cette
journée cette deuxième journée de
manifestation ils savent que les 65 ans
c'est le totem du gouvernement c'est
c'est le totem dont il eux ne veulent
pas mais aujourd'hui voilà il est 64 64
pardon ça c'est sûr
ils sont revenus à 64 justement pour le
faire passer pour pour le rendre
acceptable à la fois politiquement
et auprès des syndicats justement bon
nous verrons ce qu'il en est est-ce que
les syndicats se braquent avoir tiens
Timothée justement vous êtes avec un
manifestant visiblement non je ne sais
pas vous allez me dire
qu'en est-il ce qu'il se braque les
syndicats après la phrase d'Elizabeth
borne ce weekend
oui avec un manifestant qui est venu
exprès pour pour cette mobilisation ces
journées de mobilisation aujourd'hui on
parlait à l'instant en plateau de
l'attitude des syndicats ensuite aux
propos de Elisabeth borde qui dit que
les 64 ans c'est non négociable et ce
qui se braque les syndicats je pense que
oui ce braque pas il défend de vraiment
les intérêts de leurs syndiquer ils ont
raison de de montrer qu'il ne souhaite
pas
revenir sur les sur les négociations qui
qui sont fermes ils ont raison pardon de
rester ferme sur ces négociations
d'après ce que j'ai compris en écoutant
parler France Culture il y a pas eu
beaucoup de négociations
alors vous avez vous avez reçu un
message vous me disiez à l'instant de
votre caisse de retraite de quoi il
s'agit un message qui vous a un petit
peu agacé je crois dites-nous un petit
peu voilà alors je suis retraité depuis
deux ans du travail social j'ai une
retraite confortable je vais le dire
quand même et je reçois ce texte qui me
dit que d'un côté il y a une évolution
des prélèvements sociaux m'ont évolution
et bien choisi mais surtout on me dit
très simplement que votre retraite sera
donc réduit voilà ce que me dit il y a
quelques jours bon alors c'est pas en
lien direct avec cette réforme des
retraites mais ça peut-être est-ce que
c'est pour cette raison que vous êtes
venu manifester aujourd'hui ou bien
c'était prévu déjà de prévu mais je vous
dis honnêtement ça m'a un peu motivé à
venir voir quand même accompagner tout
le monde qui vient réclamer quand même
des droits normaux pas des cette
retraite d'après ce que disent certains
chercheurs certains c'est pas que le que
la porte des syndicats ne sera pas tout
à fait juste
on disait vous êtes déjà retraités vous
n'êtes donc pas concerné directement par
cette réforme des retraites mais
pourquoi alors êtes-vous là aujourd'hui
vous pensez aux générations futures
c'est ça tout à fait puis à ceux qui ont
des travaux difficiles parce que on
oublie que c'est vrai que l'âge a
augmenté en fait notre notre
longueur de vie est plus longue mais il
y a qu'un des travaux qui sont très
difficiles parce que en particulier je
passe aux enseignants imaginez-vous un
enseignant de 64 ans s'occupant d'une
classe de CM2 bon avec tout ce que les
enfants maintenant de nouveaux problèmes
par rapport et une vingtaine d'années
c'est vrai que se retrouver enseigné en
62 ans ou même dans un collège avec des
adolescents quand même qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont un vocabulaire
quand même faut dire assez fleuri bah
c'est quand même quelque chose de
difficilement envisageable pour certains
retraités à venir est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas un affaiblissement du
mouvement après la forte mobilisation du
19 janvier dernier oui ça ça peut
arriver puisque les vacances de février
sont pas loin mais je pense que là quand
même l'attitude du président et de la
première ministre qui est une ancienne
socialiste directrice de cabinet en plus
de socialiste c'est quand même un peu de
la provocation voilà donc je pense que
ça va je pense je suis pas ni
politologue ni je fréquente pas tous ces
milieux là mais je pense vraiment que
regarder autour de nous on a quand même
des gens très motivés et d'un certain
âge on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'attitude des syndicats est-ce que vous
pensez que le mouvement peut
s'endurcir qu'est-ce que vous pensez par
exemple de certaines situations de
blocage de grève perlées à répétition
est-ce que c'est une éventualité est-ce
que c'est souhaitable selon vous alors
bien entendu à partir du moment où les
salariés eux-mêmes sont très impactés
par des grèves surprises c'est vrai que
ça risque d'amener une réaction négative
mais je pense que quand même il y a plus
que ces syndicats pour quand même
défendre une partie de la population
même si les gens ne sont pas syndiqués
voilà Thibault pour pour cette interview
c'est commentaire alors que le cortège
continue et bien de s'avancer les
ballons maintenant des syndicats qui se
rapprochent de nous ça veut dire que le
fond du cortège commence à arriver nous
sommes au niveau de Port-Royal on va
maintenant s'avancer pour voir ce qui se
passe à l'avant de ce cortège du de la
manifestation et puis je vais vous
demander de vous arrêter devant la
rotonde vous savez c'est ce restaurant
dans lequel Emmanuel Macron avait fêté
sa victoire
pas encore mais en tout cas sa première
place au soir du premier tour de la
présidentielle en 2017 on imagine qu'il
pourrait y avoir des événements là-bas
on sait qu'il y a eu un appel de
certains syndicat de certaines
confédérations à des actes plus forts
ciblés des coupures d'électricité est-ce
que
la tête de la CGT par exemple craint que
sa base de la dépasse alors ça c'est
vrai que c'est un problème pour les pour
les syndicats en tout cas au niveau
central eux ils sont ils sont pas alors
la CGT bon il faudra porter d'iliance
mais là au niveau central ils sont pas
pour des actions violentes coup de poing
et effectivement c'est ce font-ils
dépasser par des bases plus violentes on
a vu
une radicalisation de fédération
Confédération
c'est le danger c'est le danger les
syndicats y jouent ils jouent au
paradoxal quand j'écoute Philippe
Martinez il dit bon non non on est on ne
soutient pas mais en tout cas il ne les
arrête pas non plus
de de d'essaye de trouver un discours un
discours qui est qui est balancé sans
condamner
un homme dangereux finalement mais en
étant en respectant l'incendie de la
gare de l'Est que ça vienne de alors
il s'avéra devrait s'avérer c'est pas
eux voilà que l'histoire est assez
compliqué mais ils ont eu peur que ça
vienne de de d'une base qui les aurait
vraiment dépassé avec cet événement
violent qui n'avait franchement pas lieu
d'être
il joue gros aujourd'hui dans la mesure
où les syndicats veulent montrer qu'ils
ont encore la main sur les
manifestations nationales qui savent les
organiser que jusqu'au bout ils vont
espérer qu'il y ait pas de violence
alors là c'est un petit peu plus violent
les images que il y a 12 jours à la même
heure on est en train de s'en rendre
compte en même temps qu'on le voit
pas d'image pas de violence pure et dur
mais on sent une tension très clairement
vous avez raison Marie et c'est ce que
nous disent Vincent roseron et Timothée
Hélène sur place on avait moins d'images
de ces CRS de de ces policiers en
permanence voilà ça on l'avait beaucoup
moins donc voilà les syndicats ils
veulent que leur au niveau central avec
la CFTC c'est pas les plus radicaux en
plus ils sont ils sont dans le cortège
bleu effectivement
euh donc il y a un enjeu pour les
syndicats de montrer que c'est les
patrons de la manifester la patron les
patrons des mouvements et Gérald
Darmanin leur ami d'une certaine manière
la pression les remerciant je sais pas
si vous avez hier il a pris la parole en
disant c'est bien c'est des
manifestations qui sont tenues à tenir
les manifestations ce genre de petites
phrases bon on va on verra la suite de
la manifestation et puisqu'il se passe
dans les différentes confédérations
la première ministre des 64 ans ne sont
pas négociables bon ça en a parlé mais
les 64 ans c'est 95% de la réforme
qu'est-ce qu'il y a à négocier
maintenant
alors oui alors les 64 ans c'est le cœur
de la France on parle quasiment que de
ça je pense que les gens qui ne suivent
pas de pré cette histoire se disent on
veut me faire partir plus tard la
retraite mais c'est tout alors
ce qui reste à négocier pas grand chose
parce que on était parlé la semaine
dernière le gouvernement explique qu'il
avait deux stratégies pour cette réforme
des retraites soit des mettre sur la
table une réforme trop dure entre
guillemets et se dire on va faire du don
en donnant et on va lâcher des choses
soit mettre sur la table une réforme
équilibrée et tout en considérant qu'il
y a plus rien à bouger et donc beaucoup
plus compliqué dans les dans les
discussions donc du coup il a opté donc
pour cette deuxième stratégie sur la
table la réforme qui l'estime l'aime
être la bonne et la réforme équilibrée
des toutes petites choses vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure avec Marie-Cécile
Renaud de la question des femmes des
trimestres des femmes il va y avoir des
discussions là-dessus vous savez les
femmes ont eu trimestre certaines femmes
qui auraient qui aurait la possibilité
parce qu'elles ont assez de trimestre de
partir plutôt à la retraite seront
obligés d'avoir des trimestres en plus
qui ne servent à rien parce qu'elles
doivent partir à 64 ans
et si je vous parle d'un cas tout à fait
hypothétique qui ne ressemblerait à
personne que nous ne pourrions connaître
d'une femme qui a deux enfants et qui
aurait pu partir à 62 ans
j'ai l'impression que je connais je
connais ce gars voilà il partira cette
femme à 64 ans et voilà c'est les femmes
sont mais bon ça c'est pour des
carrières complètes enfin vous le voilà
vous en avez parlé parlé tout à l'heure
il y aura peut-être des petites choses
sur les sur les femmes mais vraiment pas
grand chose le gouvernement il a un
autre argument qui est de dire avant
notre réforme les femmes partaient plus
tard à la retraite que les hommes après
la réforme compte tenu de tout un tas
d'autres dispositifs qu'on va mettre en
place elles vont partir à la retraite
avant les hommes là où ils peuvent
bouger un tout petit peu dans ce qu'on a
cru comprendre c'est sur le dispositif
carrière longue ils ont conscience que
de ne pas mettre dans les carrières
longues les salariés qui ont commencé à
travailler à 20 ans ça pose un petit
problème là-dessus ça peut bouger tout
ça dans un instant j'ai un premier
chiffre à vous donner c'est celui de la
C qui revendique à Paris elle a un petit
Paris je vous cache le chiffre
combien
ils ont dit tout à l'heure on est au
moins autant que la dernière fois
500 mille manifestants selon la CGT
Vincent roseron
mille manifestants de la CGT dans le
cortège parisien
alors je alors
du cortège en tout cas 500 000 est-ce
que vous pensez qu'on qu'on atteint ce
chiffre aujourd'hui c'est ce qui a été
annoncé par la suite
qu'il y a vu l'attente qu'on a fait déjà
je crois qu'il y a beaucoup plus parce
qu'il y a sur les trottoirs dans la rue
aussi en plein milieu il y a beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde salut
gouvernement il comprend pas il est
vraiment absurde oui alors juste pour
appeler parce qu'effectivement on est à
au point de départ de la manif et depuis
deux heures ça a pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup avancé pourquoi parce que c'est
important pour vous d'être ici
aujourd'hui vous étiez déjà là le 19
janvier vous me disiez pourrais-je avoir
de là aujourd'hui aussi bah c'est pour
nous revendications la retraite ça a
fait déjà des années des années
on grand-père
mon père aussi il s'est battu c'est pas
avec un gouvernement de droite qui va
nous faire plier comme on dit la rue a
pas le droit de décider c'est la rue qui
est en train de décider
justement ils avaient de vendre ce
weekend a dit je 64 ans c'était pas de
négociable vous pensez pouvoir les faire
reculer aujourd'hui alors board et le
gouvernement eux ils ont beaucoup plus
d'argent que les gens qui sont
actuellement dans la rue eux pour leur
retraite ils sont en train de l'avoir
déjà actuellement et il touche avec les
royalties avec la richesse ils ont
beaucoup plus pour une retraite pour eux
plus tard ils auront pas de souci mais
pour nous même moi mon âge 55 ans
faudrait que je travaille jusqu'à 67 ans
être avec les cheveux non
je les invite à aller travailler dans
les établissements scolaires après ils
verront c'est quoi du travail pénible
parce que je travaille pénible ils
disent oui l'armée la police d'accord
c'est ils encadre le gouvernement les
gens qui avaient manifs mais c'est eux
qui font des dégâts aussi vous êtes
enseignant vous non je suis agent de
service je suis agent d'accueil dans un
établissement scolaire
agression on envoie tout le temps
on imagine je discutais avec d'autres
enseignants qui disent que voilà ce sont
164 ans voire plus vieux il va avoir du
mal à le faire ah oui tout à fait même
pour un jeune qui va commencer à
travailler à 30 ans
plus on va dire 44 ans 45 ans Daniel
cotisé ça fera travailler jusqu'à 70 ans
presque non c'est un faisable moi j'ai
des enfants ils vont faire des études à
commencer à travailler à 27 ans
je la vois mal à travailler jusqu'à 70
ans
vous avez vu un changement justement
dans ce que vous disiez sur les
conditions de travail sur les agressions
le travail je vais pas être méchant on a
rajouté encore plus de plus en plus mais
le soleil il diminue vous nous dit oh on
vous donne d'un côté mais nous reprenne
de l'autre en se dire le salaire est
toujours en baisse hélas et c'est qui
qui trinque c'est toujours le petit le
riche Noël lui il s'en met plein dans
les poches que nous non essayons de
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui
merci merci Vincent roseron je vous
voyais réagir difficile de expliquer aux
Français aux manifestants aux gens
syndiqués cette réforme des retraites
de convictions il est plein de sincérité
dans ce qu'il dit
il y a beaucoup d'erreurs aussi dans ce
qu'il dit donc ce qui veut dire que les
choses sont difficiles à expliquer
[Musique]
voilà on est un petit peu désemparé
devant un témoignage un témoignage comme
ça non ce et par-ci parle avec le cœur
évidemment
et c'est vrai que de on sent il vit de
plus en plus mal son métier il a dit
qu'il avait 55 ans
lui ne se voit pas aller beaucoup plus
loin mais il peut il a l'air très bonne
forme c'est de l'idéologie finalement de
dire qu'il peut pas qui peut pas
travailler 8 ou 9 ans de plus c'est de
l'idéologie de dire aussi à cause des
riches mon salaire baisse enfin voilà
c'est c'est très compliqué parce que je
pense que bon nombre de Français
l'entendent Emmanuel Macron a proposé un
certain nombre de réformes sans doute a
juste titre en essayant d'alléger par
exemple les cotisations des patrons en
enlevant l'ISF et aujourd'hui c'est la
manière le revenu aussi a baissé les
cotisations ses cotisations se sont
blessés aussi je pense que on en parle
plus comme
quelque chose de de qu'il connaît mal
certainement mais en tout cas lui il le
traduit affectivement par mon salaire
baisse
je pense que c'est factuellement ça
n'est factuellement pas le cas ou alors
il travaille moins d'heures par semaine
ou alors voilà chaque personnalité aussi
à une histoire et mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr et ça reflète en tout cas un
manque certains de
je dirais de compréhension et de
pédagogie de la part de l'exécutif quand
il mène des réformes qui ont pour
vocation de ramener du pouvoir d'achat
aux gens
vous aviez raison il y a l'instant vous
me disiez on n'avait pas vu ces images
la semaine dernière surtout pas à cette
heure-ci visiblement un peu d'agitation
foule un peu dispersée et des gaz
lacrymogènes on essaiera de retrouver
Timothée Delam dans un instant il est
pas loin de tout ça et il nous
expliquera ce qu'il voit en espérant là
aussi que la manifestation ne dégénère
pas j'ai entendu parler d'une clause de
revoyure c'est possible ça on dit 64 ans
on vote quatre ans mais si la
conjoncture est pas mauvaise dans
quelques années on reviendra 63 alors si
la conjoncture n'est pas mauvaise ou si
les effets ne sont pas ceux qu'on avait
anticipé ou si les effets sont plus
importants voilà c'est un truc
d'économiste ça de de faire des clauses
de voyeur c'est à dire regardons
concrètement les effets d'une réforme
qu'on a mis en place lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
fait des projections parce que j'imagine
on dit qu'on fait des économies avec
cette réforme mais il y a des courbes
c'est ça prévision haute prévisions
basse croissance
en fonction de voilà il y a tout un tas
de scénarios et paramètres avec lequel
on crée un scénario central et puis on a
des fourchettes hautes et des
fourchettes basses la clause d'envoyeur
elle permet de voir où on se situe dans
la dans la fourchette une fois que la
réforme est mise en œuvre d'accord
finalement c'est du bon sens de faire
des clauses parce que c'est un peu
facile pour le gouvernement parce qu'ils
pas de 2028 Emmanuel Macron sera plus là
alors c'est toujours
redonner la patate chaude au suivant
bon est-ce qu'on va pouvoir retrouver
Timothée on va me dire bon oui ça y est
Timothée dites-moi tout je vois que il y
a une forme de nuage derrière vous un
nuage de lacrymo
[Musique]
oui un nuage de lacrymogène de gaz
lacrymogène Thibault voilà vous le voyez
juste ici quelques
manifestants ou en tous les cas
personne présente ici est-ce qu'on peut
parler de manifestants de Black Box je
ne sais pas dans tous les cas voilà
cette cette
enceinte de la Société Générale qui a
été et qui a été cassé et donc les
policiers qui ont dû couper le cortège
en deux qui ont dû stopper arrêter le
cortège qui ont envoyé des quelques gaz
lacrymogènes c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a eu un moment d'atropoint
un moment avec beaucoup de sifflet dans
l'air avec également des slogans tout le
monde déteste la police par exemple il y
a un moment de grande tension ici même
si le calme il faut le dire et revenu le
cortège qui a pu reprendre et vous le
voyez ici ce cordon de CRS nous sommes
au niveau donc toujours boulevard du
Montparnasse au niveau de la rue
Campagne Première
vous me parliez tout à l'heure Thibault
de se barre de la rotonde où Emmanuel
Macron a ses habitudes nous ne sommes
pas encore parvenus se trouve à une
centaine de mètres de nous donc toujours
au niveau du boulevard Montparnasse
quelques gaz lacrymogène à un moment de
grande tension de grande confusion même
si le calme vient de revenir ici bon
tant mieux tant mieux Timothée on va
vers vous faites attention à quoi ça
sert honnêtement tout ça évidemment pas
les cas les casseurs tout ça c'est
manifestation est-ce que le gouvernement
regarde ça d'un œil un peu hautain en se
disant
c'est quand même une manifestation de
force entre guillemets à quoi ça sert
2010 il y avait autant de monde dans la
rue le gouvernement n'avait pas reculé
2019 le covid a arrêté cette réforme des
retraites systémique à l'époque mais le
gouvernement ne semblait pas être très
reculé à quoi ça sert alors je pense que
ça sert pas à rien d'ailleurs je
vous proposerai de poser cette question
à un des syndicats vous verrez comment
vous seriez reçus
qui leur plaisent pas il semble ils sont
pas de nous envoyer bien promener
là c'est pas terrible les images on les
découvre direct devant la rotonde
qui est le symbole justement des riches
que que notre manifestant dénonce est
tout à l'heure non non ça sert pas à
rien
ça sert pas à rien parce que c'est tout
simplement c'est la démocratie les
syndicats s'expriment les syndications
dans la rue les Français sont dans la
rue
vont obtenir des petites améliorations
dont on parlait dont on parlait tout à
l'heure
voilà c'est la liberté d'expression
est-ce que il ne faudrait pas si vous
étiez conseillère de syndicats
entrer dans une grève plus longue pas
étalé comme ça espacer les mouvements et
surtout bloquer le pays plutôt que de
descendre dans la rue alors débats
donc là le débat c'est est-ce qu'on fait
quelque chose pareil très vite et on se
mène où est-ce qu'on fait quelque chose
de plus d'organisé le week-end il y a
une question sur le week-end la CFDT
voudrait le week-end parce que c'est
lourd pour les gens de poser une journée
de grève c'est un journée de salaire en
moi ou ou du de la RTT je discutais
l'autre jour avec un chef d'entreprise
dans mon entreprise c'est 50% de gens
qui posent des jours de grève et 50% de
gens qui posent une journée de RTT c'est
intéressant dans les chiffres que vous
me donniez en arrivant tout à l'heure il
y a peut-être des gens qui posent des
jours de congés ou de RTT et donc mais
mais ces jours de RTT on peut pas les
poser en déchaînement d'où cette
hypothèse éventuellement d'une d'une
journée un week-end qui permettra
davantage de français de venir
donc la suite voilà pareil ils vont se
retrouver ce soir les syndicats ils sont
c'est un peu à un moment charnière
va-t-il y avoir scission ou pas scission
dans leur stratégie
entre ceux qui veulent rester dur
bloquer la France on mettait les
Français
et ceux qui veulent le faire constructif
voilà on est là pour manifester pour
exprimer des revendications mais on
n'est pas là pour
donc c'est ce soir qu'on aura des
réponses
ce soir en fin de journée ils vont se
retrouver quelle stratégie adopter
adoptée pour la suite
donc on sera très vite dans la soirée
sauf si ça m'aide vraiment pas d'accord
ça pourra prendre un peu plus un peu
plus de temps je me souviens plus
qu'elle était votre question à l'origine
la prochaine étape et surtout ce qu'il
quelle stratégie adopté
merci beaucoup merci de m'avoir
accompagné je vous laisse ce qu'on va
faire on va rester un moment sur ces
images parce que vous avez raison c'est
un moment un peu tendu visiblement le
cortège qui avance lentement qui
s'approche de Montparnasse qui passe
devant la rotonde vous le savez c'est ce
restaurant dans lequel Emmanuel Macron
avait dîné au soir du premier tour avec
de nombreuses personnalités qui est une
sorte de
Fouquet macronien c'est ça on reste avec
ces images puis on rentre dans un
instant
[Musique]
alors
vas-y match pour ce soir on va pas qu'on
a connu
[Musique]
face à la route
déjà son centre pour réfléchir mais nous
on est venu en direct si vous n'en
joignez sur Youtube avec cette
manifestation pour cette deuxième
journée de grève contre la réforme des
retraites le cortège s'est dénoncé Place
d'Italie c'était aux alentours de 14h ça
a pris du temps il y avait du monde et
visiblement il s'approche désormais de
Montparnasse nous sommes devant la
rotonde vous savez c'est ce restaurant
dans lequel Emmanuel Macron avait dîné
au soir du 1er tour ça avait fait
polémique c'est devenu un symbole de la
macronie et il y a une tension autour de
ce restaurant vous me confirmez
timothélem
tout à fait Thibault une tension même si
ça vient de redescendre un petit peu
mais il y a eu quelques gaz lacrymogènes
qui ont été lancés par les la
gendarmerie nationale
voilà un moment de de tension on sent
que le mouvement voilà il y a des de
plus en plus de débris de vert par terre
il y a quelques poubelles qui sont
incendiées pour l'instant
l'ambiance l'atmosphère reste maîtrisée
par les forces de l'ordre mais on sent
clairement que il y a une ambiance
vraiment tendue de plus en plus tendue
en tout cas au fur et à mesure que le
cortège avance nous sommes pour le
moment donc à l'angle entre le boulevard
de Montparnasse et le boulevard Raspail
au niveau des biens de ce bar-restaurant
la rotonde vous le voyez sur ces images
de Julien Leclerc un cordon et bien de
membres de la gendarmerie nationale et
qui sont là pour protéger
l'établissement
et on voit vraiment un contraste assez
fort entre eux et bien certains qui sont
ici pour manifester dans le calme pour
manifester leur revendications et puis
d'autres qui sont ici clairement dans
une dans la avec la volonté et bien de
faire preuve de violence de
d'interpeller d'invectiver les policiers
comme c'est le cas d'ailleurs à quelques
mètres de nous avec un homme qui
s'adresse voilà en investivant les les
gendarmes voilà vous le voyez
une vraie tension aux tensions dans
l'air avec un mouvement d'ailleurs là à
l'instant sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc là cette fois-ci c'est la police
nationale et qui intervient au niveau
d'un d'un groupe là-bas de personnes qui
sait constitué au niveau du boulevard
Raspail on a du mal à voir précisément
ce qu'il se passe en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que l'ambiance est assez
tendue pour le moment
merci merci Timothée delhem on va
continuer à suivre ces images
pour l'instant de gros dégâts on n'a pas
vu d'image de de bagarres véritables
entre force de l'ordre et potentiel
manifestants mais des tensions qui
éclatent un peu partout c'est dans
l'atmosphère visiblement vous pouvez
retrouver d'ailleurs sur le sur le
direct du figaro.fr toutes les photos
toutes les images de nos différents
reporters sur place
en tête du cortège parisien sur le
boulevard Montparnasse du gaz
lacrymogène les aigronnades de
désencerclement explose voilà ce que
nous disent nos journalistes sur place
je voudrais qu'on rejoigne Vincent
roseron il est un peu plus en arrière de
ce cortège Vincent est-ce que vous
m'entendez Vincent pour vous c'est du
calme visiblement
oui effectivement alors faut pas
utiliser je peux utiliser une expression
qu'on connaît tous mais effectivement
c'est très calme pour l'instant dans le
cortège à l'arrière du cortège même au
départ du cortège je vais vous montrer
devant moi vous voyez là devant c'est
Place d'Italie en fait là c'est la CGT
qui commençait à maniquer qui a commencé
à descendre qui a commencé son début de
manifestation en fait qui sont bloqués
depuis le début et du coup voilà c'est
la CGT qui descend petit à petit on voit
les camions arriver il y a les pompiers
qui sont venus il y a les pompiers qui
sont qui sont passés en balançant
quelques pétards qui ont un peu troublé
la tranquillité des manifestants mais
c'est à peu près tout pour l'instant de
ce côté là
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron ambiance
bon enfant visiblement de votre côté je
vous donne ce chiffre la CGT qui indique
500 000 manifestants dans les rues de la
capitale dans les rues de Paris
manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites il y avait ils avaient annoncé
400 000 le jeudi 19 janvier les forces
de l'ordre et le ministère de
l'Intérieur tablé plutôt sur sur 80 000
personnes on va essayer de retrouver
Timothée Delam Timothée vous êtes
toujours devant la rotonde le restaurant
préféré d'Emmanuel Macron d'une certaine
manière
visiblement les forces de l'ordre sont
toujours très présentes
je vous confirme Thibault les forces de
l'ordre qui sont toujours très présentes
et qui se font un vectiver par par
certains manifestants beaucoup de monde
un attroupement on a du mal à se faire
de à se faire de la place le cortège qui
peine à avancer et là on est à l'arrêt
pour le moment c'est assez confus en
fait pour tout vous dire on a du mal à
saisir ce qui se passe il y a des
moments d'arrêt des moments où ça repart
d'un coup ce qui est sûr c'est que il y
a clairement de la tension dans l'air
d'ailleurs je viens de me faire insulter
à l'instant mais voilà c'est assez
confus c'est un peu tendu on va essayer
d'avancer voir ce qui se passe à l'avant
du cortège
ouais merci faites attention anti-moto
Delam évidemment la sécurité avant tout
j'ai l'impression que ça densifie un
petit peu désormais autour de vous et je
vois des drapeaux antifascistes
notamment voilà pour pour ce qu'on peut
dire pour l'instant autour de la rotonde
tiens j'essaie de vous donner au fur et
à mesure toutes les dernières
informations merci si vous nous
rejoignez sur Le Figaro.fr sur sur
Youtube on a vu qu'il y avait
une augmentation
forcément significative mais en tout cas
de mobilisation un peu partout en France
c'est le cas à Bordeaux c'est le cas à
Toulouse c'est le cas à Nice par exemple
à Bordeaux alors c'est pas énorme mais
16500 manifestants au plus fort de la
manifestation il y avait 16000 bordelais
dans la rue le 19 janvier voilà pour
pour la ville la ville de Bordeaux voilà
ce sont les chiffres officiels cela ce
sont les chiffres de la préfecture
Vincent roseron vous êtes avec des
syndicats derrière vous en êtes où vous
du cortège parce que il semble s'étaler
tout au long du parcours et c'est un peu
moins dense de votre côté visiblement
n'hésitez pas à Vincent si vous avez un
manifestant une manifestante
et le micro et on essaye de comprendre
les motivations de tous ceux qui sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui un autre chiffre
19,4% de grévise dans la fonction
publique d'État contre 28% le 19 janvier
c'est ce que ce qui a annoncé le
ministère voilà pour pour ces chiffres
la fonction publique territoriale le
taux de grévise c'était en baisse
également à 7,9 contre 11,3 % le 19
janvier le calme est revenu Timothée
delaime je reviens vers vous je sais que
vous êtes en train d'avancer
progressivement vers Montparnasse est-ce
que ça va mieux ou est-ce que la tension
est toujours palpable
[Musique]
ah ça va mieux je sais pas en tout cas
la tension est toujours pas le pape ça
c'est une évidence on a entendu à
l'instant à nouveau des grenades de
désencerclement
grenade de désencerclement gazelle
lacrymogène ce sont les biens utilisées
par les forces de l'ordre pour contenir
les manifestants pour les empêcher de
casser une vitrine comme ça a été le cas
tout à l'heure pour l'instant et vous le
disiez Thibault ça reste contenu on n'a
pas vu de gros gros mouvements de foule
on a pas vu de mouvements d'attroupement
général de batailles généralisé mais
c'est très tendu il y a des petits des
petits moments de tension ici ou là et
vous le voyez ici d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si vous m'entendez c'est le cortège
de la CFTC qui est en train et bien de
passer devant de nous passer devant nous
sommes au niveau toujours sur ce
boulevard du Montparnasse des centaines
de mètres de la place Montparnasse et de
la Tour Montparnasse et ici le calme qui
pour le coup semble être semble être
revenu et voilà le cortège qui continue
qui continue d'avancer et voilà il y a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de policiers de CRS
au niveau de la Rotonde et là on est on
s'est avancé une vingtaine de mètres et
maintenant à nouveau place à la
manifestation et à cette manifestation
qui continue de se dérouler ce cortège
qui avance d'un sur un rythme assez
soutenu là pour le coup
voilà on a pu faire un point avec vous
avec Timothée avec Vincent on a pris le
coup de cette manifestation qui
visiblement est un peu plus tendu que la
semaine dernière même si pour l'instant
pas de gros dégâts sont visibles pas de
confrontation directe ont pu être
observé pour l'instant dans cette
manifestation bonjour Guillaume Tabar
bonjour rédacteur en chef éditorialiste
politique au Figaro acte 2 on y est
est-ce que les syndicats sont en train
de réussir leur deuxième Paris
si l'échelle est de l'ordre de l'ordre
numérique effectivement c'est plutôt
réussi il y a semble-t-il dans toutes
les villes de France un peu plus de
monde qu'il y en avait la dernière fois
sachant que pour la journée du 19
janvier tout le monde avait signalé que
les chiffres avait été importants alors
j'en parle des chiffres à un million
deux pour les syndicats pour les polices
de millions de personnes
on était dans une jauge élevée en tout
cas quel que soit le la référence que
l'on prenne police ou là les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui sont en sensibles
augmentation par rapport à
15 jours même en assez net je pense à
des villes comme comme Marseille ou
selon la police on passe de 25000 à
40000 etc à Paris aussi on a plus de un
peu plus de monde bon donc on peut
encore les chiffres officiels à Paris
pour l'instant en tout cas bon bah oui
ont déjà annoncé 500000 ce ne sera
évidemment pas le chiffre 2 par la
police donc on est quand même sur une
tendance à la hausse il y a un autre
chiffre qu'il faut regarder aussi c'est
celui du taux de grévistes dans
différents secteurs parce que là si on
prend tous les secteurs que là ça baisse
et même ça baisse de manière très
substantielle dans l'éducation nationale
on était au-delà des 50% de grévistes le
19 janvier là on a des taux qui selon le
le niveau collège école ou lycée on est
en gros autour de 25% de de grévistes à
EDF aussi un secteur sensible on était à
plus de 40% maintenant je crois qu'on
est autour de 35%
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
etc voilà on est partout dans quel que
soit la catégorie ou de la fonction
publique ou des conservices publics il y
a moins de grévistes mais plus de monde
dans les rues voilà alors pour l'instant
de cette deuxième variée mobilisation
alors il y a peut-être une application
j'allais dire financière qui est que
poser un jour de grève et bien ça ça a
un coût et que peut-être que ceux qui
voulaient se poser par la grève à cette
réforme des retraite ils se disent que
déjà une journée perdue au mois de
janvier c'est déjà bien on va pas en
rajouter une
deuxième alors
nous donner une explication potentielle
elle disait qu'en discutant avec des
chefs d'entreprise
certains lui disaient que les employés
qui voulaient faire grève prenez un jour
de RTT par exemple il y a ça il y a les
RTT on a entendu aussi ce qui pose aussi
un autre problème mais voir un problème
politique un centre de mairie a commencé
par la Mairie de Paris on choisit de
fermer un simple service ou de laisser
leurs agents aller à l'imager donc
eux ne sont pas comptés puisque c'est
l'Amérique qui décide de fermer les les
services qui ce qui est à mon avis une
démarche
comme ça on peut expliquer
alors et puis aussi il y a aussi
quelques jeunes il y a quelques lycéens
dont on se dit peut-être aussi qu'un
jour de classe il pourrait être en
classe mais bon apparemment un salon qui
sont qui sont dans la rue bon tout ça
fait monter et alors je dis pas ça pour
minorer les chiffres des cortèges qui
sont à l'évidence fournies et nombreux
mais
un million de personnes
pour une manie c'est énorme à l'échelle
du pays ça reste un million de personnes
sur sur plusieurs dizaines de millions
de Français qui
travaillent ou étudient ou sont chez eux
bien sûr que c'est une passée depuis le
19 est-ce qu'on a vraiment négocié
est-ce qu'on a continué le dialogue ou
pas vraiment personne ne s'y attendait
je veux qu'il y a des lignes rouges qui
étaient fixées depuis le début depuis le
début le gouvernement par la voie
d'Elizabeth borne mais aussi de tous les
ministres et même d'Emmanuel Macron
lui-même répète que le principe même de
sale doit savoir un report de l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans et un centre de
dispositif qui qui accompagne ne sont
pas de l'ordre du négociable il y a
d'autres points qui le sont mais
celui-là qui est quand même le cœur de
la réforme n'est pas négociable c'est ça
qui est plutôt rigolo c'est à dire que
honnêtement on demande aux Français
aujourd'hui les 100 prochains français
qui passent dans la rue on leur demande
et sur quoi porte la réforme des
retraites il ne parle que de
l'augmentation de l'âge de départ ils ne
sont pas au courant tout le reste donc
95 % de la réforme se concentre là
dessus et sur un point qui est non
négociable finalement oui et inversement
donc le gouvernement ne veut pas
négocier cette mesure d'âge inversement
les syndicats et là encore depuis le
début disent qu'ils ne veulent même pas
en discuter donc c'est voyez c'est pas
on peut avoir les syndicats ont on
cherchait à faire à faire apparaître
l'exécutif comme étant buté enfermés
dans sa certitude
refusant tout dialogue toute
concertation tout compromis mais eux non
plus n'ont même pas voulu aller sur le
terrain de cette négociation là c'est
leur droit et c'est compréhensible mais
voyez si le refus de l'ED de la
négociation le refus de tout mettre sur
la table et d'en discuter ça n'est pas
uniquement du côté du lavamance c'est
tout autant du côté du côté des
syndicats
d'Elizabeth borne ce week-end donc les
64 ans sont non négociables elle montre
du caractère là Elisabeth borne non on
la connaissait dans la rondeur à appeler
constamment à la concertation alors là
il y a pas de concertation ah je suis
pas sûr que grand monde les connu
vraiment dans la rondeur
dans tous les voilà dans tous les
ministères il est passé dialogue là il y
a plus de dialogue elle le dit
clairement non mais une fois encore il
faut pas confondre dialogue et
négociation et compromiseur c'est le bon
et je rappelle que bien des aspects de
la réforme sont le fruit du dialogue
qu'elle a entretenu et jusqu'au bout
parce que souvenez-vous alors même que
au départ le elle devait présenter ses
propositions le 15 décembre c'est
important c'est-à-dire porter et
Emmanuel Macron on donne encore 15 jours
au dialogue pour pour voir s'il peut
s'il peut aboutir donc je recule le
gouvernement peut-être même on peut
penser qu'il a trop tardé à mettre sur
la table c'est propositions voilà mais
il y a un moment vous savez
on n'est plus dans le dialogue non
personne ne cherche à convaincre
personne le les syndicalistes ne
cherchent plus à convaincre le
gouvernement qu'il ne faut pas faire 64
ans
le gouvernement ne cherche plus à
convaincre les syndicalistes que s'il
faut venir autour de la table pour
négocier donc on est maintenant dans le
symbole et dans le rapport de force
l'arme des uns les syndicats c'est la
rue pour des rayer nous sommes nombreux
nous sommes encore plus nombreux que la
dernière fois notre force c'est la rue
c'est le nombre en face l'arbre du
gouvernement c'est la détermination et
le fait d'avoir rappelé la veille du
manifestation que les 64 ans n'étaient
pas négociables
c'est de manière dire voilà très bien
allez-y mais
n'imaginez pas que notre détermination
puisse être indexée sur le nombre de
manifestants est-ce que cet arbre ce
couteau il est pas un peu émoussé parce
que d'accord il y a la rue le
gouvernement peut faire fi de la rue on
l'a vu en 2010 ça a été le cas on l'a vu
en 2019 la réforme a été arrêtée par le
covid mais ça semble être le cas
mais il y a un problème à l'Assemblée
nationale parce que aujourd'hui il n'est
pas certain que ce texte soit voté à
l'Assemblée nationale non effectivement
à ce jour il n'est pas certain qu'il y
ait une majorité absolue pour pour voter
le texte alors pressé si le gouvernement
aujourd'hui était dans une position plus
comment dire plus plus flou
prête à au concessions je suis pas sûr
que ça aiderait à vrai de majorité je
pense au contraire que le l'absence de
solidité
serait que le mythique le contour
parlementaire se déliterait encore plus
bon aujourd'hui la majorité elle-même à
savoir le groupe Renaissance le groupe
horizon le groupe moi-même on le sait
depuis le début ils n'ont pas la
majorité absolue nationale
on sait aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité alternative à l'assemblée
que toute la gauche
tout le rassemblement national plus
toutes les républicains ne peuvent ni ne
veulent oui se mettre d'accord j'entends
donc gouvernement de coalition
n'existe pas mais non la question c'est
ce que globalement une majorité relative
voilà il faut quand même une majorité
pour voter le texte mais
[Musique]
un texte peut passer si avec des
abstentions par exemple oui c'est pour
ça que je dis que ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas une majorité de voix
contre
la majorité alternative elle n'existe
pas il y a un doute sur sur les
républicains le parti en tant que tel a
accepté de soutenir la réforme à 64 ans
grosso modo
président de la
députée LR et Olivier Marleix président
du groupe alerte à l'Assemblée nationale
ce sont dit favorables en gros les
dirigeants du parti ont dit ok mais tous
les députés du groupe ne sont pas
forcément sur cette sur cette ligne il y
a 62 députés les républicains pour que
le texte passe et une majorité absolue à
assembler il faudrait qu'il y en ait au
moins une quarantaine alors j'ai fait
les comptes les donner il y aurait une
quinzaine de
réfractaires de frondeur au sein de la
majorité qui ne serait pas prêt à voter
pour cette réforme durée un tiers des LR
ce qui donnerait à peu près 20 personnes
ce qui fait sur la base de quoi c'est 15
c'est qui alors j'ai pris des chiffres
j'ai pas les noms précisément mais par
exemple barbara Pompili une voilà ça
fait une il y en a plusieurs il y en a
quelques-uns chez Horizon il y en a
quelques-uns au modem donc on additionne
il y en a qui sont incertain j'ai trouvé
ces chiffres d'ailleurs je vous les
conseille sur France Inter
c'est une incertitude il y aurait entre
285 et 295 voix c'est très incertain
sachant qu'il faut 289 voix pour le
texte pour que le texte passe non alors
précisément il ne faut pas 289 il faut
une majorité absolue des votants
oui mais sachant que les autres ne vont
pas s'abstenir si le RN pourrait dire on
y va pas on va pas voter
les filles pourraient dire on y va pas
on va pas voter
oui mais c'est ce que je vous dis tout à
l'heure la somme de la gauche plus du RN
oui ça ne fait pas une majorité vous
avez raison
la nuque je crois qu'on y sont en 150
députés plus
49 88 maintenant
député donc en gros on a 240
on a 240
députés au bois dans un nombre de
groupes fameux groupe liotte
mettons qu'on est aujourd'hui avec une
certitude 250 voix contre contre
il faudrait aujourd'hui
251 voix pour bien sûr on peut avoir
pour que le texte passe
et donc c'est là on voit comment en gros
combien de voix elle est il faudrait et
il en faut je pense environ une
quarantaine vous me dites que la
subtilité est dans ce qui ne sont pas
prêts à la voter est-ce qu'ils voteront
contre ou est-ce qu'ils savent voilà
ensuite les chiffres vous me citer des
chiffres de France Inter très bien
aujourd'hui personne n'est capable de
dire qui qui va s'abstenir
prospective on essaye de savoir
il y en a qui sont à certains il y en a
qui ne se prononcent pas pour l'instant
qui n'est pas encore déterminé
précisément est-ce que je mettrai ou non
et on le saura quand ça est-ce qu'ils
vont sortir du bois est-ce que le
gouvernement prendra le risque oui mais
enfin une fois qu'on fasse tout le monde
doit ce petit jeu je veux dire que un
député qui répond jaunis
à mon vote c'est pas forcément des
qui hésitent c'est pas forcément député
qui a sa tenir ça député qui qui choisit
de ne pas répondre à une question d'un
journaliste et c'est c'est son droit bon
donc mais il n'empêche qu'il y a une
bataille qui se joue à la semaine
nationale pour pouvoir faire aboutir ce
texte
sachant que de deux choses l'une où ce
texte réussi à trouver une majorité
ce qui est pas certain mais ce qui reste
aujourd'hui malgré tout le scénario le
plus probable à ce moment-là ça passe au
scénario il passera encore plus
facilement puisque pour le coup La
droite majoritaire et davantage sur une
ligne de soutien cette réforme par
contre si infinie on n'a pas cette
majorité
la question c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
tu fais le gouvernement il y a deux
solutions soit un retrait du texte on
n'a pas de majorité on retire le texte
peu probable très peu probable et
deuxième solution on n'a pas de majorité
on utilise le 49-3 alors actuelle est-ce
que le gouvernement est prêt à prendre
le risque est-ce qu'on ait une tendance
49-3 ou
tentative de faire passer le texte alors
sa préférence est bien sûr pour le faire
voter le texte
de notre discussion avec un risque
ensuite je pense que ce que ce dont
n'oubliera pas le gouvernement c'est de
retirer son texte vous restez sur un
échec puisque une fois que il a les
moyens
constitutionnels de faire voter ce texte
et que
Emmanuel Macron a compris que s'il
devait renoncer à ce texte c'est pas
uniquement à un texte parmi d'autres qui
renoncerait c'est carrément à l'ensemble
de son action c'est des rats à la suite
de son quinquennat qu'il renoncerait
parce que il y a du renoncer à la
réforme pour l'instant la plus difficile
et la plus problématique et comme on dit
souvent ça veut dire que sur aucun autre
texte il n'aura ni légitimité ni
autorité ni peut-être même envie
d'avancer donc ce serait la fin du
scannera moins d'un an après l'avoir
commencé donc à partir du moment où de
toute façon l'accusation de passer en
force l'accusation de rester sourd à la
rue etc elle est déjà formulée donc oui
mais Guillaume un gouvernement qui
ferait passer un texte via le 43 qui est
constitutionnel
ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'il y a un
million un million et demi de personnes
dans la rue est-ce que ça ne paraît pas
un peu anti-démocratique je sais
Emmanuel Macron a été élu et il a
légitimité de l'élection vous répondez
vous-même mais ce reproche là
il est fait et il se fait à Emmanuel
Macron même si il a une majorité pour
rétention de texte on vient de voir
l'instant enfin je sais pas si on l'a vu
sur nos écrans mais Marine Le Pen était
interrogée en direct de l'Assemblée où
elle disait non il est faux de dire que
Macron a un mandat pour pour faire cette
réforme puisqu'il n'est pas majoritaire
à l'assemblée donc elle conteste pour
lui la légitimité à faire cette loi et
la gauche tient ce discours donc dire
Macron vous passez en force et vous
n'avez pas le droit il le lui dise déjà
et il lui le diront il le lui diront
même s'il avait une majorité j'ai une
dernière question Guillaume tabard on
parle d'un référendum est-ce que c'est
possible ça c'est ce que propose le
rassemblement national c'est ça alors
pas que là
il y a eu un petit épisode de en gros
toute la gauche toute la gauche et l'URN
proposait un référendum et donc vous
savez pour ça il faut que
un groupe dépose une motion référendaire
soit ensuite débattue ce qui sera le cas
lundi bon mais donc il y a une sorte de
course de vitesse entre tous ces groupes
entre le groupe LFI entre le groupe
socialiste le groupe communiste et le
groupe RN bon et grosso modo comme tout
le monde est arrivé un peu en même temps
la solution retenue par la présentation
on va tirer au sort d'accord et le
tirage au sort a fait que c'est la
motion du rassemblement national qui
était choisi c'est donc la motion du RN
qui sera débattu
en séance lundi et alors qu'est-ce que
ça change que ce ne soit pas celle des
autres groupes alors c'est que la gauche
refuse de voter le texte du RN alors que
l'URN a déjà montré alors le révolté
mais en tout hypothèse on en rejoint on
revient au calcul du début on n'aura pas
compliqué vous avez raison de majorité
absolue pour voter la motion
référendaire donc de toute façon ça
c'est un effet de
d'ailleurs pourquoi le gouvernement est
opposé n'a jamais ouvert la voie à cette
question
les manifestants quand on va les
sondages qui disent que les gens sont
aux deux tiers hostiles à la réforme des
retraites il serait au minimum imprudent
et pour te dire assez suicidaire de
tenter de faire passer ce Dex par
référendum merci beaucoup Guillaume Tana
merci à vous parce que je veux qu'on
éclaircisse cette question des votes à
l'Assemblée nationale le vote ça va ça
se fait le dire la discussion assemblée
va se situer le 17 février voilà donc
jusqu'au 17 on va compter et reconter
j'ai l'impression tu le Parlement n'a
jamais été aussi puissant d'une certaine
manière on revient à une forme de régime
parlementaire là parce qu'on va aller
chercher j'imagine du côté du
gouvernement voit par voie on va appeler
les députés c'est comme ça que ça se
passe alors que depuis des années enfin
Emmanuel Macron pendant 5 ans n'avait
pas faire ça hein il demandait à ses
députés de voter c'est là où le la
l'absence de majorité absolue change RA
le fonctionnement pas forcément la
logique parce que infidèle on l'a vu il
y a accent d'outils qui permettent au
gouvernement d'aboutir mais en tout cas
dans le fonctionnement c'est sûr que ça
ça change beaucoup de choses 16h52 merci
Guillaume tabac rédacteur en chef
éditorialiste politique au Figaro on
retourne sur le terrain Timothée Delem
on vous a quitté il y a une dizaine de
minutes il y a un petit quart d'heure
dans une certaine tension autour de vous
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas parce
que l'atmosphère est aussi chaude ou ça
descend un peu
alors en fait Thibault ce qui se passe
c'est que c'est un petit peu une
manifestation d'aujourd'hui on s'est en
réalité il y a le cortège des syndicats
qui se trouve derrière nous à une
centaine de mètres où là l'ambiance est
à la manifestation des slogans rien de
plus de plus classique pour une
manifestation en revanche dès que l'on
s'approche de du cortège et vous le
voyez à quelques mètres devant nous à
des dizaines de mètres et bien là des
moments de tension ce qui est assez
frappant c'est que ce sont très souvent
des moments de tension localisés
c'est-à-dire que les forces de l'ordre
parviennent à m'en tenir l'ordre
précisément nous avons aperçu une
interpellation et si ou là nous avons
également aperçu une charge de CRS à une
vingtaine de mètres devant nous ça
c'était il y a peut-être deux minutes à
peu près pour le moment nous nous
trouvons à du rock donc au niveau de
l'hôpital Necker en format malade voilà
et donc des moments en fait de tension
toujours localisée avec qui est bien
dégaze lacrymogène avec des bombes va
surdissantes avec parfois également en
tout cas nous l'avons vu je le disais
une charge des CRS et dès que l'on
laisse le cortège avancé filet et que
l'on se retrouve au niveau du cortège
des syndicats et bien là l'ambiance qui
est redescend petit à petit voilà donc
c'est vraiment une manifestation de
l'ambiance cet après-midi pour le moment
merci beaucoup Timothée delhem toujours
dans le cortège vous faites attention on
ira voir Vincent roserand dans un
instant William Ploemeur bonjour bonjour
journaliste au service économie du
Figaro on a parlé un peu de politique
tactique politicienne c'est pas simple
vous avez compris que on va compter
recompter re-conté la moindre voie à
l'Assemblée nationale en attendant le
gouvernement doit faire face à l'épreuve
de la de la rue
acte 2 c'est un moment décisif là les
syndicats doivent prouver aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont crédibles et que ils peuvent
faire descendre du monde dans la rue
alors ils sont là vraiment pour pour
montrer
leur état de force c'est une vraie c'est
un vrai challenge pour eux parce que ils
sont déjà dans une forme
victoire vis-à-vis du premier around qui
a eu lieu le 10 janvier le 19 et le 19
pardon et ils veulent faire aussi bien
si ce n'est mieux que que la dernière
fois pour l'instant on a l'impression
que c'est plutôt bien parti du moins
dans la rue on voit dans pas mal de
villes que que la bombe les nations a
bien pris les chiffres sont en
augmentation on a vu le chiffre de la
CGT vous l'avez dit plus tôt
un chiffre intéressant celui de
Marseille 25000 personnes le 19 janvier
exactement
même la CGT voyez un peu plus de monde
elle a à Paris 400 000 enfin 500 000
contre 400 000 il y a 10 jours donc oui
le le ça c'est au niveau de la rue c'est
c'est une réussite enfin c'est une
réussite on attendra quand même les
chiffres nationaux en fin de journée
mais on voit que ça ça prend de
l'ampleur là où en revanche on peut
peut-être un peu nuancer c'est sur la
mobilisation prenons la rue elle prend
un peu moins dans les entreprises ça il
y a moyen de grève on a essayé vous avez
dans ma révision tout à l'heure la
rédaction chef du service économique est
venu nous parler de ça Guillaume Tabar
aussi nous en a parlé comment on
explique ça pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent parce que il y a plus de
monde dans les rues mais moins de
grévistes dans les entreprises paradoxal
on aurait dû s'attendre à ce que le
mouvement prenne de l'ampleur partout
que ce soit dans la rue ou dans les
entreprises sauf qu'en fait il y a une
contrainte qui s'appelle l'inflation le
pouvoir le pouvoir d'achat la
conjoncture
on sent que que faire une grève et c'est
bien le nerf de la guerre au sein de
l'Inter syndical on sent que on peut pas
demander à à
plein de personnes de faire des grèves
recondictibles parce que effectivement
la fin de mois
ça compte c'est à dire que c'est facile
d'appeler à la grève après il faut la
faire exactement
de
calmer les ardeurs de la CGT et des
syndicats et des bases les plus les plus
radicales parce que
ces bases là veulent veulent forcer
veulent y beaucoup plus fort Val de la
paralysie veulent du blocage dans le
pays mais effectivement la CFDT est en
train de calmer leurs ardeurs dans le
sens où on voit que que ce sera pas
possible sur sur du long cours parce que
effectivement ça compte sur le niveau de
vie des Français et et effectivement ça
c'est un frein aujourd'hui on va
retrouver Vincent roseron qui est dans
le cortège parisien près des drapeaux de
la CGT alors qu'est-ce que je lis Vitry
vous allez nous dire tout ça Vincent
tiens
qu'est-ce qu'ils disent les manifestants
qui vous accompagnent au sujet de la
suite de la grève parce qu'on imagine
que pour eux s'ils sont là aujourd'hui
ça veut dire qu'il perde de l'argent
c'est forcément difficile
et oui forcément Thibault c'est
difficile pour eux forcément c'est aussi
des sacrifices qu'ils font l'un d'entre
eux me le disait tout d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure il me disait quand même hors
micro il disait voilà moi je viens ici
ça va être un sacrifice mais je le fais
pour pour les faire reculer pour faire
recul gouvernement l'idée c'est c'est
d'arriver à faire ça à faire recul
gouvernement c'est c'est leur avis et
c'est ce qui ils attendent aussi de voir
les prochaines mobilisation c'est qu'il
vient de l'interseyndicale plus tard
dans la journée et à ce moment là on
aura de la suite de ce qui se passera
pour s'il y a un prochain jour et quand
est-ce qu'il se sera parce que là pour
le coup on a entendu 12 jours entre les
deux manifestations
essayer de essayer de trouver si vous le
pouvez un manifestant pour qu'il puisse
nous dire ce qu'il aimerait faire lui
pour poursuivre le mouvement si c'est
difficile pour lui c'est la poser des
RTT par exemple c'est ça William on
trouve des solutions pour pouvoir venir
sans perdre de la base effectivement ça
permet de pour les manifestants et les
personnes qui veulent se mobiliser ça
permet de maintenir le coup si je puis
si je puis dire de de la mobilisation
mais effectivement ça va être un enjeu
très important et je pense que ce soir
durant l'Inter syndicale les syndicats
vont vraiment se poser la question de
l'après parce que c'est c'est une
question quand même qui est qui est
majeure parce que là ça prend un peu
d'ampleur mais on est encore loin des
mobilisations qu'on a connu par le passé
que ce soit en 1995 ou en 2010 et on
puisse en 2010 on avait vu que la
mobilisation de la rune n'avait même pas
pesé puisque le gouvernement avait
maintenu sa réforme
là effectivement il va falloir se poser
c'est une vraie question parce que
d'accord il y a du monde dans la rue
c'est vrai ça actuellement il y a du
monde dans la rue les chiffres le
montrent les chiffres de la CGT qui
peuvent paraître parfois un peu sur
gonflés mais en tout cas ceux des
ministère de l'Intérieur montre qu'il a
du monde est-ce que le gouvernement
pardonne-moi de parler comme ça on n'a
rien à faire de ça est-ce que c'est
vraiment impactant est-ce qu'il ne faut
pas pour ces travailleurs faire grève
plus longuement sur leur lieu de travail
bloquer le pays est-ce que ça serait pas
plus d'impactant du côté du gouvernement
on a été
au début dans une logique de
d'explication de la réforme d'un petit
peu de SAV d'essayer de convaincre les
Français et on a vu que ça a pas marché
effectivement l'opinion de se retourne
pas on sait que d'opinion de français
sur sur trois et opposé à la réforme
donc là ils ont abandonné abandonné
l'idée de convaincre maintenant on l'a
vu ce week-end Elizabeth borne qui a dit
on ne reculera pas sur l'âge em Macron
l'a dit hier soir il y aura pas de
marche arrière ils vont vouloir faire
passer leur réforme après effectivement
est-ce que les syndicats s'en rendent
compte ou pas à la CFDT on prend le
parti de dire que si la mobilisation
monte crescendo qu'il y a qu'il y a eu
du monde le 19 qu'il y a du monde
aujourd'hui et il y en a éventuellement
encore plus
lors de la prochaine date qui sera là
qui sera fixée plus tard si
effectivement ça monte crescendo on
estime que le gouverneur le gouvernement
ne pourra pas on ne pourra pas faire la
sourde oreille justement à
la troisième
mais si effectivement le mouvement prend
encore plus d'ampleur ce sera aux yeux
de la CFDT un argument pour faire
reculer je vous coupe William Ploemeur
parce que Vincent roseron est avec
personnalité importante de la politique
et de la Vie Française matin
la patronne des députés LFI à
l'Assemblée nationale
oui effectivement je suis avec Mathilde
panneau bonjour merci d'être avec nous
est-ce que aujourd'hui c'est déjà une
réussite de voir autant de gens dans la
rue pour vous je pense parce que quand
on regarde rien qu'à Paris le syndicat
c'est gêné CGT annonce 100000 personnes
de plus que ce qu'il y avait le 19
janvier et un peu partout on voit 10000
personnes en plus à Brest et dans
beaucoup de villes on voit que la
mobilisation a à grimper alors c'est
simple le gouvernement fait de la
pédagogie sur sa réforme il fait la
pédagogie ça fait plus 100000 personnes
à Paris et plus beaucoup un peu partout
on va avoir les chiffres pour l'ensemble
du pays donc je crois que c'est Madame
borne qui parlait pour l'opposition de
déni et de refus de construire des
choses et bien le gouvernement devrait
sortir du déni voir l'opposition massive
à sa réforme et surtout comprendre que
personne ne s'arrêtera tant qu'il
n'auront pas retiré ce projet de
retraite donc on l'invite à regarder
avec lucidité le fait que lui Français
sur 10 ils seront opposés meuf actif sur
10 ans opposées que l'Inter syndicale
est uni première fois depuis 12 ans
contre ce projet de réforme des
retraites et la mipesse aussi et que
nous allons tenir fermement notre rôle à
l'Assemblée tant qu'ils n'auront pas
retiré ce texte pourtant
ce week-end ils avaient deborn disait
sous 24 ans c'est pas négociable
elle a voulu montrer sa détermination
aussi là-dessus je pense que là on a une
belle réponse aujourd'hui le 31 janvier
le
peuple des choses qui ne sont pas
négociables et le retrait du texte n'est
pas négociable je crois que c'est ce que
sont en train de dire tous ces gens qui
défilent parce que travailler deux ans
supplémentaires les gens ont très bien
compris ce que ça voulait dire avec les
facteurs de pénibilité avec ce que ça
veut dire pour notamment des femmes qui
vont elles devoir partir plus tard parce
qu'elles vont être pénalisées avec des
pensions qui vont être plus faibles bref
tout le monde a compris que personne
n'avait intérêt à cette réforme et
regardez le nombre de gens qu'il y a
dans la rue personne n'en veut
il y a moins de grévis est-ce que ça
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait vous
inquiéter
non parce que je crois que il faut
comprendre que pour beaucoup de gens
c'est très très dur de faire grève
aujourd'hui vous avez cette réforme des
retraites elle n'arrive pas à n'importe
quel moment dans notre pays elle arrive
dans un moment où vous avez 10 millions
de personnes sous le soleil de pauvreté
la moitié des pauvres qui ont moins de
30 ans 42000 enfants qui sont soit à la
rue soit en hébergement précaire mais à
un moment où le prix de l'alimentation
de l'énergie en train d'exploser et
d'étrangler l'ensemble des familles donc
on peut comprendre que ça soit très dur
de faire grève aujourd'hui et je pense
que le niveau de mobilisation qui est
bien plus élevé que ce qu'il y avait le
19 janvier augure en tout cas d'une
détermination sans faille des gens qui
ne laisseront pas faire le fait que
chacun et chacune soit obligé de
travailler deux ans supplémentaires la
retraite à 64 ans se sont en train de
dire les gens dans la rue c'est non et
ça sera toujours non après le premier
février le 2 février ou même le 17
février voilà j'ai une dernière question
ce sera quoi la suite qu'est-ce que vous
attendez pour la suite de ce mouvement
alors la suite c'est l'Inter syndicale
évidemment qui va la décider ce sont les
âgés des travailleurs et des
travailleurs un peu partout qui vont la
décider quant à nous nous allons jouer
la nuit Pesse notre rôle d'opposition
résolu à cette réforme on est en train
de le faire en ce moment en commission
des affaires sociales et on continuera à
le faire dans l'hémicycle à partir du 6
février suivez les débats parce que déjà
en un jour de commission des finances
ils ont réussi à nous expliquer que les
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap le faisait par choix pour avoir
leur mercredi et leurs vacances
scolaires pour 760 euros par mois en
moyenne vous comprenez et bien la vie
est faite de choix comme disait cette
députée macroniste je pense qu'on va
entendre beaucoup d'autres choses de
déconnexion comme cela et que plus ils
expliquent leurs réforme et plus ils
parlent et plus il y a de monde dans la
rue donc qu'il continue à parler
continuer à écouter et en tout cas nous
on va mener la bataille très bien merci
beaucoup
voilà vous venez d'entendre la
présidente du groupe la France insoumise
à l'Assemblée nationale vous avez vu
aussi quelques images vous voyez ici on
s'approche de la place Vauban les
Invalides au fond le gaz de lacrymogène
une foule dispersée des
manifestants mais tu donnes noires avec
des capuches des drapeaux
noirs également
on va essayer de retrouver Timothée dans
un instant pour qu'ils nous explique ce
qui se passe lorsqu'on s'approche de la
fin de ce cortège visiblement il y a une
petite tension
de la suite du mouvement est-ce que
certains envisagent chez les syndicats
d'arrêter ses journées de mobilisation
comme ça très impressionnante c'est vrai
du monde dans la rue des images en
hauteur avec des rues grondées et au
contraire entrer dans une grève plus
dure plus longue avec les gens qui
bloquent le pays je pense le cheminots
font les possibilités de le faire aux
enseignants au raffineries etc etc
commencer dans la c'est la logique de la
CGT qui qui veut qui veut durcir le
mouvement qui va aller sur quelque chose
qui est effectivement à l'inverse de la
CFDT qui pense que que la rue permettra
de de faire de le faire tourner le
gouvernement enfin reculer du moins le
gouvernement ce sera pas possible pour
pour la CGT qui pensent qu'ils se font
faut aller plus fort alors effectivement
il y a des il y a des velléités rien
notamment de la base on voit que sur sur
certains sur certains dans certaines
fédérations à savoir les cheminots les
les au niveau de l'énergie le pétrole
c'est des fédérations qui sont réputés
pour être assez radicales on a déjà eu
des vérités ces dernières semaines
d'aller plus loin au niveau de dans
l'énergie et et pétrole il y a déjà eu
des menaces de fermer le le robinet de
gaz et d'électricité de certains élus
qui portaient
des actions ciblées exactement
mais mais ça dénote tout de même une
certaine volonté de radicalisation on
peut dire dans le mouvement
donc oui il y a une volonté d'aller plus
loin
donc au sein de la CGT chemineau on est
assez clair et aider le 19 janvier on a
vu déjà des décisions au sein des
syndicats dans le sens où alors ils
avaient fait grève certains
cheminots notamment les contrôleurs sont
Laval des syndicats exactement donc
c'est la base on pourrait avoir envie
d'y aller tout seul exactement c'est la
base qui dépasse la maison mère si on
peut dire ça comme ça on l'avait déjà vu
ça d'ailleurs en octobre
octobre-novembre avec les raffineries on
se souvient en fait de la CGT avait pas
mal bloqué les les raffineries et et
tout à l'énergie à dessiner un accord de
sur les salaires des petits frères alors
la CFDT là CGT Philippe Martinez même
les têtes pensantes les têtes dirigeants
disent non non il faut pas rentrer là
pour l'instant il y a une volonté
d'union au coussin des syndicats pour
justement peser le plus possible mais on
voit bien que ce soir ça va être un
moment charnière dans le sens où on
verra certainement des des stratégies
différées williamer vous restez encore
un instant avec moi on retourne sur le
terrain Timothée Delem
qu'en est-il vous approchez de la fin de
la manifestation place Vauban tout
proche des Invalides on a vu des images
avec des gaz lacrymogènes des
gens qui couraient un peu partout qu'en
est-il
bah c'est c'est ça Thibault on est en
train de s'approcher de cette de ce lieu
d'arrivée de la manifestation vous le
voyez peut-être le dôme et bien des
Invalides qui se trouvent à quelques
dizaines de mètres de là ça veut dire
que la le point d'arriver la place
Vauban de la manifestation mais plus
très loin et cette manifestation qui a
été marquée en tous les cas ce
pré-corpège comme je vous l'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure une deux ambiances très
différentes entre le précurtège et le
cortège des syndicats se précortège qui
a été marqué depuis maintenant de
longues minutes par et bien de
nombreuses échauffourés entre et bien
des dizaines de groupes d'ultra vêtus de
noir qui ont te lancer des projectiles
en direction et bien des forces de
l'ordre lesquelles ont répondu par des
tirs de gaz lacrymogène c'est donc dans
cette ambiance que le cortège est en
train d'arriver place Vauban dans cette
ambiance en fumée cette ambiance où l'on
sent vraiment cette odeur de gaz
lacrymogène avec des points de tension
localisés je vous le disais ici de des
lancer de projectiles contre les forces
de l'ordre là des poubelles incendiées
on entend des bruits de verre également
par terre voilà cette ambiance vraiment
vraiment tendue avec un certain nombre
de tension également lorsque nous sommes
passés au niveau du ministère des
Outre-mer dans le quartier Montparnasse
sur ce boulevard Montparnasse avec un
cordon de CRS qui ont et bien coupé la
manifestation en deux ce qui n'a pas plu
aux manifestants lesquels ils ont
invectivé à de nombreuses reprises les
policiers avec des slogans du type tout
le monde déteste la police policier
assassin voilà ce genre de slogan qui
ont donc émergé et bien de la foule qui
est en train maintenant de se diriger
vers le point d'arrivée de cette
manifestation
on a bien compris dans cette
manifestation de l'attention quelques
échauffourés pour l'instant pas de
violence très importante même si on a vu
quand même tout à l'heure le Timothée ne
l'a montré une banque qui a été qui a
été vandalisé est-ce qu'on a continué à
négocier ces derniers jours entre
syndicats et politique alors du côté
qui me disait que ils étaient toujours
ouvert aux discussions avec le
gouvernement mais que eux leur stratégie
désormais c'était d'aller voir les
députés
on sait que la réforme est en train de
passer en commission des affaires
sociales à l'Assemblée et il y a
effectivement ils sont depuis deux
semaines allez voir tous les députés de
de tous les morts alors surtout de la
majorité d'accord pour essayer de les
convaincre et leur dire bon le jouet sur
la FC pas possible on a d'autres leviers
pour pour revenir à cette réforme que la
CFDT soutenait à l'époque exactement
cette cette cette notion d'âge c'est une
ligne rouge pour eux donc ils essayent
de convaincre est-ce que ça va prendre
ou pas c'est compliqué mais à dire du
moins mais mais on sait que il va y
avoir aussi une vraie bataille à
l'Assemblée et les syndicats veulent
veulent influer sur ça alors c'est
étonnant parce que pour l'instant tous
les syndicats
demandent le retrait de la réforme mais
ils vont quand même essayer de faire
amender la réforme au cas où elle passe
il cherche tous les moyens justement
pour pour parvenir à leur fin il y a la
rue il y a le débat démocratique même si
on sait que le gouvernement va très
certainement faire passer ça sa réforme
notre dispositif mais effectivement les
les syndicats veulent peser tous leurs
poids la place Vauban vous voyez l'Hôtel
des Invalides et lieu d'arriver de cette
manifestation ça a mis du temps parce
que il y a quelques minutes William je
passe vous étiez en train de parler la
place d'Italie se vider seulement donc
sont partis de manière très disséminée
on va retrouver Vincent roseron merci de
nous avoir accompagné William merci
d'être venu sur le plateau de nous avoir
donné ces explications sur la suite du
mouvement j'imagine qu'on me retrouvera
dans les joueurs qui viennent parce que
ça va continuer à pas douter en son
roseron vous en êtes où vous êtes
manifestation
vous regardez passer les gens vous les
suivez expliquez-moi
alors je les suis je suis parti de Place
d'Italie qui commençait à se vider petit
à petit cette place a commencé à se
vider et donc du coup j'ai suivi le
cortège qui avance en tout cas beaucoup
beaucoup plus vite qu'au début de cette
manifestation là vous pouvez le voir
voilà alors c'est le cortège de la CGT
qui maintenant avis avance à très bonne
vitesse en gros en deux heures on avait
fait 50 mètres et depuis ça avance
vraiment je pense que devant ça a dû se
décanter un petit peu et du coup le
cortège est en route
je sais que c'est pas simple et si vous
nous rejoignez accrochez-vous bien
je vais essayer en fait
les ce que pose l'étude d'impact c'est
que les femmes sur l'âge effectivement
de départ elles partiront plus tard que
les hommes sous l'effet de la réforme on
parle pour la génération 1980 les femmes
qui sont 980 partiront de dans une
partie en deux fois plus tard que les
hommes ça reste relativement relatif
parce que relativement parce que on
parle de quatre mois pour les hommes et
moi et huit mois pour les femmes
pourquoi c'est parce que avec la réforme
les hommes nés en 1980 partiront 4 mois
plus tard tout ce qui est prévu pour
l'instant
dans les faits des questions que je ne
parle pas de l'âge légal je parle de
l'âge effectif de départ très bien
il y a une marge tout le monde l'a bien
compris les oppositions en particulier
donc il cible le gouvernement et la
réforme sur ce sur ce point-là il y a de
fait quelque chose qui peut relever
d'une injustice et donc il y a des
marges de négociations assez fortes le
gouvernement prévoit éventuellement
d'octroyer ce qu'on peut appeler
peut-être pas rentrer dans le détail
très technique mais ce qu'on peut
appeler je vous arrête de toute façon si
c'est trop technique vous allez voir mon
visage je comprends rien et j'essaye de
mettre avec les interventions pour qu'on
comprenne je vais en fait pourquoi les
femmes vont travailler plus longtemps
c'est parce que c'est à cause au fond de
l'âge légal c'est parce que les femmes
les perdre des maires de famille en
particulier on leur octroie des
trimestres de cotisations
supplémentaires du fait de leur
maternité 8 trimestres exactement ok
chaque femme lorsqu'elle a un enfant
récupère 8 trimestres parce qu'on
considère que la maternité fait elle
doit s'occuper de ses enfants etc
ce qui fait que elle cotise beaucoup
et qu'elle parte en général à 62 ans
pile parce qu'elles ont cotisé tous les
trimestres qu'il leur fallait d'accord
parce que ces trimestres qu'on le rock 3
lorsqu'elles ont un enfant leur
permettent d'avoir
la durée de cotisation rempli à 62 ans
c'est pas le cas beaucoup de Français
elle se retrouve donc dans une situation
qu'on appelle sur cotisation lorsqu'on
repousse l'âge légal à 64 ans cotiser
pendant deux ans donc supplémentaire
pour le plaisir exactement pour le
plaisir ou pas d'ailleurs mais parce
qu'ils sont obligés voilà je rappelle
quand même que l'âge légal de départ
continue de travailler mais elle cotise
encore voilà ça qu'on dit qu'elle
surcotise pour elle-même exactement
parce que je rappelle que l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans ça veut dire que sauf
qu'a exceptionnel que les Français ne
pourront pas partir en deçà de cet âge
légal bref tout ça pour dire que pour
rétablir cette situation le gouvernement
l'hypothèse qui tient la corde dans les
négociations à l'Assemblée nationale
parce que le gouvernement est prêt un
peu à lâcher en tout cas ce qui
semblerait c'est d'octroyer un bonus aux
femmes donc davantage une augmentation
de leur pension du fait cette
surpatisation d'accord premier point
donc on ne touche pas 64 ans ça aurait
compris non une association ouverte sur
les femmes de toute façon le
gouvernement était bien obligé de le
faire Franck Riester le ministre des
Relations avec le Parlement un peu venu
un couteau dans le dos du gouvernement
en pointant du doigt de sujet et donc il
aura sans doute discussion sur cette
question enfin c'est écrit on a fait
beaucoup rire à Franck Riester mais
c'était écrit dans l'étude d'impact bon
le problème c'est que lorsqu'on se parle
ça évidemment plus de porter qu'une
étude d'impact deuxième point sur lequel
il pourrait y avoir des négociations
cette clause de revoyure là c'est dans
les tuyaux ça expliquez-moi en gros on
signe pour 64 ans mais si dans quelques
années on se rend compte que 63 ça
suffit on s'arrête là c'est ça l'idée
ouais alors je suis pas je suis pas très
très au fait de cette question de clause
de revoyure mais ce que je peux dire
c'est que en effet c'est bien une
hypothèse qui qui tient la corde et le
gouvernement le gouvernement est prêt là
aussi comme pour les femmes à
éventuellement à lâcher du Lestre on va
aller sur le terrain magnifique
parce qu'il est avec un élu un député
Vincent vous êtes avec Julien Bayou
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
oui
oui exactement alors il y a beaucoup de
musique au moment où vous me parlez
beaucoup de gens qui passent je suis
avec Julien Bayou effectivement dans
l'écologie et vert bonjour j'ai un voyou
merci d'être avec nous est-ce que pour
vous cette mobilisation qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est une réussite déjà oui
oui c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
enthousiasmant moi je suis député on va
démarrer l'examen à l'Assemblée on
repart avec une force incroyable
beaucoup de sourires des gens qui sont
heureux d'être dans la rue d'être
engagé en fait et aussi beaucoup de
personnes qui viennent un peu pour la
première fois ou en tout cas qui était
pas venu depuis très longtemps des gens
qui disent j'ai jamais fait grève alors
là j'ai fait plutôt une RTT mais voilà
qui veulent s'engager et qui cherchent
le moyen et la leçon vraiment de tous
les échanges c'est on a compris que
cette réforme est injuste et injustifiée
il y a pas il y a pas de de raison
financière il y a c'est purement
idéologique et même pire c'est
uniquement pour que Macron ne perd pas
la face et tout le monde convient que ça
n'est pas une raison suffisante pour
imposer deux ans de travail à toutes les
Français et les Français voilà donc je
crois vraiment le gouvernement a perdu
la partie dans l'opinion publique et
demain à l'Assemblée mais est-ce que ce
sera suffisant justement parce que
l'opinion publique c'est c'est bien mais
en 2010 aussi il y avait il y a eu des
grosses grèves enfin voilà est-ce que ce
sera suffisant je crois vraiment qu'il
faut qu'on mesure que cette idée de
travailler toujours plus longtemps au
mépris des corps abimés le fait que il y
a des personnes quand elles arrivent à
la retraite elles ont pas des dizaines
et des dizaines d'années de d'espérance
de vie en bonne santé des fois
malheureusement c'est 4 5 6 ans
d'espérance de vie en bonne santé les
faire travailler deux ans de plus c'est
pas un petit effort c'est leur voler les
les années les plus précieuses celles ou
il pourrait apprendre une langue enfin
voyager s'occuper leurs petits-enfants
s'engager dans la vie associative vous
voyez c'est un immense effort pendant ce
temps-là on demande rien au plus riche
je crois vraiment que ça ça infusé très
profondément et que
Emmanuel Macron ne veut pas perdre la
face et alors on pourrait travailler
beaucoup mieux avec un projet qui répare
les inégalités il a choisi la voie
contraire il va perdre voilà c'est quoi
la suite pour vous enfin en tout cas
pour vous pour cette manifestations
qu'est-ce que vous voyez pour la pour la
suite du mouvement ça arrive à
l'Assemblée moi j'ai organise par
exemple un meeting dans le 10e
arrondissement jeudi à 19h30 à la mairie
du 10e j'étais surpris parce que les
différents collègues parlementaires ont
répondu tout de suite pas de problème on
vient et on s'organise ensuite il y a
une vraie envie de dans des coudre
sur le fond parce qu'on voit bien qu'en
face lrem à l'Assemblée n'a pas
d'arguments ni financier ni social ni
économique il y a pas d'argument et plus
il parle plus ils perdent et donc on va
les faire parler très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur voilà Thibault pour ce
Julien Bayou qui était avec nous et qui
est sur lui que Emmanuel Macron va
reculer
bonne ambiance en tout cas Vincent rose
ici visiblement on est place Vauban à
l'arrivée du cortège des hommes en noir
bon visiblement ça a l'air d'aller se
faire que cela ne va pas dégénérer il va
être Richard Florin ces Figaro.fr
service économie bon
l'équilibre financier de cette réforme
ça c'est une grande question parce que
on en entend de tous les côtés moi je
suis pas un expert du madame repérer
dans tout ça est-ce que c'est très fort
et obligatoire ce qu'il faut la faire à
tout prix parce que sinon ça explose ce
qui est certain c'est que en effet le
système des retraites et en déséquilibre
dans les 10 15 prochaines années c'est
pas Richard Florin qui vous le dit c'est
le corps le conseil d'orientation pour
les retraites un organisme qui fait
autorité et qui teste différentes
hypothèses économiques je vous passe le
détail parce que de toute façon quel que
soit l'hypothèse économique précisément
il y en a quatre le système
universitaire jusqu'en 2035 après il
serait équilibre on pourra peut-être
revenir mais pour des raisons de leur
démographique donc si on veut si on veut
rééquilibrer le système oui une réforme
est indispensable pour se faire on joue
sur les paramètres
il y a trois paramètres exactement
rappeler les mois donc il y a là de
départ il y a la durée de cotisation
waouh c'est un peu en gros c'est le
paramètre de l'âge
il y a joué sur le le montant des
cotisations c'est ça au cotise tous sur
notre salaire pour pour les retraites on
pourrait augmenter le le montant des
cotisations ou la proportion des
cotisations et puis enfin il y a le
montant des retraites évidemment et on
pourrait baisser les pensions le choix
du gouvernement on y touche pas de toute
façon c'est difficile aujourd'hui même
si les retraités semblent être on les
augmente
sans de pas y toucher d'autant que c'est
une question également politique
Emmanuel Macron armée décoratrice c'est
les retraités on ne touche pas à
depuis 2017 très largement Emmanuel
Macron veut alléger les charges pour les
patrons donc on touche à l'âge
exactement de départ là je légale de
départ et à la durée de cotisation qui
augmente aussi un qui passe de 40 à qui
c'est l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine qu'on arrive plus vite à une
durée de communication 43 ans combien on
gagne avec cette réforme là
dans tous les sens essayer de ne pas
nous perdre là aussi Richard c'est c'est
assez simple d'abord il y a consensus on
gagne on gagne 17,7 milliards on dit 18
milliards enfin voilà dans ces eaux là
ça c'est ce qu'on gagne grâce aux
mesures qu'on appelle salé de la réforme
donc tu es précisément précisément le
report de l'âge légal et l'accélération
des milliards sur un an sur cinq ans sur
10 ans combien 17 milliards tous les ans
17 milliards tous les ans ce sont des
chiffres tellement énormes on a du mal à
se rendre compte de ce que c'est
exactement sauf que on gagne 17
milliards 17,7 milliards grâce au report
de l'âge légal et grâce à la longement
de la durée de cotisation mais
il nous aura pas échappé que ce projet
de loi il compte aussi des mesures qu'on
dit sucrées par humour mais en gros
c'est les mesures d'accompagnement c'est
les mesures pas en retraitante 1200
euros par mois notamment voilà ça c'est
mais il y a aussi la retraite La
retraite progressive enfin il y a tout
un tas de dispositifs ça c'est ces
grosso modo un tiers de ces 18 milliards
donc 6 milliards d'euros un tiers des 18
milliards d'économies iront directement
pour financer les mesures
d'accompagnement voilà et j'ajoute ça
c'est à peu près exactement
en tout cas chez le au sein du
gouvernement mais que les économistes
n'oublient pas c'est que repousser l'âge
légal ça coûte plus cher pour le système
de chômage voilà il y a tout un tas de
conséquences indirectes et espèce de
consensus chez l’économiste qui disent
que en gros il y a aussi là aussi un
tiers 33% des écon qui doivent être qui
seront indirectement réimputés dans
d'autres systèmes de d'accompagnement si
je puis dire on rejoint Timothée delhem
Timothée est-ce qu'il m'entend il est
sur place
Vauban justement dans la manifestation
Timothée vous êtes arrivé cette place
remplie progressivement et surtout ce
qu'elles se remplit dans le cadre
[Musique]
oui cette place qui se qui se remplit
avec un flux continu de manifestants qui
arrivent depuis le boulevard juste
derrière moi et qui arrive donc sur
cette place Vauban au niveau des
Invalides vous l'entendez ici il y a une
ambiance assez calme une ambiance en
tous les cas assez soutenu avec ici et
bien des tambours des sifflets et ceux
et ce slogan on est là on est là même si
Macron ne le veut pas on est là chante
les manifestants avec et bien derrière
moi le cortège de la CFTC du syndicat de
la CFTC qui est en train d'arriver il
est à une à 100 mètres environ on va
dire d'ici voilà et ici l'ambiance est
assez calme avec une présence massive
mais assez discrète de policiers je
m'explique ils sont en fait toutes aux
alentours de la place pour et bien
contenir les éventuelles attroupements
mais voilà pour l'instant au milieu de
la place les forces de l'ordre se font
assez discrètes parce que l'ambiance
pour le moment est assez calme
[Musique]
merci
en tout cas pas de violence ça c'est
plus important c'est ce que vous voulez
dire évidemment Timothée
[Musique]
économie j'ai une question est-ce que
dans cinq ans que cette réforme passe on
n'est pas obligé de remettre le métier
sur l'ouvrage et de refaire une nouvelle
réforme celle de 2019
avait pour objectif de ne pas retoucher
tous les deux ans tous les trois ans
tous les 5 ans quand je rentre tout à
fait c'est une question centrale
pour vous répondre directement la
réforme de 2019 la différence avec la
réforme de cette année et de celle qui
vont précéder c'est que c'était une
réforme systémique précisé
paramètres
ce que dit le gouvernement c'est que
cette réforme doit assurer l'équilibre
financier du système assura l'équipe
financier du système des retraites en
2030 quand on lui demande et au-delà ce
qui est très intéressant c'est que les
ministres porte-parole pas les ministres
en première ligne élu d'un peu la
question et en réalité
parce que il sera plus président de la
République enfin attendez 30 non 2030
non puisque ils ne sont pas inventé
qu'en 2032 exactement
quoi qu'il en soit ils élus de la
question et précisément parce que oui il
faudra à nouveau réformer les retraites
après en tout cas les économistes
unanimes sur la question en 2030 pour
garantir l'équipe financiers au-delà de
donc oui oui le le bal la valse des
réformes paramétriques comme j'aime à
l'appeler reviendra reviendra à nouveau
dans cinq ans un emploi après ça
dépendra évidemment du gouvernement mais
en tout cas bien sûr je peux pas vous
dire s'il y aura une nouvelle réforme
mais il y aura à nouveau besoin si on
veut garder un système à l'équilibre de
réformer ça c'est certain il y a
certaines déclarations notamment celle
du maire de Cannes la ville nisnard qui
parle d'une pyramide de Ponzi déjà
expliqué où est-ce que c'est parce que
on en a entendu parler avec Bernard
Madoff à l'époque exactement
expliquez-moi d'abord ce que c'est et
puis après on essaie de faire coller ça
à la réforme des retraites une pyramide
de Ponzi ou un système de Ponzi ou une
chaîne de Ponzi c'est un système de
cavalerie financière qui consiste c'est
assez simple au fond à financer les
rendements d'investisseurs avec l'argent
qu'il y a porté par les nouveaux
investissements c'est assez simple je
vous demande à vous Thibault de Me
plutôt vous me confier 10 euros et je
vous garantis
je voulais je le place sur les marchés
financiers et je vous garantis de vous
rétribuer un euro tous les ans 7 euros
tous les je garde votre 10 euros pour
moi en feignant de les placer sur les
marchés financiers et tous les tous les
l'euro annuels que je vous dois je vous
donne grâce à l'argent d'autres
personnes qui comme vous rejoindre 10
euros
la pyramide finie par s'effondrer parce
que il y a plus de financiers parce
qu'il y a plus assez de monde pour
rétribuer les les investisseurs vous
comprenez exactement le rapport avec la
réforme des retraites on se trouve avec
ce problème démographique assez
on a beaucoup de retraités et pas assez
d'actifs pour financer leur retraite
donc c'est ce qui pousse certains
d'elvisnard en particulier dans le JDD
ce dimanche je vous le rappeliez à
assimiler le système de retraite à une
pyramide de Ponzi ce que je dois dire
toutefois c'est que la différence c'est
que derrière le système des retraites il
y a quand même l'État et que l'État
aidera toujours
à faire toujours en sorte a priori que
la pyramide ne s'effondre pas après la
question qui reste entière
qu'il faut lui aussi il est pour une
forme systémique et changer cette
manière de rétribuer les retraités
l'isnard son combat ce qu'il défend
c'est d'ajouter un peu de capitalisation
dans le système par répartition
expliquez-moi ça aussi c'est pas simple
tout à fait le système par répartition
c'est celui qui est en vigueur
aujourd'hui pour pour le système de
retraite générale c'est aussi c'est très
simple aussi c'est à dire que c'est les
actifs c'est vous c'est moi qui
finançons directement les pensions des
gens qui sont actuellement à la retraite
donc tous les tous les mois on
fonctionne une partie de votre salaire
qui vont financer directement les gens
qui sont actuellement retraités bien sûr
la différence entre la répartition et la
capitalisation c'est que la
capitalisation vous cotisez pour
vous-même pour moi donc c'est un système
individualisé qui repose pas sur la
solidarité entre génération c'est un peu
comme quand vous ouvrez une assurance
vie ou un plan d'épargne retraite
c'est-à-dire que vous placez de l'argent
vous la faites fructifier sur les
marchés et il vous reviendra cet argent
lorsque vous partirez à la retraite vous
trouverez une petite dose de
capitalisation exactement bon avec un
fond de pension alors ça c'est pas du
tout envisagé par le gouvernement non
non
en fait ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
que cette capitalisation publique par un
fond de pension publique comme c'est le
cas aux États-Unis en particulier c'est
pas une mesure qui est très publicitée
parmi les Français
une dernière question de Richard les
jeunes parce que on a vu que certains
étaient dans dans la rue ils sont notés
d'Hélène va en dans quelques instants
est-ce qu'il croit encore au fait qu'ils
auront une retraite pas tant que ça
manifestement certains le croient
puisqu'il manifeste mais si on regarde
les chiffres non et c'est même assez
flagrant
il y a une étude du sac de l'épargne qui
montre assez récente qui montre que 80%
des des
18-34 ans c'est inquiet et pense que le
système des retraites sera en faillite
dans les 10 prochaines années donc c'est
sans appel et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'on voit que ces
jeunes là
sont très inquiets ils s'organisent en
conséquence et donc eux ont beaucoup
recours à l'épargne et donc à la
capitalisation sent tellement compter
sur le système par répartition et ça
peut être une solution merci beaucoup
Richard Ferrari on retrouve Timothée
delhem j'avoue que la personne si vous
accompagne faisait partie de ces 18 34
ans c'est Sacha tout à fait s'il est
dans la rue c'est qu'il pense qu'il aura
une une retraite lui
absolument Tibo avec Victor 23 ans
étudiant en théâtre à Paris vous êtes
dans la rue ça veut dire que vous pensez
vous espérez encore avoir une une
retraite plus tard j'ai un petit peu
renoncé à avoir une retraite parce que
bon je pense que c'est compliqué de déjà
c'est loin
au niveau de ma vie de penser qu'il y a
une
retraite parce que bon je suis jeune et
j'ai beaucoup de d'années d'études de
d'études et de travail avant d'y arriver
mais je pense aussi que
je me bats surtout pour les gens
actuellement qui sont proches de cette
retraite et qui pourront pas forcément
profiter à cause de leur santé notamment
les personnes les plus
les moins riches parce que les personnes
les moins riches sont une espérance de
vie qui est plus faible et qui est
beaucoup moins importante que les
personnes les plus riches aujourd'hui
c'est encore les personnes les moins
riches qui vont tranquille alors que
celle qui travaille le plus déjà donc
vous dites qu'en fait vous manifestez
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas tant pour
votre retraite parce que ça vous paraît
bien loin voilà c'est ça c'est lointain
mais je vois des gens autour de moi qui
peuvent même pas attendre de l'âge de la
retraite qui qui sont dans un état
lamentable et les voir ça me fait mal ça
me touche ça me ça me percute et quand
je vois ça je peux pas laisser genre je
peux pas ne rien faire quoi je suis
touché par ça je suis empathique on va
dire qu'est-ce qu'il se dit dans les
mouvements étudiants vous êtes venus
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous êtes venus à
plusieurs est-ce que vous sentez qu'il y
a un mouvement qui prend ou bien vous
êtes venu de manière un petit peu isolée
cet après-midi
je suis venu avec un ami et puis on a
retrouvé de deux ou trois amis et on
sent quand même qu'il y a cet état de de
confusion par rapport à notre avenir
parce que
bah on va juste fou quoi on va aller
jusqu'où on va trouver jusqu'où dans
quelles conditions est-ce qu'on sera en
mauvaise santé on a beaucoup d'inconnus
la retraite c'est très lointain en même
temps ça nous concerne parce que bah
c'est maintenant que ça se décide et
c'est maintenant c'est dessiner notre
avenir aussi quoi l'examen du projet de
loi a débuté à l'Assemblée nationale
hier si vous étiez interrogé si vous
deviez dire quelque chose au député ou
bien au gouvernement qu'est-ce que vous
leur diriez ben je leur demanderai
de réfléchir à la condition humaine des
gens qui vont travailler en mauvaise
santé et qui devront s'arrêter avant qui
toucheront pas leur retraite à taux
plein qui vont vivre dans la précarité à
cause de leur santé parce que juste ils
sont bout du rouleau et c'est des
questions de qui faut se poser en tant
qu'être humain avant tout et pas
seulement en tant que politique il y a
des questions qui dépassent le simple la
simple économie à des questions qui qui
doivent parler à l'être humain avant
tout aussi dernière question il y a
quelles sont les perspectives selon vous
de ce mouvement de contestation si le
mouvement venait à se durcir avec par
exemple des blocages est-ce que c'est ce
sont des choses dont vous parlez par
exemple avec vos camarades d'étudiants
c'est des choses auxquelles on parle
malheureusement le problème c'est que la
radicalité est souvent le seul moyen
d'être entendu et moi j'ai pas envie de
me radicaliser pour me faire entendre et
je pense que le gouvernement c'est à ce
moment là qu'il faut qu'il nous
entendent parce que c'est à ce moment là
où on s'est encore relativement
pacifique qu'il faut quand même avoir
cet écoute des gens qui vont dans la rue
des gens qui travaillent ne pas attendre
que ça dégénère comme ça pu déjà
dégénérer avec les gilets jaunes c'est
maintenant qu'il faut avoir cet écoute
là voilà merci beaucoup pour ce pour ces
quelques mots alors que Thibault le
cortège continue d'arriver avec ce flux
continu qui arrive sur cette place
Vauban et vous l'avez certainement
entendu des pétards ou bien des des
pétards insourissants c'est pas
exactement de quoi il s'agit on va on va
aller voir qui ont qui ont retenti
ambiance toujours un petit peu pareil on
sent que il y a de la tension dans l'air
mais pour l'instant c'est le contenu pas
de gros mouvements de full ni
d'affrontement en tous les cas
en espérant que ça reste comme ça
jusqu'à la fin de cette manifestation
voir s'entraînement les villas bonjour
bonjour Thibault directeur agent de la
rédaction du Figaro acte 2
moments déjà décisif dans cette danse
Bradfer ou bon pas forcément on en fait
trop non au moment enfin si on prend les
éléments objectifs maintenant il faut
attendre d'avoir les chiffres définitifs
il faut attendre de voir si la dimension
pacifique de la manifestation se
poursuit jusqu'à la fin mais bon il y a
moins de grévistes mais il y a une
mobilisation plus importante et donc ce
mouvement s'inscrit maintenant dans la
durée on a compris que ça n'est pas
l'équivalent de ce qui s'était passé en
2019 en 2019 la première manifestation
réunit 800 ou 900 000 personnes et des
lasses secondes
là il y a à la fois la conjonction d'une
opinion publique qui dans les sondages
reste très majoritairement contre la
réforme des retraites de manifestants
qui parviennent à donner une image pour
le moment qui ne correspond pas à
l'aborderification je mets les
guillemets puisque c'est le mot employé
par le ministre de l'Intérieur et puis
on a en face un gouvernement qui est
déterminé à ne pas céder sur les
éléments centraux de de sa réforme donc
alors le mot guerre serait peut-être un
peu excessif parce que on n'est pas dans
une chose militaire mais la guerre
d'opposition voilà on est maintenant les
positions sont fixées et ça va être
à
chacun des camps va attendre que l'autre
fasse une erreur ou une faute pour
essayer de pousser son avantage les
Français quant à eux doivent s'attendre
à avoir plusieurs semaines avec des
transports erratiques avec des
manifestations et avec une incertitude
qu'installe ce mouvement social vous
souvenez une question j'ai l'impression
que les plus pragmatiques semblent bien
qu'il faut faire cette réforme des
retraite en tout cas qu'il faut faire
une réforme des retraites pourquoi les
Français n'y adhèrent pas vous l'avez
dit ils sont dans les sondages
défend et contraire avec ce qu'il a
pratiqué je m'explique la réforme des
retraites elle est fondée sur deux
piliers fondamentaux le travail
l'équilibre des comptes le travail a été
comment dire
détourner de son principe il était le
cœur palpitant de la vie et il est
devenu secondaire et notamment dans un
moment de cristallisation collectif qui
a été le confinement c'est-à-dire que
les gens ont vu qui pouvaient gagner de
l'argent sans travailler et profiter de
leur vie privée et de leur cocon sans
travailler donc ça a été la réalisation
de du rêve de Benoît monte une forme de
revenus universel et puis d'autres alors
j'exclus de ce il faut le préciser de ce
de ce moment la première ligne mais la
première ligne ce qu'on appelait à
première ligne c'est-à-dire les
caissiers les gens qui allaient
travailler les gens qui allaient à
l'hôpital etc mais ces gens-là ne sont
pas dans les représentations collectives
du travail la deuxième chose et ça c'est
à mon avis le plus difficile à renverser
pour le gouvernement c'est l'équilibre
des comptes c'est à dire que le ressort
profond de cette réforme c'est
rééquilibrer les comptes de notre
système de retraite or depuis le covid
et le et la crise sanitaire la notion
même de déficites a disparu des esprits
puisque les sommes engagés sont hors
même de nos possibilités de
représentation pendant un instant
Vincent parce qu'on voit ces images et
ça évolue malheureusement
nous sommes place Vauban donc l'arrivée
du cortège on va essayer de retrouver de
Timothée d'Hélène parce que lui il est
sur place il va pouvoir nous expliquer
ce qu'il voit mais on a déjà des images
qui nous n'avions pas vu
lors du dernier lors de la dernière
journée de mobilisation le 19 janvier
oui là c'est des images qui ressemblent
plus à malheureusement ce qu'on voit à
la fin de chaque manifestation pour le
moment on va voir comment ça tourne on
pourra pas vu se former en tout cas dans
la manif jusqu'ici de Black Bloc non
oui si on en reste là on pourra pas dire
que malheureusement c'est une forme de
de rituel
qui est désolant mais qui qui est
courant je vous laisse continuer sur sur
donc
l'équilibre des comptes simplement de
chiffres 500 milliards de dépassement
des dépenses publiques selon un Cours
des comptes de 2020 à 2022 donc 140
milliards pour le covid à partir du
moment où vous avez ces chiffres là une
réforme qui entraînerait à terme entre
20 et 30 milliards d'économies
n'apparaît plus comme prioritaire pour
ceux dont vous parlez c'est-à-dire ceux
qui pensent qu'elle est nécessaire et
donc cette réforme leur apparaît comme
accessoire le problème simplement on a
donné tellement d'argent et on a ouvert
les caisses tellement de points
notamment pendant le covid que
finalement c'est 20 milliards là et on
va bien trouver l'État le pognon de
dingue quelque part exactement et au
fait il y a maintenant une forme de
jurisprudence
de la dépense un esprit de dépense qui
fait que la notion d'économie et
d'équilibre a disparu de la plupart des
esprits ou en tout cas cela même qui
sont attachés se disent mais pourquoi
faire des économies sur ce domaine alors
qu'on pourrait en faire dans dans
d'autres je sais pas si vous avez lu ce
matin l'interview qu'on a publié de
François l'anglais oui qui évoquait ce
sujet là et qui rappelait que il y avait
même eu dans le différent chèque d'aide
les remboursements des grilles peints
bon c'est une c'est une symbolique
extrêmement éloquente puisque ça veut
dire que dans les moindres petits objets
de la vie quotidienne l'état vient nous
assister et là il demande un effort je
pense que c'est ça qui rend la chose
difficilement intelligible pour des gens
qui seraient plutôt favorables et après
et pour ceux qui sont de toute façon
opposés alors après la question c'est de
savoir qu'est-ce qui dans quel autre
motif de contestation s'agrège c'est à
dire
la personne d'Emmanuel Macron
l'inflation
et ça pour le moment je n'ai pas
l'impression qu'on assiste à une
coagulation on a eu quand même lorsque
Timothée Vincent sur le terrain ont posé
la question avait manifestants il y en a
eu plusieurs ils ont toujours ils
viennent pour manifester contre la
réforme des retraites il y a toujours un
petit quelque chose en plus il y a une
prof qui est contre la fermeture de son
lycée il y a un une aide-soignante qui
est contre
la désertification enfin voilà etc non
mais il y a de toute façon un terrain
favorable mais mais il y a on a publié
lundi une étude très importante très
intéressante de Jérôme Fourquet sur les
villes moyennes qui se sont mobilisées
les et les populations qui se sont
mobilisées
on voit dans dans ce travail notamment
que les endroits où les RN vote beaucoup
donc les gens qui devraient très opposés
à la politique et à Manuel Macron c'est
les endroits où les manifestations sont
les moins spectaculaires donc là on a
quand même une population habituée se
manifester c'est qu'il se retrouve et là
je voudrais le souligner parce qu'on
compare ça ces chiffres là au chiffre de
2019 voire de 2010 mais la France 2023
c'est pas la France de 2017 et il y a eu
entre les deux le covid et la France
était l'expression est toujours Kate
comme une dans une sorte de covid long
et donc d'une sorte d'aphasie politique
où on se disait mais plus personne ne
s'intéresse à la politique les gens sont
que dans l'individuel et pas dans le
collectif donc réussir à à organiser une
manifestation aussi spectaculaire ça
veut dire quelque chose je pense que le
million et demi doit être considéré
comme plus important que les millions et
demi que l'on voyait lors de la réforme
verte en 2010 2011
les gilets jaunes sont passés par là
également entre 2010 et 2023 et
on a eu et on pensait que ces syndicats
étaient incapables n'avaient plus la
main ne pouvait plus réunir autant de
monde dans la rue finalement si là c'est
possible c'est toujours possible c'est
un peu inespéré pour eux c'est de dire
que là le cette réforme vient leur
offrir le moyen de ils en étaient à
la question de la survie dans leur
capacité de représentation et de
contestation bah là il retrouve un rôle
alors jusqu'à ces images si elle ne
dégénère pas mais il montre aussi une
capacité à manifester qui se distingue
de celle des gilets jaunes qui étaient
un espèce de mouvement complètement
liquide impossible à maîtriser et qui
remettait en cause même ses propres
chefs donc il restaure une forme de
qui avait un chef qui arrivait on lui
disait qu'il est coupé la légitime et on
l'écartait quoi là il retrouve une forme
de en fait on retrouve une forme de
chorégraphie traditionnelle avec un
pouvoir qui tient sa position et des
syndicats organise des manifestations
pour obtenir
un compromis et pour le moment la
poussée n'est pas encore assez forte
pour que le le gouvernement soit
vraiment
contraint de
faire ce compromis donc encore une fois
c'est les 15 jours à venir qui vont être
décisifs est-ce que c'est le point
culminant est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
effet de souffle après cette
manifestation et des blocages ça ma vie
personne ne le sait aujourd'hui et c'est
ce sera à nous de le suivre jour le fond
Timothée delhem est-ce qu'il est avec
nous parce que je voudrais qu'il nous
explique ce qu'il se passe place Vauban
ah ça vient de couper on va attendre
quelques minutes le réseau passe à
nouveau parce qu'on a envie de savoir ce
qu'il se passe pour ce rebond on voit
quelques échauffourés rien de dramatique
pour l'instant dans ce qu'on voit c'est
toujours dommage évidemment Timothée
vous êtes sur place dites-moi on vous a
retrouvé qu'est-ce que vous voyez ça
s'agite
Timothée de l'aime je voudrais qu'on
fasse un peu de politique politicienne
malheureusement Vincent Jabès un peu le
niveau mais on essaie de faire les
comptes tout à l'heure avec avec
Guillaume Tabar parce que il y a des
preuves de la rue évidemment visiblement
les gouvernements depuis plusieurs
années son moque un peu mais dans les
jours qui viennent il y a la bataille à
l'Assemblée nationale pour l'instant il
n'est vraiment pas certain qu'il
Emmanuel Macron puisse faire passer son
texte mais la grande différence de
Guillaume a du voulait expliquer
brillamment avec les précédentes réforme
de retraite et avec la chorégraphie du
gouvernement face aux syndicats et au
contestataire la grande différence c'est
que aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
de majorité absolue voilà donc il a une
majorité relative qu'il peut enrichir
grâce au groupe des Républicains mais
c'est là que ces manifestations sont
importantes autant que les blocages
c'est à dire que l'effet symbolique de
la
peut donner des raisons et à certains
députés de la majorité et surtout à
beaucoup de députés des républicains de
dire bon moi j'étais pour mais pas comme
ça ah pas maintenant vous êtes en train
de me donner la réponse que j'attends
depuis le début de cette journée à quoi
ça sert c'est ça la question je me pose
à quoi ça sert de faire tout ça alors
qu'on voit bien que le gouvernement ne
va pas reculer il ne l'a pas fait c'est
un autre gouvernement mais en 2010
Nicolas Sarkozy et François Fillon
n'avait pas reculé en 2019 il n'était
pas prêt à reculer Emmanuel Macron
pourquoi il le ferait ici ne le fera pas
vous me donnez un concert à deux ces
choses là ça servant d'abord pour ceux
qui ont été manifestés
un mouvement social il est réussi quand
celui qui participe peut se regarder en
images et contempler son succès donc là
manifestement rentrer ce soir ils vont
regarder Figaro live
peut-être des chaînes d'info continu si
ils regardent pas tous Figaro live mais
se trompe et ils vont voir que ce qu'ils
ont fait a fonctionné donc normalement
les stimules pour recommencer ensuite
qu'est-ce que à quoi ça sert ça sert à
bousculer
psychologiquement ceux qui sont dans la
majorité ou dans la périphérie de la
majorité les plus fragiles et les moins
déterminés au fond d'eux à soutenir
cette réforme il y en a à droite mais il
faut quand même voir que il y en a aussi
à gauche le la gauche de du macronisme
Marisol Touraine Françoise samen on dit
publiquement qu'ils étaient opposés à
cette réforme Gilles Legendre ancien
patron quand même du groupe en marche à
l'Assemblée barbara Pompili a dit qu'il
était opposé barbara Pompili ancienne
ministre d'ailleurs
mais qui n'ont jamais été emballés par
cette mesure d'âge et qui donc accepte
de prendre sur eux pour défendre ce
texte
borne et Olivier Dussault au début du
processus était absolument favorable à
cette mesure maintenant ils l'ont adopté
ils vont la défendre jusqu'au bout mais
si vous voulez ça n'est pas vous n'êtes
pas dans le même état d'esprit quand
vous êtes convaincu de votre bon droit
depuis toujours ou quand vous devez
porter quelque chose sur lequel vous
auriez pu discuter et quand derrière
vous voyez une foule qui vient vous dire
il sait pas comme ça qu'il faut faire et
pour les anciens socialistes
dans la foule que l'on voit là il
retrouve un peu de leur imaginaire de
leur mythologie donc c'est c'est
en ça que c'est c'est manifestations
peuvent avoir un rôle plus important que
qu'en 2010 parce que il y a cette
fragilité
parlementaire Timothée on voit les
images en bas à gauche Timothée est-ce
que vous pouvez nous décrire ce qu'il se
passe devant vous vous entendez déjà
vous êtes au milieu des gaz lacrymogènes
on entend sporadiquement Timothée delhem
c'est pas grave on a les images et on
essaye de suivre ce qu'il se passe place
Vauban à l'arrivée du cortège on est
encore ensemble 5 minutes si vous le
voulez bien Vincent tremolet
si vous voulez si je vais conclure ce
que je vous disais la manifestation
c'est une condition qui n'est pas
suffisante mais qui est nécessaire de là
il peut arriver aussi des événements
dans cette manifestation et j'espère
qu'il n'arriveront pas mais toutes les
questions de maintien de l'ordre peuvent
devenir des questions politiques on l'a
vu dans d'autres manifestations il peut
y avoir dans des déclarations
gouvernementales une provocation un
propos malheureux à une comparaison
malvenue qui fait qu'il y a une
remobilisation de
décompter sa terre moi j'ai en tête
c'était avant les gilets jaunes qu'un
jour avant la première manifestation
quand Benjamin Griveaux dit c'est la
France qui fume des clopes et qui roule
au diesel oui c'est pas il augmente 5%
euh la participation mécaniquement donc
voilà il y a il y a ça crée un terrain
très un peu fragile sur lequel il faut
conduire c'est un peu de l'aquaplaning
il faut pas faire une seule sortie de
route parce que ça peut aller très vite
derrière on fait les comptes à
l'Assemblée nationale et me dire vous
aussi si ça vous paraît clair et si je
me trompe une quinzaine de députés de la
majorité sont hésitants sont prêt à
voter contre ou à s'abstenir est-ce que
ça vous paraît de cet ordre là pour
l'instant alors je serai plus prudent
c'est à dire que il se déclare opposé
d'accord évoque une abstention quand on
arrivera au moment du est-ce que vous
êtes avec nous pas avec nous ça dépendra
du climat les 15 LR alors oui cela c'est
la deuxième partie beaucoup plus
difficile pour le gouvernement
62 députés dans le groupe LR
le tiers serait dans cette situation
également
s'abstenir ou voter contre si on part
pour le gouvernement avec ses 20 LR qui
s'abstiennent ou qui votre contre et ces
vins 15 députés de la majorité qui vote
contre ça fait pas 289 ou en tout cas ça
fait pas la moitié du corps
très important et l'assemblée n'est pas
une
un lieu clos un Vasse clos
elle reçoit elle est la chambre déco de
ce qui se passe aussi dans la rue et
donc selon le climat c'est député
qui sont dissonants par rapport à leur
groupe
six centres qui sont portés par un
mouvement très fort ils auront envie et
ils seront confortés dans leur volonté
de ne pas suivre ce qu'on leur demande
mais en revanche si le mouvement
tournait vinaigre s'il commençait à
avoir des violences s'il y avait une
lassitude de l'opinion publique devant
les à la fois la casse les blocages etc
vous pouvez avoir aussi des députés LR
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas favorables à
la réforme qui la vote donc ça ce climat
on le connaît pas aujourd'hui et tout
tout le jeu en fait entre les syndicats
et et le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron
c'est de pousser l'autre à la faute pour
faire basculer ces 30 c'est 40 voies qui
qui seront décisions quelle est la
tendance aujourd'hui est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron est prêt à tenter sa chance à
prendre son risque comme il dit souvent
en soumettant en vote sa réforme des
retraites ou
préfère-t-il même si il se dit qu'il
n'aime pas beaucoup de 49-3
préférera-t-il à passer ce texte par le
49-3 quelle est la tendance aujourd'hui
il veut obtenir une majorité pour voter
son texte il y croit il peut encore y
croire il peut encore tout à fait y
croire légitimement
il faut voir que la question là on voit
les images c'est pour ça que Gérald
Darmanin l'a fait
la question va être est-ce que le
mouvement social va restaurer les forces
du désordre contre le parti de l'Europe
le parti de l'ordre c'était un peu ce
qui a incarné Emmanuel Macron à la fin
des gilets jaunes et ce qui lui a permis
avec une tête de liste qui n'était pas
très connue
à la aux élections européennes de faire
Nathalie Loiseau de faire un très beau
score si jamais cette dialectique entre
partie de l'ordre des forces du désordre
se remettaient en place
les députés les républicains auront du
mal à participer directement ou
indirectement à ce qui serait considéré
comme comme le désordre donc vous voyez
c'est c'est bon et ça il faut plusieurs
manifestations il faut des blocages il
faut des actes et puis si d'un autre
côté vous avez des provocations vous
pouvez aussi avoir des gens qui lâchent
en faisant maintenant c'est plus
possible
on n'a pas vu s'appuie des années non
bah là oui le le de toute façon le
Parlement est l'Assemblée nationale et
est redevenu parce qu'on en parlait
politique français alors que pendant les
5 dernières années tout se passait à
l'Élysée
et là le Parlement crée une forme
d'incertitude et de dramaturgie qui qui
lui est propre avec quand même il faut
le reconnaître un gouvernement qui pour
le moment parvient malgré ses
difficultés cette majorité relative à
faire adopter un à un dans la douleur
mais il y arrive quand même ces textes
vous en parliez ce sera ma dernière
question de Vincent très mollet vous me
parliez de ce duel entre gouvernement
les corps intermédiaires les syndicats
il y avait un article ce matin d'Arthur
berbrad François-Xavier bourneau qui
expliquait qu'Emmanuel Macron avait tout
fait pour éviter ça comment il avait
commencé comment se sont déroulés ces
six années pour en arriver là et se
retrouver dans la même situation que les
autres est-ce qu'il y a cru peut-être il
a cru à son rêve de nouveau monde moi
qui me laissait sceptique et le nouveau
monde c'était donc le dépassement de du
clivage traditionnel de la droite et de
la gauche c'était aussi la
désintermédiation c'est-à-dire qu'on
allait directement du président de la
République aux personnes et aux
individus retraités et pas et que toutes
ces vieilles formes et le l'Assemblée
nationale était une chambre
d'enregistrement et il ne fallait pas
revivre ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a vécu
comme ministre de l'économie avec la loi
Macron où il a trouvé infernal d'avoir à
jouer avec les députés socialistes qui
pouvaient mener la fronde tout est
revenu mais parce que le nouveau monde
n'existe pas et les permanences
surtout en France sont des choses qui
traversent le temps et donc en France
quand on veut faire une réforme sur le
travail il y a des syndicats il y a des
gens qui manifestent et il y a une
chorégraphie qui ressemble celle qui
précède l'aventure politique de
d'Emmanuel Macron et il est obligé
maintenant de de l'affronter de s'y
confronter merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
Vincent très bien de la rédaction du
Figaro on va rester avec ces images là
qu'on rejoigne d'abord Vincent roseron
Vincent vous vous êtes plutôt en queue
de cortège vous voyez pas ce qu'il se
passe place Vauban à l'arrivée de la
manifestation de votre côté c'est calme
c'est ça
[Musique]
effectivement de mon côté c'est
extrêmement calme comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images à part de la musique
qui est très très forte à côté de moi
actuellement mais pour l'instant tout
est extrêmement calé en tout cas à
l'arrière du cortège ce cortège qui a
mis beaucoup beaucoup de temps à
démarrer là à 18h les business ne sont
pas encore arrivé à Montparnasse donc
ils avancent petit à petit je suis
toujours dans le cortège de la CGT qui
avance voilà petit à petit dans une
bonne ambiance
merci beaucoup merci Vincent rose on
retrouve Timothée delhem Timothée vous
êtes place Vauban c'est l'axe déroule
les événements de cette fin de journée
de cette fin de manifestation c'est
tendu on a vu des affrontements entre
forces de l'ordre et manifestants
oui Thibault c'est très tendu ici vous
l'avez vu sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc des moments de grande tension
avec on a vu des
projectiles qui ont été lancés contre
les forces de l'ordre et qui ont répondu
par des tirs de gaz la
de gaz lacrymogène alors que notre Jr il
vient d'être à l'instant agréé par un
par un manifestant je ne sais pas si
vous m'entendez encore Thibault c'est
très tendu ici voilà des gaz
lacrymogènes pour bien calmer tenter de
calmer les tenter de calmer les
manifestants alors que voilà bon j'y
arrive rien de se faire bousculer
ambiance très tendue ici ça commence
vraiment à dégénérer sur la sur la place
Vauban avec quelques charges de de des
forces de l'ordre pour essayer de
contenir tout cela mais c'est vrai que
c'est très très confus ici
merci Timothée on va rester avec ces
autres images un peu en hauteur que vous
allez découvrir de la place Vauban avec
les forces de l'ordre les policiers qui
voilà en haut à gauche on va les mettre
en plein écran je demande à Riad Becker
qui est en régie parce que c'est là que
ça se passe place Vauban c'est là que
s'achève cette manifestation ce défilé
et donc il y a des des échauffourées je
voudrais qu'on puisse avoir le son et
l'image on essaie d'écouter ce qui se
passe quelques instants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok d'accord à tout de suite
[Musique]
et je roule et tout ça
pinceau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
18h08 nous sommes toujours en direct sur
le cigare au point fr Figaro live sur la
page Youtube du Figaro nous suivons la
fin de cette deuxième journée de grève
contre la réforme des retraites la fin
de la manifestation parisienne avec
malheureusement et pour la première fois
depuis le début de ce mouvement des
échauffourés des affrontements entre
force de l'ordre et manifestants
difficile pour l'instant de quantifier
l'étendue des dégâts on a vu tout au
long de l'après-midi l'atmosphère un peu
tendue avec notamment des
devantures de banques fracassées taguer
et là place Vauban vous voyez ces
colonnes de gendarmes mobiles ou de CRS
qui tentent de désamorcer ces violences
on retrouve Timothée Delam vous mettez
vous êtes sur place
racontez-nous vous nous le disiez depuis
le début de la journée s'est étendu et
bien ça y est ça a fini par exploser
place Vauban
[Musique]
oui Thibault c'est exactement cela vous
le voyez sur ces images en direct de
Julien Leclerc nous sommes au milieu de
la place Vauban c'était étendu on
sentait que voilà ça pouvait un petit
peu éclater à tout moment
malheureusement c'est ce qui est arrivé
avec notamment pendant notre notre
dernier duplex un manifestant qui est
bien bousculé Julien Leclerc qui est
derrière la caméra et qui a endommagé
notre notre caméra c'est la tâche du
moniteur en fait qui qui est se détache
désormais voilà on fait attention en
tous les cas vous le voyez cette
situation qui est très tendue ce qui se
passe et bien c'est que des manifestants
invectives les forces de l'ordre on a vu
des pavés comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui ont été lancés contre les
forces de l'ordre des beaucoup de gaz
lacrymogènes il y a également eu
quelques tirs de mortier
qui ont été dirigés en fonction en
direction pardon des forces de l'ordre
on vous fait vivre ce moment en direct
vous le voyez sur ces sur ces images le
boulevard par lequel nous arrivions sur
cette place Vauban a été bouclés a été
fermé par la police et donc et bien les
les manifestants qui sont en train
d'arriver par les rues adjacentes nous
avons nous avons également vu de
nombreuses interpellations quand je dis
de nombreuses évidemment on les a pas
tout vu quand je dis nombreuses c'est
peut-être 4-5 que nous avons vu de nos
propres yeux je ne sais pas combien il y
en a eu exactement en tous les cas
voilà l'ambiance ici toujours très
tendue vous en vendre vous entendez
peut-être ces invectives que l'on entend
depuis tout à l'heure bande de parasites
je viens d'entendre à l'instant et je ne
vais pas toutes les toutes les répéter à
l'antenne évidemment mais c'est pour
vous donner une idée
de ce qu'il se passe actuellement place
Vauban c'est assez paradoxal parce que
d'un côté c'est très tendu avec
notamment ce que nous venons nous-mêmes
de vivre mais en même temps ça ne
dégénère pas c'est à dire que l'ambiance
enfin le la tension pardon reste
maîtrisé par les forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
on aurait pu craindre que que ça
continue à ça il y a comme une petite
accalmie pour le moment vous voyez sur
ces images de Julien Leclerc qui est qui
est derrière la caméra vous voyez
les policiers qui sont qui sont là avec
leur bouclier
et bien pour se protéger parce que des
projectiles ont été lancés à leur
rencontre il y a eu plusieurs charges de
policiers tout à l'heure c'est la raison
pour laquelle d'ailleurs
nous n'avons pas pu intervenir à
l'antenne pendant pendant quelques
secondes parce que et bien dans la cohue
général
et bien évidemment nous avons perdu le
contact entre entre mon gris Julien
Leclerc et moi-même et donc voilà c'est
la raison pour laquelle le réseau ne
fonctionnait plus nous nous sommes
retrouvés tout tout va tout va bien si
j'ose dire pour nous mais voilà cette
ambiance assez tendue il y a quelques
pavés là par terre qui ont été décrochés
par les par les manifestants en fonction
des en direction pardon des forces de
l'ordre
voilà je vous laisse vivre ces moments
en direct avec
avec ces images
on sent que voilà c'est très tendu et en
même temps c'est ça ne dégénère pas pour
le moment
mais les manifestants qui
ne quitte pas les lieux en tout cas pour
l'instant et c'est peut-être la raison
pour laquelle
la situation reste très tendue on voit
que les gens restent là les gens
regardent certains invectives comme je
le disais les policiers voilà donc c'est
c'est une ambiance très particulière sur
la sur la place Vauban là pour le moment
merci Timothée reprenez votre souffle
merci de nous faire vivre et nous rendre
compte de ce qu'il se passe place Vauban
le récapitulatif de la journée on reste
ensemble un moment évidemment pour
suivre les évolutions
des événements de la fin de cette
manifestation
place Vauban à Paris une manifestation
qui s'était lancée tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 14h 14h30 depuis la place
d'Italie
ambiance tendue c'est ce que nous ont
dit tout au long de l'après-midi les
reporters sur le terrain même si ça
n'avait pas explosé jusqu'ici jusque aux
alentours de 17h45 où les premiers
affrontements ont eu lieu place Vauban
entre les forces de l'ordre et certains
manifestants certains manifestants qui
s'en étaient pris un peu plus tôt dans
la journée toutefois à des devantures de
banques notamment
ça avait étendu lors du passage du
cortège devant le restaurant La rot vous
savez ce restaurant ou le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron lors du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 avait dîné le
soir avec des personnalités cela avait
fait grand bruit et c'est ce restaurant
était devenu un symbole de la macronie
on a des chiffres qui sont tombés tout
au long de la de l'après-midi alors les
chiffres à Paris notamment je vais vous
les donner des chiffres à Paris pour
l'instant ce ne sont que les chiffres de
la CGT qui annonce 500 000 manifestants
ils avaient annoncé 400 000 la semaine
dernière tu avais annoncé 400000 le
ministère de l'Intérieur et la
préfecture avaient annoncé 80 000 à
Paris il y a des chiffres officiels en
région à Marseille notamment ça c'est un
chiffre assez important parce qu'il y a
il y avait la semaine dernière 25000
manifestants dans la cité phocéenne il y
en a eu aujourd'hui 40 000 et ça ce sont
des chiffres officiels de la préfecture
donc ça montre sa témoigne d'une d'une
hausse de la mobilisation et c'est à peu
près la même chose partout en France
dans toutes les toutes les villes
moyennes et grandes de du pays voilà ce
qu'on peut dire sur la mobilisation en
revanche des chiffres un peu
différents concernant le nombre de de
grévistes il y a moins de grévistes dans
l'éducation nationale il y a moins de
gregistes dans la fonction publique il y
a plus de trains ce matin plus de métro
donc moins de grévistes mais plus de
personnes dans la rue on explique ces
chiffres peut-être par l'utilisation de
moyens différents pour ne pas aller au
travail les RTT par exemple on peut
compter aussi des lycéens qui ne sont
pas comptés parmi les parmi les
grévistes pour aller pour aller dans la
dans la manifestation les manifestations
voilà qui pourraient expliquer cette
hausse de la mobilisation dans les
manifestations mais pas dans les
chiffres et dans les dans les
entreprises on va rejoindre Vincent
roseron Vincent vous êtes sur place vous
êtes vous en peu plus en arrière de ce
cortège qui a mis du temps à démarrer et
de votre côté c'est beaucoup plus calme
de ce que je vois
[Musique]
oui effectivement je me trouve à la fin
alors je me trouve juste à côté du
restaurant La Rotonde où il y a eu
quelques incidents vous en parlez tout à
l'heure là actuellement moi je me trouve
du coup à ce niveau là il y a les
derniers véhicules qui passent de la de
la de la manifestation les derniers
véhicules qui passent puisque tout de
même on est encore à peu près 30 35
minutes de la place Vauban de la fin du
coup cette manifestation et pour
l'instant tout est tranquille de ce côté
merci Vincent merci en espérant que ça
continue on va rejoindre dans un instant
Timothée de l'aime parce que c'est place
Vauban sous l'hôtel des Invalides
derrière le thème des Invalides que
qu'on lui lieu les affrontements ça a
duré aller 10 minutes un quart d'heure
ça a été court mais assez intense je
vous donne quelques chiffres avant qu'on
retrouve Timothée 45000 manifestants à
Lyon selon la CGT 7000 de plus que lors
de la mobilisation du 19 janvier ça ne
sont pas des chiffres les chiffres
officiels le ministère de l'éducation
qui indique que 1330 lycées ont
participé à des actions aujourd'hui
les lycéens sont donc mobilisés
il y a 4500 lycées publics en France
voilà un quart à peu près des lycées ont
été touchés 11 blocages de lycée voilà
ce que
dit le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale voilà j'essaye de redescendre
pour vous trouver quelques le chiffre
pendant que je les cherche on retrouve
Timothée Delam Timothée vous êtes
toujours sur place Vauban c'est le cas
de le dire comment ça va de ce côté là
est-ce que la tension est retombée un
petit peu
[Musique]
non la tension la tension n'est pas
retombée Thibault ça serait ça serait
vraiment mentir que de vous dire cela ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a un moment où
en fait tout le monde se tout le monde
s'observe et vous le voyez d'ailleurs
là-bas sur ces images de de Julien
Leclerc à une vingtaine de mètres on va
s'approcher un petit peu tout en restant
prudent il y a une charge actuellement
qui est en train d'être mené par les
forces de l'ordre vous vous le voyez sur
ces sur ces images évidemment la nuit
qui est en train de tomber sur cette
place sur cette place Vauban voilà on va
demander à Julien de se déplacer un
petit peu vers la gauche tout en faisant
bien sûr bien bien attention et vous le
voyez donc voilà des projectiles qui qui
sont lancés les forces de l'ordre qui
essayent et bien de casser les
attroupements à l'instant c'est un
mortier là qui
qui est
qui est allumé qui est dirigé contre les
forces de l'ordre vous le voyez sur ces
images de Julien Leclerc vous voyez
également des projectiles qui sont qui
sont lancés les forces de l'ordre qui
sont pour le moment en train de se
replier si j'ose dire malheureusement
c'est c'est un vocabulaire un peu
guerrier mais qui est qui est un petit
peu de circonstances vous voyez
également des de la fumée de la fumée de
mortier ou bien de gaz lacrymogène voilà
c'est toujours très confus très tendu
ici avec un round d'observation et des
et des interpellations pour le moment et
cette odeur de gaz lacrymogène vous
l'imaginez bien mais qui qui est
persistante ici sur cette sur cette
place Vauban
[Musique]
on va rester avec vos images on va
s'imprégner de l'ambiance en espérant
que elle ne soit pas trop mauvaise place
Vauban et on se retrouve dans un instant
on suit tout ce qu'il se passe dans les
dans les rues de la capitale vous avez
en à gauche les images place Vauban en
haut et en bas et puis à droite nous
sommes encore dans le cortège avec
Vincent roseron plus haut vers
Montparnasse on essaie de suivre ce
qu'il se passe avec ces images en direct
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que les forces de l'ordre ont employé
des gaz à lacrymogènes d'ailleurs on
peine à respirer ainsi
très très forte odeur de gaz lacrymogène
vous voyez à l'instant
les forces de l'ordre qui commence
à se diriger de nouveau au milieu de la
place je vous cache pas qu'on a du mal à
parler parce que évidemment les gaz
lacrymogènes font leur effet
et beaucoup de mouvements de foule ici
les forces de l'ordre qui tentent de
reprendre le contrôle de la situation la
situation qu'il y a totalement dégénéré
tout à l'heure
c'est très confus il y a comme un moment
où
et bien voilà un round d'observation
et des charges de policiers de temps en
temps ce sont les la gendarmerie
nationale là qui
que vous voyez actuellement à l'écran
on vient personnellement me demander de
un gendarme qui me demande de décaler
tout cela évidemment sous le regard
attentif de nombreux de nombreux
journalistes que vous voyez avec ce avec
ce bandeau presse
c'est vraiment par vague voilà il y a
des moments où ça se ça se calme où il y
a un round d'observation et puis et puis
voilà quelques projectiles qui sont
lancés puis c'est et puis une nouvelle
une nouvelle scène de tension ça dure
jamais très longtemps
une minute à 2 minutes maximum mais
c'est suffisant pour faire des dégâts
évidemment avec évidemment également de
nombreuses interpellations que nous
avons constaté
il nous restons bien sûr très très
vigilant
pour l'instant ça semble plutôt plutôt
contenu comme vous le voyez sur ces
images
de Julien Leclerc
un gros gros dispositif de de sécurité
nous sommes vraiment entourés là de
gendarmes et de policiers
11000 policiers déployés
d'après 11000 policiers ouais d'après
d'après le ministère de l'Intérieur un
nouveau mouvement là au milieu de la
place Vauban on va s'approcher un petit
peu tout en restant que dans évidemment
ce sont ce que nous voyons là je vous
décris ce que nous voyons à l'instant
sous cette odeur toujours de gaz
lacrymogène
nous voyons des des forces de l'ordre
qui se rapprochent du centre
de la place qu'est-ce qu'il tente de
faire et bien il tente de contenir les
attroupements les attroupements de
[Musique]
voilà de manifestants ou en tous les cas
de
ceux qui cherchent à
en découdre et sur cette place peut-être
que vous le voyez je ne sais pas parce
que évidemment la nuit est tombée mais
il y a des morceaux de pavés par terre
il y a
des détritus des déchets on sent que
voilà il s'est passé quelque chose ici
on sent que la situation a dégénéré cela
se voit très très clairement on va
s'approcher encore un petit peu avec
Julien avec Julien Leclerc ça gaz en
tonton à l'instant voilà c'est
ça ça dégénère c'est difficile à dire on
sent que c'est ça reste contenu mais en
même temps voilà c'est très tendu et il
y a des scènes de de violence
ponctuelles comme je le disais sur
quelques secondes 30 secondes une minute
deux minutes et puis ça redescend et
puis ça reprend voilà
on voit quand même que la place c'est
vider d'ailleurs ça se voit voilà vous
le voyez bien sur ces sur ces images
on sent qu'un certain nombre de
manifestants ont quitté les lieux mais
ceux qui qui veulent en découdre sont
toujours là et toujours les mêmes
slogans
que vous entendez d'ailleurs
probablement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous le voyez probablement sur ces
sur ces images là c'est une ambulance
qui vient de remonter les allées de
Breteuil et qui arrive sur cette place
Vauban
on ne sait pas précisément pour quelle
raison mais voilà c'est une pour vous
expliquer un peu ce que l'on ce que l'on
voit
et alors que certaines
verrez que le cortège continue d'arriver
je ne sais pas là-bas il y a un ballon
de Force Ouvrière qui est en train
d'arriver et là vous me voyez un sous
nos yeux un projectile une bouteille en
verre qui vient d'être lancée
à destination
des des forces de l'ordre des gendarmes
en l'occurrence
[Applaudissements]
vous l'entendez peut-être un des
invectives
[Applaudissements]
on sent tous les cas qu'on est loin de
ce qui se passait tout à l'heure en
début d'après-midi aux alentours de 14h
lorsque les manifestants se sont réunis
sur la la place d'Italie avec cette
ambiance que nous avons nous-mêmes
décrites comme comme une ambiance
presque bonne enfant et là on voit que
ça a vraiment dégénéré et vous entendez
vous entendez à l'instant de nouveau des
slogans de
qui viennent qui viennent d'arriver qui
et qui invective les forces de l'ordre
lesquelles se tiennent prêtes voilà si
vous avez s'il devait y avoir une charge
je vous laisse je vous laisse reprendre
peut-être la main Thibault Christophe
bonsoir Thibault c'est avec ton grand
chef adjoint service société du Figaro
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
bon on disait tout à l'heure vous êtes
venus vers 14h30 que nous n'avions pas
vu de violence lors de la première
manifestation que en région il y avait
une ambiance presque familiale et bien
ça y est il y a eu des débordements ce
soir qu'elle en est l'ampleur voilà
Thibault c'est vrai que le temps un peu
viré à l'orage mais c'est pas encore la
grande tempête genre là on est dans une
configuration
[Musique]
presque classique de fin manifestation
où vous avez le dernier quarteron de de
casseurs ou des métiers qui vont tenter
de faire basculer le mouvement dans
autre chose dans quelque chose de
violent on est à l'heure où je vous
parle avec un bilan qui est quand même
pas énorme il y a eu 23
personnes interpellées il s'agit
essentiellement ce que les policiers
appellent des éléments radicaux donc en
fait des gens qui participent à des
Black Blocs qui s'en prennent aux forces
de l'ordre pardon que ça vous coupe
c'est on vous demandais tout à l'heure
si vous pouvait y avoir un effet
d'entraînement les gens qui ont été
interpellés c'est des gens qui étaient
venus pour ça pour à la ligne ça c'est
sans nul doute
et là c'est des gens notamment qui s'en
prennent aux forces de l'ordre qui
essaient de protéger des jolis ce que me
disent les les notes de police là qui
protège les panneaux de messages
variable aussi autour de la place Vauban
c'est à dire que autour de la place au
bord vous avez des des panneaux qui
permettent aux manifestants de de les
informer sur l'arrivée du cortège sur la
dispersion etc et ça permet en fait de
d'apporter une forme de fluidité au
cortège et là les les casseurs essayent
de briser ces panneaux pour essayer
j'imagine de semer la pagaille la nuit
est tombée
l'espace des Invalides est quand même un
champ de bataille rêvé et le le les
forces de l'ordre vont tout faire pour
pour que ces panneaux de signalisation
puis d'accord renseigner un peu le
public mais on est vraiment pour
l'instant plus sur un round de
d'observation sur une fin de ce serait
comme une fin de partie une fin de
soirée où il y aura deux trois alcoolo
qui resteraient je pense qu'on est
véritablement là dessus on n'est pas sur
la tempête moi je me suis fait j'étais
aux Invalides en 2006 pendant le CPE et
à la même heure il y avait 2000 casseurs
ah oui d'accord qui voulait en découdre
on était vraiment dans un schéma
exactement au même endroit
faire la tête du côté des Invalides on
était juste derrière mais dans le même
périmètre et il y avait 24 heures qui
étaient venus essentiellement de
banlieue et qui
se frottait avec quelques centaines de
militants d'ultra gauche qui était venu
aussi et au milieu il y avait plein de
gaz lacrymogènes et des CRS qui chargée
un peu dans le
dans le brouillard il y avait eu un
grand nombre de blessés je me sens sur
cette place il y avait eu genre 200 à
300 et donc là on est il vient donc très
important d'interpellation
quand on regarde les images
oui je pense qu'il faut raison garder on
va maintenant on va pas se mentir il y a
eu un quart d'heure chaud voilà un quart
d'heure 20 minutes là on voit ces images
en direct place Vauban vous voyez c'est
peut-être un peu loin mais cette colonne
c'est comme ça on voit cette ligne là
c'est force de l'ordre en randonnée on
les voit et il sécurise la place
finalement j'ajoute et j'aimerais qu'on
puisse le retrouver si on peut que
Vincent roseron qui est en amont lui il
est dans le cortège qui continue à
arriver me dit ça se disperse en amont
en fait il n'arrive plus plus personne
n'arrive ou presque place Vauban oui oui
non mais de toute façon là je je vois
que au terme des 23 interpellés là la
dispersion manifestement se poursuit
dans le calme en fait le la préfecture
de police parle d'un épisode comme si il
y avait une espèce de bouffée un peu de
violence qui s'est emparée de la tête du
du cortège où ce où se retrouver c'est
c'est les gens habillés de noir et et
manifestement soucieux dans des cordes
dans des coudes avec les forces mais
pour pour l'instant c'est c'est calme je
peux vous donner un chiffre que je viens
d'avoir de la préfecture de police
la préfecture de police annonce
87000 personnes
à Paris dans les l'itinéraire principal
et l'itinéraire bis d'accord c'est
intéressant ils avaient annoncé 80 000
le 19 janvier donc on a aussi en rose on
est aussi en hausse tout à fait on est
en hausse c'est pas c'est pas un
déferlement c'est c'est c'est une hausse
quand même qu'il faut qu'il faut noter
c'est-à-dire que le mouvement en tout
cas s'essouffle pas c'est ça 23
interpellations la semaine dernière il
en avait eu aussi oui de mémoire on
atteint une trentaine une trentaine
maximum rhum mais c'est celle là encore
ça met en regard avec les quelques 2000
interpellés qui avaient à l'issue de
certains de manifestations des gilets
jaunes ou l'ambiance était infiniment
beaucoup est-ce que baroque est-ce que
les
force de l'ordre les renseignements à
qui vous parlez souvent Christophe vous
ont dit que cet après-midi l'ambiance
était plus tendue parce que c'est ce que
nous ont rapporté les reportages
justement sur le terrain nous disent ça
débordait pas bon il y a eu si une ou
deux devantures de banque taguer brisée
et c'est évidemment de trop mais
c'était pas dramatique non plus mais ils
ont senti tout l'après-midi
il y a eu c'est tout à fait vrai
il y avait comme une forme d'électricité
le cortège les cortèges d'ailleurs il
est peut-être à remarqué que il y a eu
des incidences à Rennes et à Nantes qui
sont de bastions historique de l'ultra
gauche
ultra gauche type qui très classiquement
repart à l'assaut et qu'elle a
l'occasion
donc on a eu effectivement des des
moments comme ça où un peu éruptif mais
pour l'instant j'ai pas l'impression que
dégénéré même si en terme de maintien de
l'ordre il faut toujours être prudent
mais là on a l'impression que la police
contrôle c'est à dire qu'à la bille un
périmètre autour une nasse même si cette
nasse est toujours prévu il y a toujours
une voie de sortie pour que les gens
puissent
évacuer tranquillement s'ils le veulent
et puis après ils peuvent procéder parce
qu'on appelle des bons offensifs c'est à
dire que vous avancez les bons foncils
c'est à dire il bouge pas et puis d'un
seul coup
gagner de l'espace
et mettre en situation d'échec en
situation de pâtes les adversaires comme
aux échecs dans le coin des chéquiers
jusqu'à ce que il y a plus de de il y a
plus d'opposition possible on va
rejoindre Vincent roseron Vincent vous
vous êtes un peu plus loin dans le dans
le cortège vous approchez de la place
Vauban vous me dites que finalement les
manifestants ne se rendront pas place
Vauban il quitte le cortège plutôt
alors si si quand ils vont s'y rendre
ils vont s'y rendre ils sont en chemin
pour s'y rendre mais ce qu'on remarque
c'est que là la manifestation est quand
même assez bloquée c'est rebloqué on va
dire et beaucoup de gens quittent en
fait la manifestation soit par la droite
ou à gauche et rentre peut-être parce
qu'ils savent que ce qui se passe sur la
place Vauban mais du coup voilà on voit
beaucoup de gens faire machine arrière
sortir même si les camions continuent à
avancer petit à petit à la place
merci beaucoup Vincent et Christophe Le
on parlait de
la stratégie du ministère de l'Intérieur
est-ce que ce soir Gérald Darmanin
félicitera ses équipes est-ce que au
contraire il y a eu des débordements
alors que la semaine dernière il en
avait pas eu c'est pas bien
alors où l'on parle si si la physionomie
de de des cortèges en tout cas du
cortège parisien reste celui que l'on
voit
on pourra considérer en tout cas que le
matériel de l'ordre a été une réussite
sur Paris parce que des manifestations
avec
87090000 selon la police donc ça veut
dire qu'on est certainement largement au
dessus de 100000
et qui se déroule un peu de cette
manière là finalement avec un petit
quart d'heure de gaz lacrymogène et 23
interpellés
en termes de maintenir c'est une
véritable réussite bon ce temple
d'autant plus qu'on était sur 5 km avec
on a on se souvient que la foule est
passée devant la Rotonde
là là les Invalides ont l'air de n'ont
pas l'air de s'embraser alors on parle
donc
et en province hormis donc le classico
Nantes et Rennes classico de l'ultra
gauche rien ne rien n'a bougé le lait
n'a pas débordé de la casserole est-ce
que vous avez vu ces chiffres très
différents ça m'interpelle toujours
alors oui on connaît la différence de
chiffres entre les syndicats et les
ministères de l'Intérieur à Paris
notamment il y a des cabinets
indépendants qui sont parfois plus bas
que les ministres les ministères le
ministère de l'intérieur ça paraît
toujours très étonnant ça paraît comment
on compte les manifestants alors le
ministère de l'Intérieur il a mis en
tout cas il a une
la police ou la gendarmerie une
méthode qui est très simple en fait
c'est que il y a des gens qui comptent
le long du parcours
de boulevard et entre tel born et tel
board il compte x manifestants après ils
essaient de faire une préquation sur la
sur la longueur totale du d'accord il y
a pas quelqu'un qui se met au début de
Place d'Italie et qui hop à chaque fois
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui a un petit peu
c'est un peu compliqué d'autant plus que
là il y avait deux itinéraires et après
ce qui se passe c'est que il y a une
contre-vérification sur les caméras de
vidéos protection qui sont notamment
qui sont à peu près partout dans la dans
la capitale et donc ça permet en fait de
d'avoir une lecture assez fine de de du
nombre de manifestants après parce que
alors là je vous donne les chiffres
aujourd'hui à Paris 500 000 selon
la CGT
87000 selon le ministère de l'Intérieur
55000 selon le cabinet indépendant
occurrence entre nos soi-disent je pense
que le ministère de l'intérieur doit
avoir un chiffre qui me semble en tout
cas 55000 ça me semble vraiment faible
pour le coup 500
000 on peut imaginer que la CGT a tout
avantage à à montrer que la mobilisation
était un franc succès même si quand on
réfléchit il y a toujours un risque
derrière parce que si un acte 3 et oui
plus on a la note plus on met la barre
haute plus après il faut être sur ce
matin quand vous êtes venus Christophe
vous m'avez dit ce cet après-midi de la
CGT pourrait annoncer 2,5 millions de
manifestants oui le chiffre vient de
tomber à 2,8 millions de manifestants en
France selon la CGT ça ne surprend pas
mais ils prennent un risque aussi en
annonçant parce que s'il faut un acte 3
il va falloir qu'il garde un petit peu
de réserve parce qu'ils devront annoncer
3 millions parce qu'autrement si vous
avez une décélération du mouvement
évidemment après une des commentaires
disant que ça s'essouffle et c'est pas
bon Christophe vous êtes descendu parce
qu'il y avait il y a eu des échauffourés
c'était il est à peu près une heure
entre 18h45 et 19h 19h15 nos
journalistes sur place nous l'ont
expliqué notre caméraman a été bousculé
bon est-ce que
ce qu'il s'est passé tout à l'heure
pendant un petit quart d'heure peu faire
ce soir la Une de toutes les chaînes
d'infos est-ce que cela peut déjà
décrédibiliser un peu le mouvement ou
non il ne faut pas exagérer c'est minime
au vu de ce qu'il s'est passé
aujourd'hui en terme de volume et même
le 19 janvier dernier non non a priori
non non c'est pas ce qu'on retiendra de
cette journée de d'action
avec les quelques 260 cordages en France
et le cortège parisien il y a eu
effectivement ces ce quart d'heure un
peu ou un relien de à gauche mais j'aime
beaucoup
plus loin enfin on va on va regarder
jusqu'au bout mais
c'est pas ce qu'on retiendra aujourd'hui
je pense que s'il y avait eu des
dizaines de vitrines brisées s'il y
avait eu des voitures quel ciné comme on
l'a vu il y a il y a 3 ans au moment des
gilets jaunes si on avait vu des
policiers s'enflamme au milieu des rues
on a bien lors des gilets jaunes de
policiers débordés qui couraient qui
jouaient
au chat et à la souris dans les autour
de l'Arc de Triomphe là c'est pas du
tout le cas même si visiblement un
nouveau des des petits débordements on
le voit sur ces images de Julien Leclerc
mais assez vite le calme est revenu
parce que les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues on a vraiment l'impression
que les forces de l'ordre en tout cas je
parle encore plus d'amende à l'heure où
voilà alors on voit les images semble
avoir la totale maîtrise de la de la
situation à Christophe je donne la
parole à Timothée de l'homme qui est
dans les gaz lacrymogènes s'il peut
parler parce que on sait que c'est
toujours difficile Timothée
décrivez-nous ce que vous voyez
expliquer nous ce qu'il nous passe ce
qui ne se passe
alors là Thibault je vous entends très
bien je peux vous parler on est à
proximité des gaz lacrymogènes qui
viennent d'être lancé vous le voyez sur
ces images en direct de Julien Leclerc
en fait ce qui s'est passé là il y a une
charge de dépolla ce sont des policiers
et des CRS qui qui viennent d'intervenir
un homme en fait parce que je vous
raconte ce que j'ai vu avant cette
charge un homme qui était qui était tiré
par terre par qui était-il tiré pour
être tout à fait net je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas vu je n'ai pas cette information et
il y avait un homme qui était tiré par
terre donc une scène de une scène de
tension et et bien les forces de l'or
voilà vous le voyez les tensions
en direct merci
[Musique]
à l'instant
ouais pas de souci Timothée faites
attention
tenez vous à l'écart des problèmes même
si évidemment on aimerait que vous nous
montriez ce qui se passe ça a l'air une
nouvelle fois à Christophe de s'embraser
pendant quelques secondes et puis ça
redescend voilà non mais en fait on va
être sur des sur des épisodes
d'escargots de de gens véhément qui vont
essayer de provoquer d'aller à
l'incident de provoquer les forces de
s'en prendre aux journalistes comme
cette comme c'est devenu l'usage hélas
enfin l'affaire de chaque manifestation
mais là encore on n'a pas l'impression
que il y a des groupes de casseurs
constitués
agissant en nombre pour pour renverser
le le cours de cette fin de
manifestation on est vraiment sur
quelque chose qu'on voit sur le plan
général là on voit que c'est
relativement la place Vauban est
complètement vide il est clair que les
manif c'est toujours là par définition
où ça ça peut ça peut déraper et c'est
là où les journalistes notamment doivent
faire attention est-ce que j'ai vu des
photos avec l'apparition de la brave
est-ce qu'ils ont été utilisés déjà
rappelé nous ce que c'est les brigades
c'est la célébrigade de répression
anti-violente qui sont très mobiles ils
ont très mobiles il y a de souci
alors on veut pas vous me disiez que ça
fait c'est un traumatisme aussi dans la
police dans les Voltigeurs ont été
supprimés après après la mort de Maliko
seki dans en 1986 les braves en fait
c'est il y a deux unités une unités à
pied à moto à moto parce que l'ancien
préfet de police l'allemand était un fan
de moto Harley Davidson
et lui il avait il a tout de suite
compris effectivement l'intérêt de de de
de de de de de de de de transport des
forces à l'arrière d'une moto pour les
projeter de manière extrêmement rapide
sur sur des sur des sur des incidents là
les bras vont les a pas vu en tout cas
moi j'ai pas vu les braves motos
intervenir mais il est une photo de
Sophie de Ravinel d'autres journalistes
politiques qui étaient dans la
manifestation et qui a envoyé une photo
voilà ah mais bon mais c'est possible de
toute façon c'est ce qui est clair c'est
qu'elles sont ils sont les braves sont
dans le discours dans le dispositif
toute de même que les brigades
anti-criminalité en civil et en tenue
sont aussi dans le dispositif mais ils
n'ont pas vocation à à intervenir tant
que il n'y a pas une situation
de dernier recours quoi quand ça tourne
mal alors le dernier il y A E et puis on
l'a vu aussi le dernier l'ultimation en
fait en termes de de maintiendra c'est
le cas dans WoW ah oui alors on l'a vu
vous l'avez vu
on l'a vu un alors il est je sais pas
s'il est s'il est à proximité de de la
place mais je l'ai vu très
impressionnante avec toujours
quand on a des gros problèmes de temps
public la manifestement son usage ne
sera pas ne sera pas nécessaire
que faire des 23 interpellations c'est
ça qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour eux
est-ce qu'ils vont aller parce que c'est
toujours l'une des interrogations
je vous posais la question à Christophe
la dernière fois on connaît ces
personnalités c'est genre violence et
2002 à 3000 casseurs à 3400
comment on peut les connaître et ne pas
les interpeller c'est ça qui m'interroge
qui me fait me poser des questions et
c'est 23 personnes interpellées
qu'est-ce qui va leur arriver maintenant
ce qui va leur arriver c'est que on va
déjà prendre leur identité on va essayer
de voir si on peut
[Musique]
rendre concret leur implication soit par
de l'ADN soit par des images
soit par des témoignages directs par
application dans des faits de violence
et ou de harcèlement contre les forces
ou de dégradation devantalisme et si tel
est le cas de toute façon là je pense
qu'il y a une partie de de ces gens-là
qui va te placer en garde à vue et c'est
au terme de leur garde à vue il a pu
administrer la preuve de leur
implication dans un fait ils seront
présentés en magistrat instructeur et et
un juge en tout cas et ils seront après
soit l'objet d'une comparaison immédiate
amende ils iront pas en prison un
sérieux régime d'un emprison sauf si
évidemment la violence sur force de
l'ordre il faudra qu'ils aient commis
des violences sur les forces de l'ordre
de manière très spectaculaire mais je
crois pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de
policiers blessés aujourd'hui d'accord
on nous direz ça évidemment puisque ce
sont des chiffres qui sont communiqués
également merci beaucoup merci d'être
redescendu nous voir et sauf Cornavin
rédacteur en chef adjoint du service
société spécialiste des questions de
sécurité on retourne voir Timothée
delaime Timothée
fin de manifestation le calme semble
revenir enfin c'est ce qu'on voit nous
sur les images vous êtes dans la
manifestation vous en savez plus que
nous dites nous tout
oui tout à fait Thibault le calme qui
est en train de revenir il y a quelques
scènes de violences ponctuelles qui
durent à chaque fois quelques quelques
secondes comme le disait à l'instant
Christophe cordevin à l'antenne les
derniers camions de syndicats sont
arrivés il y a il y a peut-être 20
minutes maintenant
et les manifestants qui sont qui sont
qui ont quitté qui ont quitté les lieux
il reste ici quelques manifestants
quelques émeutiers des gens qui sont là
pour pour voir en fait ce qu'il se passe
et voilà il y a malheureusement parmi
les manifestants des émeutiers mais pour
le moment voilà l'ambiance est en train
le pardon quand je dis l'ambiance les
tensions sont en train de redescendre
parce qu'elles sont contenues par par
les forces de l'ordre vous le voyez
également sur ces sur ces images de
Julien Leclerc on voit là-bas ce sont
des de nombreux camions
de CRS et bien qui ont bouclé cette
cette place Vauban il y a également un
canon à eau je ne sais pas si vous le
distinguez sur ces sur ces images et
voilà les tensions qui sont en train de
retomber ici avec de la musique de la
musique électro également voilà je vous
dis c'est c'est vraiment
comme un Rhône d'observation et petit à
petit les gens sont en train de de
rentrer chez eux et de et de quitter la
place
merci beaucoup merci Timothée Delem de
nous avoir accompagné tout au long de
cette journée je vous rappelle quelques
chiffres et puis évidemment on restera
avec ces images après Le Figaro live on
fait vivre jusqu'au bout cette journée
de mobilisation cette journée de
manifestation et cette ce cortège
parisien 500 000 personnes dans les rues
de Paris selon la CGT 87000 selon les
forces de l'ordre selon donc le
ministère de l'Intérieur qui a
communiqué tout à l'heure c'est donner
2,8 millions de manifestants c'est le
chiffre avancé par la par la CGT
aujourd'hui
partout en France nous n'avons pas
encore le chiffre du ministère de
l'Intérieur plus de manifestants donc
que lors de la première journée de
mobilisation c'était le 19 janvier
dernier moins de monde faisait grève en
revanche c'est un paradoxe évidemment il
y avait moins de grévistes dans
l'éducation nationale dans la fonction
publique à SNCF et à la RATP et
quasiment dans toutes les autres
filières tous les autres secteurs
notamment celui de de l'énergie quelques
échauffourés ça a eu lieu aux alentours
de 17h 17h45 17h45 18h un quart d'heure
tendu place Vauban à la fin de la
manifestation ambiance électrique ça a
duré un quasiment toute la toute
l'après-midi de 14h à 19h maintenant
18h54 ambiance électrique c'est ce que
nous ont expliqué nos reporters tout au
long de l'après-midi quelques banques
ont été attaquées avec des tags avec des
vitrines brisées pas beaucoup plus et
puis donc ces échauffourés mes
Christophe Cornavin spécialiste des
questions de sécurité nous expliquer que
c'était une fin de cortège somme tout
assez logique que les le la
manifestation du 19 janvier dernier
faisait figure d'exception il n'y avait
eu aucun problème lors de cette
manifestation aucun ou presque je vous
rappelle donc les forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
vraiment vous ne ratez pas à 20h
l'événement le club politique pour
analyser cette journée toutes les
équipes du Figaro du Figaro live autour
pour savoir cette journée de
mobilisation peut changer la donne peut
faire changer d'idées ce gouvernement
qui pour l'instant tient bon Elizabeth
borne l'a dit 64 ans ne sont pas
négociables merci de nous avoir suivi on
reste avec ces images excellente soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a juste un
truc qui fait
nous avons tous
[Musique]